well it is it is 9 A.M uh this is the
house Judiciary Committee
um and I think we um we should uh
get uh we should uh we should get
started I'd like to begin uh by asking
you to stand please and join me in the
Pledge of Allegiance
where is the flag
yeah
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
justice overall
all right I'd like to open the hearing
first on House Bill uh 67 relative to
the right to review source code of
software in criminal cases and is
representative Gallagher here yeah yes
please if you come forward
so
um hello I'm Eric Gallagher
uh representing
Merrimack County district attorney
that's conquered
Ward 6.
which is
down that way
um so I'm here to
introduce
House Bill 67 relative to the right to
review source code of software in
criminal cases so
um
this this bill is part of
what last term
uh I referred to as
the software act which was an acronym
securing our freedom to write and read
everything that was um how spill
one two one nine or wait no no no it
wasn't hold on um it was
um one two seven three
last term
um
so
um yeah it has will
uh 1273 last time was kind of a big
omnibus
bill
um
about securing software freedom
in our state
um
and so that went before
Edna and part of their feedback they
gave
um was that I was trying to do too much
stuff in one bill
so I took that advice to heart and
broke it up into
several smaller pieces so as a result
some of the pieces
are now going to separate committees
like this one
which is coming here to judiciary
so this one is pretty simple
um
it's just
about
the right to review source code
and
criminal proceedings so
um
as computers become more
widespread they're used for more and
more purposes
such as DNA sequencing fingerprint
analysis video processing
so
um
one of the
important things in criminal cases is to
ensure that all the evidence is reliable
as possible to ensure that
we're making the right decisions based
off of it so
um
the way to do that here would be to
provide a right to review source code of
software so this
um
would basically uh codify
a decision
um
by a New Jersey appeals court
so it was the case of Corey Pickett who
was in
a Jersey City shooting in
2017 uh
won the right to
examine the source code of a software
program called true allele to make sure
that the um
make sure that the
DNA testing results that were being used
against him
in trial were accurate
um
so that's the
um there have also been some
um
other court cases where it came to
a similar result of
defendants having a right to examine uh
source code but that's just the um
first of them that I saw and um
the main one that I thought okay this is
a good idea so
um
yeah in the in this case
um it was
uh
proprietary program but
um
one way that uh so if prosecutors are
um worried about oh this could be a
difficult if
um were being asked to reveal uh the
source code of programs that aren't even
ours well that's all the more reason to
shift to
using free and open source
software programs
to generate evidence instead which
is where the source code is already
available and can have been examined
ahead of time
um
so yeah that's the um
two main purposes here one for to sell
greater confidence that all evidence in
our cases is
reliable and to to encourage prosecutors
to use more free and open source
software and
um so with that I'll take any questions
all right questions from members of the
committee yes representative Alexander
thank you Mr chair and thank you um uh
representative Gallagher take my
question
um do you see like there could be a
security concern about this like
especially if we're revealing like a
bunch of State software
um and could it open up to Fabulous
lawsuits that's my question and would
you be open to maybe amending this to
um have you know the right to have an
independent review of the software as
opposed to having the defendant be able
to review every single
um piece of software that's used to
um prosecute them
um
well
all right so that was two questions one
about security so
um first I'd like to um
remind people of the distinction between
data and code
um so there are actually a lot of Open
Source programs out there that store
private data and do so successfully
and the fact that they're open source
actually makes them more secure due to
what's known as The Many Eyes principle
the more people that look at the source
code of something the greater chance
that though that a vulnerability will be
realized and fixed then if only a
certain a select few number of people
are allowed to view it
um
so
um yeah it's it's only about the code
not the data private data would remain
private
um and
then ask for the second question
um about
um
requiring
pending it off to an independent party
to handle the review I guess I'd have to
see the details about that about how
um
how exactly the independent uh
party would be chosen and
um
how they'd report their results and what
they'd publish
um
it sounds that sounds like it would add
some uh complexity to the bill uh the
current way it's written
um I kind of prefer due to the
Simplicity of it but um
if there is a
valid way to
set up
and independent party to review the
source code then I would be open to that
so
I guess my concern is that how far would
we go with this
um and would you be willing to amend to
perhaps Define the scope a little bit
and you know slightly concerned that
this could potentially open up for every
single case for somebody to say you know
even in a misdemeanor case where
somebody was caught on camera stealing
something and then later confirmed you
know using cell phone software that they
were in fact at that location for them
to say well I want to see the source
code of the you know software from the
camera that was used or the security
system as well as Verizon source code
for how they pinpointed on the towers my
location and you know this would be a
minor case where the person had stolen
you know maybe a hundred dollars worth
of stuff and it's only a misdemeanor and
maybe they're using a public defender
and then on both sides the prosecution
and the defense then you know we're
funding for an expert witness
to review this source code so would you
be you know open to perhaps
defining the scope a little bit a little
bit further I I hear what you're saying
about the DNA piece and maybe some of
the pieces where that particular piece
of software is generally used by
you know government entities in order to
prosecute somebody but where something
is not typically used for that purpose
and may be owned by a private company
would you be willing to amend a little
bit
um
well
so as far as the part about
um
it being every single case
I guess I would be
open to
um
some sort of repetitiveness limitation
like if somebody else
if some previous defendant has already
um
has already
requested
um a review of the exact same source
code then I think it should be possible
to just reuse that rather than doing a
new one
um
but um
yeah I um
yeah and um
that that would be the main one I'd be
open to there
thank you
Lorenzo I believe you had a question
okay other questions yes representative
thanks representative Gallagher um I'm
just curious what the if you know what
the current status of
um
this type of issue being raised is in
terms of can evidence currently be
questioned on this basis the the soft of
of suspected uh issues with the
underlying software and I guess sort of
the flip side of that
um if this were put in place is is it
your sense that there'd be the
opportunity to claim insufficient
defense or something like that if you're
if you're your defendant did wasn't able
to examine all the different software
that that was used
so
I'm not a lawyer uh I yeah I don't
practice law and
so um yeah I don't know if this is
something that lawyers have already been
trying to do in New Hampshire
specifically I'm mostly coming at this
from
the software perspective of
um
just trying to
so yeah if um I I don't know about New
Hampshire Court specifically but I think
uh yeah I have seen other cases where
um the
like the um
video
like when where there was a video
recording of something and people were
wondering if it was doctored or not that
came into question but um
yeah I'm not I'm not quite sure about
what the current stat is if that is
under
New Hampshire law
Jersey
and I was wondering if you had the
citation to that case and that you could
provide to the committee and I think you
mentioned there are some other cases and
I would be interested in in Reading
those also if you have them
um yeah well I mean I have the URL
um so yeah I can email that to you
um
uh I
I don't have the um
exact like legal format citation but I
do have like a URL so
foreign
I do have a couple of questions yet
um
is um I guess what I'm wondering is why
why do we need a statute to deal with
this why couldn't I mean presumably in
in cases that where there is some basis
to believe that there's something wrong
with the source code
the the judge would have the power to
order that in a particular case anyway
wouldn't he
um
I mean he or she I should say I mean I
don't know I think having it in statute
would
Grant some greater clarity about whether
that is actually the case or not
um if it is then create then now now
we've at least said so explicitly so
that way people can know in the future
okay can I ask you it's a follow-up
question that the New Jersey case that
you referred to in that case
was there before the court ordered this
access to the source code was there
an allegation in the in that particular
case that there was
you know something was amiss
or did the court just say
you know anytime a criminal defendant
wants the source code he or she can get
the source code
um yeah I'll I'll have to send you the
whole
um
you are also
you can review it um but you know a
second you don't you you can't tell us
now whether that whether there was some
basis in the particular case for the
judge ordering the source code
I mean it's a 74 page ruling here and um
yeah finding that and
the text of a ruling would be would take
more time than we have here I think okay
all right any other questions
all right thank you very much sir
appreciate your testing thanks
keep turning off the mic Melissa Staples
please
foreign
good morning my name is Melissa Staples
I'm the director of the New Hampshire
State Police forensic laboratory and I'm
here testifying a post to this bill
we absolutely agree with the sponsor of
this bill that we want to ensure the
reliability of everything that we do and
this includes not just the software but
the instrumentation the Personnel
everything that we do in the laboratory
because we understand the stakes that
that are resulting from our work
the laboratory is accredited to ISO
17025 an international standard and we
also are bound by the FBI's quality
assurance standards for DNA Testing
Laboratories
and all of these standards that we are
required to follow
involve extensive testing before any
process is used on an item of evidence
so this includes instrumentation it
includes Personnel it includes software
everything in the laboratory requires a
validation process where we test the
processor the new technique or the new
software in many different ways but one
of the most important ways I think is to
use known samples that have an expected
result
and if the software of the instrument is
not giving us that expected result we
need to figure out why is it because the
software is faulty is it because we're
doing something wrong but we want to
ensure in every instance that we're
getting the most reliable and accurate
result possible
oftentimes these samples that we use to
test the software and the
instrumentation are either mistraceable
or certified reference standards
something of that nature where there is
a known result that we should be
obtaining each and every time and we
want to ensure that we're obtaining that
result
repeatedly we don't want to just do one
test and then we're good this is a very
extensive often a month-long process to
ensure that these things are working
properly
in addition to that with every run that
we do with items of evidence we also
alongside the evidence have a control
sample which again is a sample with a
known outcome and so this will also tell
us if anything in our process including
software is providing us the correct
result and only after that control
sample gives us the correct result can
we go on and look at what the result
from the evidence is so we have built-in
insurances that the software or the
instrumentation is working properly
in addition to that on an annual basis
everybody in the laboratory undergoes
proficiency testing and this is a
process where an outside agency provides
us with unknown samples we don't know
what the results are if it's a white
powder we don't know what we're trying
to find out it could be heroin it could
be cocaine it could be fentanyl it could
be meth we don't know
but the Outside Agency does and so at
the end of our testing using our regular
processes we submit our results to the
Outside Agency and they tell us if we
got the right result or not
if we didn't get the right result we
want to go back and figure out what
happened is it an analyst error isn't
the instruments not working properly you
know what happened that we didn't get
the right result but essentially the
software in our processes are being
tested continuously throughout the year
not just at the very beginning when we
start to put it into use but
consistently and throughout its lifespan
because of all of these things I have a
great deal of confidence that our
software is working properly
the controls that I mentioned that are
run with every test are documented in
every case File which is discoverable to
the defense and so there is an
opportunity to review that all the
samples that we're supposed to give a
certain result did and to ensure that
everything was working properly
the many of the software that we use
there is no free and open source
software available for those purposes if
you can think of a free and open source
software that will allow us to bypass
passcodes on iPhones that'd be great
because I would love to not pay for
software to do that every year but the
point is many of these software are
proprietary
and the bill does not give any
protections to these vendors with their
Source codes so that someone else could
not then you know steal that source code
and the concern for the laboratory for
the state might be that some of these
vendors may say you know what this is
opening us up to someone else
essentially copying our software and
we're no longer going to do business
with the state and that would pretty
much bring the laboratory certainly to a
standstill because I'm sure you're aware
a software is ubiquitous today it's used
in almost everything we do and so
opening that up could have very
detrimental effects in a lot of areas in
the state
so thank you very much I'm happy to take
any questions here any questions for our
members committee yes representative
Schmidt
thank you Mr chair
um do you routinely check everything
or is it only when the defendant or the
prosecutor in a criminal case asks you
to check we it's a consistent thing
every every run we do every time we use
software we are checking with a known
sample to ensure it's working properly
so that's something that we want to
ensure happens all the time consistently
so it's not only when a defendant asks
we do our process no matter what no
matter who's asking for what we have
these quality assurance processes in
place because of our accreditation and
because we want to do things right thank
you may I follow up yes absolutely um
and uh in terms of your operation are
you adequately
staffed and
um uh defined budgeted so that you can
respond in a timely way
understanding that Justice delayed is
Justice denied right we understand
but to
really received
received and we do respond to those
typically our standard response is to
provide an entire copy of the case File
which includes the controls the results
of the controls that we run along with
our procedures are freely available as
well that's essentially our cookbook
that we use to test all of our evidence
so those are available so a lot of
things are available on Discovery freely
and openly from the laboratory
if you if you could just answer the last
part are how timely is your response
typically for a standard Discovery like
that typically within a week thank you
very much you're welcome other questions
from members of the committee
all right seeing none thank you very
much thank you
um uh Jeff strelsen please
good morning Mr Shelton welcome thank
you good morning my name is Jeff
strollsen I'm an associate attorney
general at the New Hampshire Attorney
General's office so I oversee the
criminal Bureau
um
could you spell your last name oh sure
it's
s-t-r-e-l-z-i-n thank you you're welcome
uh we're opposing this bill because we
think it's unnecessary there's already a
robust system in place in New Hampshire
that allows the parties to obtain
evidence and contest it for example we
have rules of criminal procedure in New
Hampshire specifically rule 12 that
allows the parties to make Discovery
requests which is request for
information from each other almost all
the time in criminal cases the parties
are able to work out these requests with
each other in the rare instance where
they can't agree the rule allows them to
file a motion with the court and then a
judge decides the issue and decides
whether or not
um the discovery is necessary
there's also significant amount of case
law in New Hampshire
that directly addresses the issue of the
reliability of evidence and generally
speaking lawyers call that Dal bear
cases and what those cases do is they
set out the standards that judges
already use when they examine novel or
new scientific evidence and essentially
if a defendant raises an issue about
something that's novel or new the burden
is then on the state to show that that
evidence is reliable and that typically
involves experts depositions and
hearings before the court so we already
have extensive rules extensive case law
New Hampshire that works extremely well
to address these types of issues which
is why we don't believe that a statute
mandating it in all cases is necessary
because the proposed bill would do away
with the system we already have that
works extremely well and it would allow
a defendant to ask for source code
without limitation
and that would apply to technology which
has been used for decades and for which
there's no there's no legitimate concern
about reliability that would obviously
cause a lot of delay a lot of expense
and again you've heard a little bit
about just some of the things this would
apply to it's ubiquitous if if
detectives sit down and do an interview
with somebody use the digital recorder
that uses software so that a defendant
would be able to contest that software
surveillance systems are everywhere in
businesses and personal homes people
have cameras on their doors cameras
outside all that runs on software a
defendant would then be able to make a
request and contest that cell phones
obviously everybody has a cell phone not
just location data but also photographs
things like that just even making calls
a defendant will be able to contest that
and finally just basic things for
instance in assault rape or murder cases
any medical testing that's done by a
hospital including digital x-rays that
all runs on software that requires
source code so this would open the door
to testing in an unlimited basis and
right now a judge acts as the gatekeeper
in New Hampshire and decides does it
make sense whether to allow this type of
inquiry into scientific testing and
again we already have a robust set of
rules and our rules of chrome procedure
and case law that governs how that's
done so this is simply not necessary
another issue is that
um this would allow unlimited claims
throughout the state no matter how many
times this issue has already been
litigated so again that's going to slow
things down and cost a fair amount as
well
one thing I would like to address is
this the sponsor mentioned about
encouraging prosecutors I think to use
open software so prosecutors don't have
really any choice on what software we
use because this is evidence that's
coming from somewhere else we can't say
for instance to a private company you
need to do something with your Trade
Secrets or your cot you know copyrighted
materials we can't do that we either get
it or we don't and so I took a quick
look at that New Jersey case that was
mentioned one of the reasons that the
company in that case objected was
because the private company it's Trade
Secrets and the solution was that the
material was provided into what's called
a protective order meaning the judge
ordered that that material is provided
but the parties are limited in how they
can use it and how they can share it and
so those are the types of things that
judges can do in these cases to craft a
remedy that satisfies the private
company that's worried that all the work
they put into their software could just
go out to the other side but at the same
time honor the defendant's rights and
give the defendant what he or she needs
in a case and again our system works
extremely well it's set up to do that
but it's important for judges to be able
to hear from both sides consider the
facts of the case and decide what's
appropriate in that case in other words
a one-size-fits all doesn't work in
every case I think one representative
mentioned about for instance in
misdemeanor cases and so you might do
different things in different cases this
statute would take that away and again
it doesn't matter if this is software
that's been used for 30 or 40 years it
would make it would make the state
justify the use of that software even
though we don't have much choice in what
we use and we don't have control over
private companies and their software so
that's generally our objections to this
bill and I'd be happy to answer any
questions that anyone has questions for
members of the committee yes
representative Manos
good morning good morning does
it can if it if it meets the test of in
other words if somebody raises a claim
about its reliability and its novel
scientific evidence it very well could
and that's what happened in the New
Jersey cases true allele it's a it's a
new type of DNA testing
um
it's been around actually for a while
and it's gaining more and more ground
but when it first came out it was brand
new private company and it hadn't been
tested before and that's why it was
getting litigated in these courts and I
did look at a few of the decisions and
the and the courts are saying yep you've
got to provide this software but we'll
protect it with these protective orders
because obviously the company spent
millions and millions of dollars in
years uh putting this together you can
imagine if I reached out to Apple and
said I want your source code for for
your phone they tell me to go pound sand
but there are ways I think that our
court rules and our decisions can
accommodate this and do
other questions
thank you Mr oh I'm sorry representative
De Lorenzo hey go Mr chair thank you for
taking my questions good morning good
morning when we talk about
um evidence and you know how it's
processed I have to think about the
Annie dukin case in from Massachusetts
that was the Massachusetts drug lab
Scandal where the chemists falsified 34
000 drug tests
um does New Hampshire have protections
against that type of thing happening
so first of all that's not a software
issue so that's not what this bill talks
about but generally speaking and answer
your question I know a little bit about
that case I think it goes to what
director Staples talked about which is
the system of checks and balances that
we have the other thing is that in New
Hampshire practitioners in the criminal
side are pretty experienced and
most of us can take a look at stuff and
realize when something doesn't make
sense and then we can consult with other
experts the defense does that as well so
I do think the system of checks and
balances is pretty good in New Hampshire
um I certainly can't guarantee you that
a a single Rogue person can't happen but
again I think you heard from director
Staples about the checks and balances
and having a vigorous well-resourced
criminal bar in New Hampshire which
which we do in many ways helps protect
the rights of defendants in that case
yes absolutely so if the chemist is
using software to analyze her
um you know the drugs that were seized
does that run into this law that we're
looking at today
so this law would say that no matter how
long that software had been around no
matter how well tested it was no matter
how reliable it's already been
established a defendant could challenge
it in every single case
thank you you're welcome other questions
all right seeing none thank you Mr
Shelton thank you for your questions and
let me testify I appreciate it
thank you
um Paul Halverson
good morning I'm Paul I'm Paul Halverson
h-a-l-v-o-r-s-e-n and I'm the Merrimack
County attorney
um attorney strelsen and director
Staples took many of my comments so I'll
just adopt what they had to say uh into
my testimony please and uh only uh
expand on what I wanted to say from some
questions that you had one of the
questions talked about not and attorney
straussen mentioned this about whether
or not this statute if it was an act it
would be over broad I think the answer
clearly is yes you asked that that
question and I sat down when this when I
first read this and did a short list of
um of items that would be affected by
the statute and the list was quite quite
long it included the automatic
fingerprint identification system that's
used at police departments it affected
any phone dump that would generate
evidence in sexual assaults seeking the
software for individual phones internet
crimes against children which I know
someone's going to speak about here in a
few minutes it would affect that the
intoxic 9000 a tried and true item
that's even certified by the federal
government used for years it would
affect the software regarding that any
digital analysis of firearm shell
casings bullets and tool tool marks even
a digital stopwatch that I bet the guy
in the plane uses to time people on on
89 for uh for speeding tickets the
software of that stopwatch with this
legislation could be re could be
requested the most innocuous objects
that we use on a daily day-to-day basis
would be called into question for the
reliability I'm sure many any of us look
at our digital watches for those of you
who have digital watches I'm an analog
guy myself but you look at your digital
watch and works all the time pretty much
and when you look at it that pretty
keeps pretty accurate time it's pretty
accepted item but under this statute the
use of that watch if an officer uses it
in a DWI stop the time part of his field
sobriety testings the software on that
watch could could be requested that
watch was used to generate evidence
against a defendant so is it over broad
you bet do I think that this legislation
is needed I do not attorney straussen
mentioned he used the word gatekeeper
and he also mentioned the gatekeeper in
that New Jersey versus Pickett case
being the individual judge he like I
pulled out our cell phones when Mr
Gallagher mentioned New Jersey versus
Pickett and look that case up in that
case did indeed involve a novel involved
what they at the time when was a novel
approach to an analysis and I didn't go
as much in depth as attorney Charleson
did but the gatekeeper in that case was
the judge attorney straussen mentioned
that we have a robust system here in New
Hampshire and that works very very well
I can tell you about
probably close to 15 years ago now I
litigated a case where the Mr Nelson I
don't mean to interrupt you but I'm just
you know I guess I would ask if you
could move along I was going to ask
others this is my last example all right
thank you I litigated a case with a
source code for the intoxicizer 5000 was
requested and just as attorneys
Charleston said there were appropriate
protective orders took place uh issued
the gatekeeper who was the judge acted
on that issue and ensured that the
individual rights of the defendant were
protected and the individual uh
secrets of the trade the trade secrets
of the company were also protected at
the same time so other than that I'll
defer to uh any of your questions and uh
thank you very much questions from the
committee
seeing none thank you very much and I'm
I'm going to next call uh Stephen uh n
Anders I think I've promised that
correctly
um and again Mr Anders I I want welcome
and we want to hear your testimony I
would just ask if if somebody's already
said something and you know we've we've
probably got it so I'd ask you if you
could try not to repeat things that
other people have said absolutely thank
you the only thing I would add is that I
don't believe the court can order a
third party to reveal their source code
so it essentially would fall on the
state to request the third party to
reveal their source code
um certainly technology companies and
companies writing source code may have
no interest in revealing that
information
which would essentially put the
admissibility of evidence into the hands
of these third parties
that's the only thing I wanted to add if
there are any questions
for this witness can we just get from
where like who you're representing uh so
my name is Steven Andrus my last name is
end res I'm a prosecutor in New
Hampshire I work for the Merrimack
County Attorney's Office I've been a
prosecutor for about 20
some odd years thank you
thank you very much any other questions
from members of the committee thank you
all right uh next uh attorney Anthony
scalabrini
sorry
it's just going Briny welcome welcome uh
thank you your honor um well I'm
representative Lynn please thank you I
have appeared in front of you so many
times as your honor I'm sorry uh Mr
chair thank you for uh giving me the
opportunity to talk
um
I'm here on behalf my name is Anthony
scalambrini
s-c-u-l-i-m-b-r-e-n-e and I'm here on
behalf of the NHA CDL we did not request
this bill or consult with a sponsor but
we are in here in support of this bill
I've been a criminal defense lawyer in
Nashua for 18 years I've appeared in
front of you your honor many times I
worked for the public defender I worked
for Dave goddessman and now I'm in a law
firm uh with a former prosecutor Leslie
Gill
I think that this bill
shows the basic principle that we were
all taught in third grade mathematics
which is show your work and while you
can come up with extreme examples of
things that are mundane that would
require divulging under the source code
I think that we have to realize that all
of this is filtered through how a
criminal case works and some of the
questions that were raised I think go to
that direct issue so representative
Alexander originally spoke about
concerns for protect security we get
information all the time in a criminal
case it's subject to protective order so
that issue is something the courts
routinely deal with and it wouldn't be a
problem representative Alexander also
talked about an independent evaluator
unfortunately the way that the criminal
system works now most of the cases get
the state gets information from the
state lab and then the defense gets that
information and they go out and they
hire an expert to evaluate it so it's
not really an independent evaluator
because they're hired by the defense but
they are somebody that's separate from
the defense apparatus that will look at
it and I can tell you that most good
defense lawyers go and find their expert
with one guiding principle tell me what
the science says don't tell me what you
think I want to hear tell me what the
science says and so to the extent that
that's how the system works it is sort
of getting to your idea about the
independent evaluator you also mentioned
frivolous lawsuits one thing that you
should all be aware of and I think most
of you are is that prosecutors have
basically absolute immunity under the
doctrine of prosecutorial immunity and
police and other state workers have
immunity under the qualified immunity
Doctrine which is difficult to pierce
and I can't think of a scenario in which
failing to develop source code would
constitute grounds for a lawsuit because
you'd also have to prove damages and
damages would mean that the person would
be innocent but for the source code
divulging and it's it's very complicated
to Envision a scenario where that would
happen the other thing that I want to
bring to the committee's attention is
that as the criminal justice system
develops and responds the increases in
technology we have cases that are
essentially given to these black boxes
and the black boxes tell us guilty or
innocent now there are other things that
you can do to challenge the
admissibility of the evidence but in
cases like possession of child
pornography in cases where DNA is
important in cases where you have to do
evaluations of skid mark analysis and
car accidents you know and the DWI cases
mentioned before in drug identification
cases
oftentimes the case comes down to what
does the machine tell us
and if we don't know how the machine
tells us that how can we be sure that is
reliable and the example I want to give
is a pretty simple one a long time ago
in the 1960s they developed something
called the modified Duke noise test and
it was a way of detecting drugs you put
a little bit of the drugs in a tube the
tube had a reagent in it the reagent
interacted with the drugs and It
produced the color then you match the
color on a chart and it told you what
the drugs were well later many many
years later as scientists were
evaluating the validity of some of these
modified duquinoise tests that were
designed for use on the street they
found that marijuana was a cross
indicator with two things that are
relatively common coffee grounds and
essence of sandalwood and these are
things that I mentioned as an example of
why we need to be able to have access to
these basic fundamental parts of these
black box machines that determine guilt
or innocence if we can't be sure that
they're working right then we can't be
sure that the conviction is right and I
think the fact that we have a system
where we get to ask these questions is
really important but having this statute
would make sure that the courts are
aware that this is something we need to
take notice of your honor uh Mr chair
the couple of things that you had asked
uh the New Jersey case I think Attorney
Charles had mentioned the big issue was
because it was a novel issue and a novel
way of testing they had not fully gone
through the Delbert analysis and so that
is why the court authorized the release
of the source code you would also ask
why do we need a statute and I think
that the reason why we need a statute is
largely because we need to have people
take notice and be cognizant of the role
these technological black boxes play in
determinations of guilt or innocence
some defense lawyers know some
prosecutors know some judges know that
these things are real but there are also
places where you know in the hubbub and
hustle of a court room which you
remember very well it may not be on the
front of somebody's mind to say hey what
what is the mechanism that this thin
layer chromatography machine at the
state lab uses to determine the Peaks
that show this is a chemical of one sort
or another and if we have a statute not
only does it give the defendant the
ability to Avail themselves of that
right it also puts it in people's mind
this is something we should be looking
at attorney straussen who have a great
deal of respect for it I should tell you
I've known all the prosecutors here that
have testified I have a great deal of
respect for all of them and many of
their points are correct one thing that
he mentioned that I want to point out is
that it allows a challenge in every case
that's not what the language of the bill
says the language of the bill simply
says the defendant shall have a right to
examine
bringing that challenge later on is
something that would be made between the
lawyer and the client and I think that
the division of labor and the
ineffective assistance of council area
shows that it is the lawyer that would
ultimately decide to make the challenge
so it is not the case that by passing
this bill a challenge would arise in
every case where there is a bit of
technology used at least that's not the
language that's used here
um
there were a couple other points uh
uh I believe it was representative Manos
you were looking for the citation for
State versus Pickett it is uh 466 New
Jersey super 270 it's a 2021 case
uh and
um I think that one of the
representatives I think it was
representative Turner brought up the
issue of ineffective assistance of
counsel and I think that this is
probably the most cogent problem with
the bill but I do think that there is a
workaround that is Incorporated in how
these cases are processed that makes it
a non-issue so if you have a defendant
who is particularly obstreperous and
decides that he wants to challenge the
source code on you know the digital
watch for the guy that pulled him over
for speeding he's going to do that no
matter what it's going to happen whether
his lawyer tells him no or not it's
going to happen no matter what and so
the idea that this would cause a bunch
of new challenges is probably not the
case because most of the time they're
filtered through the lawyer and in the
cases where the defendant and it's so
obstreperous that he doesn't listen to
his lawyer he's going to slow down the
process no matter what we do whether
this bill exists or not but in terms of
ineffective assistance of counsel the
standard to prove an effective
assistance of counsel is so high that
the scenarios in which non a non-request
of the source code constitutes an
effective assistance of counsel are
vanishingly small if not impossible for
me to conceive of is it theoretically
possible in a million years that
somebody could figure out a scenario yes
is it likely given how high the standard
is in an effective assistance of
councils this cases the answer I think
is unequivocally no and so I think that
the committee should support this bill
this bill just goes to the fundamental
basic fairness of show your work it is
not unduly burdensome and because of the
protective order I think that we would
be able to meet the concern the private
companies would have about divulging
source code that they worked on for
years to produce if anybody has any
questions on questions uh yes
representative Bruce
thank you sir thank you Mr chair for the
for the uh for coming and for taking
their questions is this bill
establishing a new right or does a
defendant already have a right and this
bill is just declaring that they do in
fact have this right that's it's not
just a uh
inside baseball kind of thing
so I will tell you as a defense lawyer I
would love the answer to be this is just
codifying a right the defendants already
have but I think that the problem is and
why this bill would be important is the
area of source code knowledge is such an
esoteric fine point that even if they
have this right I'm not sure how many
people Avail themselves of it in the
same way that we've had a right to
privacy before The Constitution in New
Hampshire was amended based on both
state and federal law putting that into
language and putting that into writing
helps people understand what their
rights are so I think that we already
have this right the problem is I'm not
sure how many judges would agree with me
other questions
thank you very much Mr scombre
thank you manager Mr chair
um detective uh Wade brown
good morning chairman Lynn members of
the committee my name is Wade brown
brown spelled like the color I'm a
detective at Concord PD I'm here as a
member of the New Hampshire icac which
is internet crimes against children task
force our commander is out on a active
case this morning so I'm here in his
place we obviously oppose this bill for
reasons that have been mentioned the
only thing I'll add is when we are
investigating child sexual abuse
material or csam as we call it that
typically comes from one of these tech
companies such as Google Facebook
Microsoft discovering these images or
these videos on their servers and then
turning them over to neck Mac the
national Center for missing and
exploited children ultimately they track
an IP address and determine that the
crime occurred in New Hampshire and it
gets assigned out that way my point is
is that these are tech companies that
are used by the general public so it has
nothing to do with what the government
uses as far as forensic software or
other operating systems this this is
what the public uses to make these
transactions and this legislation would
clearly open up that source code for
these as it generates evidence so we'll
clearly open that up to any defendant
charged with a crime that involves one
of those tech companies we cannot
force them to use open source they're
going to use Facebook they're going to
use Google and to expect any of those
companies to turn over source code to
assist us is not realistic and would
create a loophole that anyone any good
defense attorney would seek to exploit
oh that's all I have if there's any
questions thank you questions for this
Witness
thank you very much detective thank you
um I don't have any other cards is there
anyone else who wishes to testify
regarding HB 67.
all right seeing none I'm going to close
the hearing on HP uh
I'm sorry I'm now going to turn to house
bill 68.
um
and
I will recognize uh representative
Edwards
yes okay oh great thank you
thank you
foreign
Edwards welcome uh
thank you Mr chair I uh I'm uh
representative Jess Edwards of
Rockingham District 31 that's Auburn
Candia Chester and Deerfield I'm here
today to
introduce House Bill 68 FN to you
representative Mark McLean is also a
co-sponsor on this bill he introduced a
similar Bill last year that that did not
succeed uh I the reason I'm I got
involved is because my next door
neighbor in Auburn
caught me while I was out pretending to
mow the lawn and do weeds and uh and
start talking me up about this she's an
older woman who's lost her husband a few
years ago and has grandkids and stuff in
the area so she got to be very concerned
about and got to be very familiar with
what it takes to as a single person to
transfer property upon death and so this
bill took model legislation OLS took the
model legislation and then tailored it
to New Hampshire the problem it's a 10
thing to solve is that for anyone
going through the process of setting up
your estate
can be take take a lot of time can be
very complex can be very costly and even
for people who should be able to do it
fairly easily because they have sort of
the
background to be able to read the legal
documents and understand it it can be
difficult when my wife died I needed to
do this
to make sure that my kids could get the
property and and so I consider just
doing it in a will that created a
probate potential probate situation I
considered
doing it in a trust and that's what I
ended up doing I started with one
attorney
and I I just had so much avoidance
because the document was about 50 pages
thick to do a trust
and it costs thirty five hundred dollars
so I just couldn't like you know
approach it and I can't imagine I'd be
the only one like that well you know
finally I did uh get it done I have a
trust it's about 50 pages thick it cost
me about thirty five hundred dollars
um and uh and so that's taken care of
now the limitations of that trust
um are still that it doesn't do a lot of
things that a normal person needs done
it transfers my real property but all of
my financial accounts which is really
the my estate the property and the money
each of those has to be done
independently with the financial
institution and some sort of an
arrangement with them declaring your
beneficiaries so so even though a trust
can be expensive it's still relatively
incomplete what this proposes is instead
filing a single little sheet front and
back the front is the form the back or
the typical questions and answers so
this is intended for those people who
you know probably the most common
scenario is they were married they had
their property in joint tenancy the
partner dies they need to worry about as
a single person what are they going to
do with that property this this would be
a simple way of doing it
um
let's see
okay so as I was flipping through this I
noticed in the fiscal note that there
seems to be a concern on the County's
part about whether or not there this
could have a financial impact the
financial impact if there is one is not
stated I I know that uh uh the
outstanding uh Register of Deeds from
Rockingham County is here to testify and
talking to her briefly several months
ago she was not a immediately amenable
to this and so I I have to be in my
hearing at 10. I'd love to stay and
stick around but I would say whatever
she says if we need to like add some
sort of attacks on a transfer on death
deed to keep the counties whole I I I'd
be fine with that because I know
compared to thirty five hundred dollars
to pay an attorney for a trust
paying the county a smaller a much
smaller amount in order to process a
transfer on death form is still in the
best interests of of our citizens so so
with that
um I'd be open to questions if there are
any questions remember yes uh
representative Anderson
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question representative
Edwards my only drawback on this and I'm
you can see I'm older and
my husband and I are trying to get
things together
is the people that might be exploited
how do we get around that
I you know I don't have an answer to
your question the exploitation is just
deeply embedded in our society and and
there's you know a caveat and tour
everywhere uh I I would I would hope
that uh if this uh committee supports
this bill you can either figure some
little codicil in there in an amendment
or jail car could figure something out
or that you know once it got to the
registrared Deeds people like you know
um Miss Stacy would have a great idea I
think that's a valid concern but uh keep
in mind that the point of this is to
make it much less expensive much simpler
and save a lot of time for each of our
citizens and with that benefit that with
that reward yes I can see some
incremental risk
other questions yes representative Perez
thank you
um I just have a question about this
would this eliminate having to go
through probate
that's the goal I mean this would this
is this is a dumb thing to do if it
doesn't uh bypass uh the probate
requirement uh and would it
if if you had an irrevocable trust
would this supersede an irrevocable
trustee in my case I could have done
this instead of an irrevocable trust I
went ahead and did an irrevocable trust
it cost me thirty five hundred dollars
it don't it only did uh my my my real
property my house basically uh it did
not do my financial accounts I had to do
those independently so this is meant to
be an alternative to a irrevocable trust
there would still be those people who
would benefit from having an irrevocable
trust instead of a simple transfer on
death this would just create an option
for those people who have a simpler
estate planning requirement but it could
be done in addition to that probably as
well to verify perhaps trust I I don't
know I I think that might actually raise
um
another issue with which document if
they are in conflict in any way which
one would be Supreme to the other I I I
don't know that's a question I didn't
anticipate thank you representative
Smith
thank you very much Mr chair first in
out of respect for my colleague
representative Edwards I hope no one
takes seriously his suggestion that um
we manage it with attacks I don't think
he liked that quote in any place else
but I'm teasing representative
for the record taxation is theft
[Laughter]
[Music]
um but representative Edwards if I
recall correctly one of the questions
that arose last year when this was
before this committee
was that
um it might very well be that the
recipient of your largesse might not be
interested for example it might be a
property
um where there is
um involved some
um
uh
representative Lorenz is trying to help
me I said in conferences thank you it's
a good catch our word summon coverages
for example if it is property physical
property that had been condemned in some
way and would require extensive
expenditures in order to get it up to a
legal standard
or if it had in fact there was a lot of
debt involved in that and to have
um property
given to you without you having agreed
to accept it might create
some problem did you think of that as a
wrinkle okay so I think it wrinkles a
lot these days uh for what it's worth
but uh I I would say there are two
different ways that to respond to that
one one is I'm not an attorney I don't
deal in a state law but I suspect uh
what the problem you're raising is not
so dissimilar to somebody leaving you
property and a will it's still got to be
worked out on whether or not you want to
accept the property and and two the if
there's not an ability in this model
legislation to refuse the grant of the
property then I I think that would be
something that could be addressed
yeah thank you other questions yes
representative Turner
uh just a quick question are you aware
of anywhere else that this is a process
like this has been adopted and
implemented and what the experience has
been if so that that is an excellent
question and and I'm gonna have to tell
you I don't I can't cite you today where
this has been adopted I I will say that
it has been adopted in other states I
think the number is about six or seven
and it is model legislation so it's
floating around and available to any
state to you know try it out for size
so I can
try to get you an answer to that
question and I'm sorry I can't see your
name from here it's Eric turr t-u-r-e-r
okay and I'll I'll give it probably to
uh your Clerk or your Vice chair sure no
that's that's fine okay that's fine
other other questions for yes uh
representative Manos
thank you
um
I'm not
depending why
in the situation of your neighbor she
couldn't just retitle the property on
her husband's death why she couldn't
just retitle the property in the name of
the children her and the children or
whoever else she wanted to have on the
deed why why do we need this statute I
mean clear so that that's that's a
really good question I I in my
experiences I went through this going
talking to the attorney that helped me
with my irrevocable trust
um the uh down potential downsides of
doing that transfer of the deed
prior to your own death
are involved in sort of the potential
you know corrupting influences of the
property and whether or not you would be
allowed to continue to live in your own
property and and and that and that sort
of thing and so that so I don't know if
that was the marketing to get me to go
ahead and buy a irrevocable trust
package versus going to see Miss Stacy
to you know figure it out uh in another
way
so that's a good I hopefully she'll
address that in her testimony
other uh yes representative divine
thank you
um my question refers to there's there's
a a line on page six
um
it down the number eight
where it says you may not revoke the
transfer on death Deed by Will
so is that to say if you did this and
then you changed your mind and you set
up a will after the fact
it wouldn't hold up in court
an excellent question for an attorney
that does estate law I I do not and so I
don't want to venture other than to say
this is this is model legislation that
OLS uh tailored to read New Hampshire if
that's an issue and and let's say it is
it it probably does need to be addressed
in some way you know I represented I I
don't think it is and I think that there
are there are if you in the statute
there are ways in which you can revoke
the the you know that if you make the
transfer you you you prepare the deed to
make the transfer on death but then you
change your mind there are ways that you
can you can reverse that this just says
that one of the ways is not by a will
you have to do it while you're still
something that becomes effective before
you die and and that's also in this
document the way in which you can uh
revoke uh this transfer on death it's in
it's in there any other questions uh for
representative representative I know
you're you've got to go and I I don't
want to hold you up one but I just have
one question and I wonder if you've
thought about if if you know the answer
to this one of the things I saw on page
uh the first page is it it says in in uh
on line 30 that transfers on a transfer
on Def deed is non-testamentary and I
guess my only question is do you know
what what the tax implications of this
would be under Federal in other words
generally under federal law if you
something that you leave by inheritance
the person who gets it gets what's
called a stepped up basis they get their
basis in the property is the value of
the property on the date of death
I think that's based on the fact that it
is a testamentary transfer and so I'm
wondering
if if this would have a tax disadvantage
if somebody utilized this and I don't
know whether you know the answer or not
and I don't know the answer I'm just
really asking
if I I I'm just learning how to spell
the word uh so I I'm not prepared to
provide a a legal response of tax
implications so all right well if I know
thank you I think it's something we need
to think about but other questions for
this Witness
all right thank you very much
representative thank you
I'm gonna next call on
um Elise uh
uh Sally is that if saley I'm sorry uh
Miss Haley please
good morning
is that on thank you good morning my
name is Elise salik last name s-a-l-e-k
I'm a member of the trust and Estates
bar here in New Hampshire and I've been
practicing about 30 years
um I can answer some of the questions
that have been raised so I welcome those
questions after I'm done with my
testimony but just by way of background
I want to let you know that last year
when Senate Bill 43 was introduced which
was the initial version of a transfer on
death deed statute I testified against
that statute and that is not because I'm
at all philosophically opposed to
transfer on death Deeds I actually think
that they are a good idea and they would
be a welcome addition to my toolkit as
an estate planner and I totally agree
with the testimony of Representative
Edwards on the issue of having this
transfer on death deed available to
folks who otherwise do not have a
complicated estate plan do not need the
services of a trust in a state's lawyer
to help them pass their property at
death so I think transfer on death Deeds
are something that we ought to have here
in New Hampshire and I know one of the
representatives asked how many states
have enacted similar legislation the
answer is approximately 29 and so
certainly there is a track record for
this sort of legislation in other
jurisdictions
and I just wanted the members of this
committee to know that last year when
the initial transfer on death deed bill
was proposed a number of trusts and
States practitioners here in New
Hampshire myself included got together
and took a look at that legislation we
had a number of questions and issues
with that legislation so over the past
eight months we as a group have been
working on improvements to last year's
Bill and so we were taken a little bit
by surprise to find that a new Bill had
been proposed in this session uh the
bill that we're discussing today and I
have to say that the new bill that's
been proposed is a huge improvement over
what was proposed last year and so what
we myself and members of our drafting
tne legislative committee would like to
do is to have an opportunity to speak to
the sponsors of
hb68 to sort of work with them to
improve this piece of legislation so I
just want to highlight a couple of
issues that I see as a tne practitioner
with the bill that's on the table today
with a view towards improving it so that
we do end up with a very good transfer
on death deed statute here in New
Hampshire so just by way of example
um disclaimer representative Smith you
are concerned about what to do in a
situation where a parent
transfers on death via one of these
transform identities a piece of property
to a child and that child doesn't want
it and that may be because the child has
tax problems it may be because the
property is contaminated and has you
know underground storage tanks there are
a number of reasons why people who are
gifted property don't want to accept it
this bill addresses that issue there is
a provision in
house bill
2068 that says that you can disclaim
your interest you don't have to accept
what people leave you via transfer on
death deed
but the only problem with the
legislation as it's currently structured
is that there's no notification
requirement and so as someone who's been
in the trenches working on these issues
for 30 years what I can tell you is
oftentimes parents want to leave assets
to children and especially if it's an
asset like a piece of property
those children may not be notified for
some period of time that they're
actually the recipients of this piece of
property and both under New Hampshire
law and under federal law you have a
nine month deadline to disclaim and if
you're the lucky recipient of Grandma's
contaminated property and no one tells
you that and there's no notification
requirement in the bill
then you're stuck with it because you're
going to miss your nine month disclaimer
deadline so at the very least the bill
that's currently on the table should be
modified to include some sort of
notification requirement so that people
who are recipients of property via
transfer on death deed are notified that
they've been given the property and then
have a proper opportunity to walk away
if this turns out to be something they
don't want so that's an improvement that
could be made to the statute and there
really should be made to this statute
one of the other issues I have with this
bill posed and it's not surprising
because this comes from the uniform act
and is anyone you know who practices law
will tell you there's nothing uniform
about how New Hampshire Works versus
Maine versus California or some of these
other jurisdictions so every one of
these uniform acts when proposed does
have to be tinkered with so that it
doesn't sort of work in opposition to
some of the state's existing laws so in
particular the issue here one of the
issues I have with this bill and again
there's a solution is the Creditor claim
period so if I own a piece of property
and I just want to pass the property to
my kids and I don't want to bother doing
will so I want to do this simple process
of transfer on death deed I can do that
and I should have the ability to do that
however everyone dies with creditors I
have yet to meet a single client who
died owing nothing there's always the
last credit card bill there is always
the bill from the oil delivery that just
got made two days before your death
there are medical bills there are always
everyone dies with unpaid bills
if you've managed to transfer your
property on death instantly to your
children
what are your creditors going to do if
they need to be paid all your assets are
gone you named your kids in your bank
accounts everything walks out the door
and the poor creditors are left holding
the bag
there's a provision in this bill that
deals with creditor claims however
it doesn't comport with our current
probate laws
so one of the other issues that we need
to address and again there's the
solution to this problem is to make sure
that unpaid bills have a way to be paid
if real estate is the last or only asset
and it's already walked out the door and
the problem with this legislation as
proposed is that it doesn't mesh with
our current probate statutes and with
the time limits that we currently have
under New Hampshire law for filing
claims against the estate of a dissent
so the current deadline in New Hampshire
is a six-month claim period and a
12-month claim period but all claims
have to be presented in the probate
process in 12 months what the current
proposed legislation what hb68 says is
you have 18 months
well if the last of this statute says
you've got 18 months to present your
claims but the probate statute says you
only have 6 or 12. I think that's a
problem that needs to be fixed so again
there's a solution to the problem and it
doesn't mean we have to throw this
legislation out but there are aspects of
this that just don't comport with New
Hampshire law
the other thing that I just want to
point out and this is something that's
not addressed in our statute and I don't
know how to deal with it
is the issue of title companies
so
if I want to leave my property to my
kids via one of these transfer of death
deeds and I die and my kids inherit the
property that's all well and good
that transfer does not come with any
warranty covenants that's what this bill
provides and I think that's the right
answer
however if my kids have inherited this
property and want to turn around and
sell it the next day and the person
they're selling it to needs Bank
financing there isn't a title company
that will ensure title
and that's because
the transfer on transfer on death deed
doesn't come with any warranty covenants
so that's an issue that has to be worked
out and I just want this committee to be
aware that when Maine passed its
transfer on death deed statute a couple
of years ago they did not address this
issue and it caused an enormous amount
of strain on local title companies there
are title companies now that no longer
write title or underwrite at all in the
state of Maine because of Maine's
transfer on death D statute so before we
finalize the statute I think we need
buy-in from the title insurance
companies to make sure that we're not
creating Title Insurance problems with
respect to real estate
representative Schmidt thank you Mr
chairman Mr chairman this is a question
for you the witness began by saying that
she would want to go back to the
sponsors to see about uh changes but as
you well know
um this bill is now in our hands it is
no longer in the hands of the sponsors
and so it's up to us to do something is
this a bill where it might make sense
uh for you to create a subcommittee to
look at uh the language and uh potential
ways of improving The Language by
by seeking
um I'm someone subjecting to what I'm
saying oh dear
um uh and obviously by seeking
involvement from uh those people who are
involved professionally in this area to
see if we can address some of the
questions and come up with Solutions
before the full committee discusses and
votes on the bill uh sure what you know
I'm completely open to that what I what
I was wondering though would it make
would it would it make sense and perhaps
shorten the process if we asked I mean
can I just ask you how how close are you
to having
you know sort of a final version that
would fix the problems you've identified
we're probably within 30 days uh we have
a meeting this Friday and a meeting on
Friday the 27th of our drafting
committee we've been working on this for
eight months so I think we're quite
close so I I you know I what I what I'd
love to do maybe is we could if what
rather than hold up the witness if we
could talk about I'm perfectly open to
to either you know doing a subcommittee
or maybe just saying we won't exec this
bill until we've all until we all have
the until we have the the uh the version
that you've you've talked about because
I it seemed to me anyway that you've
you've identified very real problems
that we ought to that we want you know
we want to address we have and I think
there is a solution and our committee as
a whole feels as if this is a good idea
for the citizens of New Hampshire but we
don't want to pass a bill that
inadvertently creates problems for our
title insurance companies our bankers
and for the recipients of these
properties
thank you a question we have a number of
questions representative tur
re oh yeah thanks
um uh represent Edwards uh pointed out
that he's not a Texan uh attorney
um I was wondering if you had any uh
thoughts on
um chairman Lin's question regarding
changing the basis uh I do okay I
actually have the answer to that
question I'm glad I have the benefit of
of being a tax attorney as well as an
estate planner so I feel fairly
confident in the answer so the answer to
your question representative Lynn is yes
the property would receive a step up in
basis at death and that's because by
Nature by by the virtue of the fact that
the transfer doesn't occur until the
death it means that the owner of the
property remains in control of the
property until that death and that's
enough to qualify for basis step up so
the answer is yes right other questions
yes representative divine
thank you
um my question has to do with fraud in
getting into you know the deeds and has
there been a problem in New Hampshire
for fraud and is that growing with
the Deeds being transferred or prior to
transfer that's a great question and I
don't want to step on uh attorney
panabianco's toes because he was going
to address this issue but an answer to
your question is we don't have a
transfer on death deed statute so I I we
obviously don't have a problem with this
particular issue but we do absolutely
have a problem in New Hampshire with
fraud and duress and undue influence
with respect to wills and trusts
demographically we are an older State I
see people trying to take advantage of
my elderly clients and I don't like it
so
there are ways to address that issue in
this bill and attorney Upon A Bianca
we'll talk about that because we as a
legislative drafting committee have
addressed that issue in some of the new
language that we propose adding to this
bill so yes it's a real issue and it has
to be dealt with and we need to protect
our older citizens from fraud thank you
representative representative Alexander
thank you Mr chair there's some more
question just to um pivot off of
Representative Smith but is this an
early bill or can we choose to
um no this is not this is not early bill
so the committee has the ability to hold
off and wait until the experts kind of
get right okay perfect thank you
other questions for this Witness
thank you very much it's been very
helpful thank you
uh next
um
we have a
uh Michael uh panabianco
thank you Mr chairman uh committee uh as
anything my name is Michael panabianco
I'm a trust in the state's tax attorney
I live and work in Concord New Hampshire
and for many years I was an Adjunct
professor at uh Franklin Pierce law
school where I taught Wills trusts and
Estates I'm here on my own behalf as
attorney salik indicated there's a
committee of attorneys that have been
working the past eight months on
improving this bill I'm one of the
attorneys on that committee I agree with
everything that attorney salic has
already testified on and I'm not going
to repeat that here but I want to say
that I am in agreement with what she
already said a couple of things that I
wanted to add and one of which she
alluded to was the idea of how do we
deal with fraud and and challenges to it
so the current statute does not address
challenges to whether or not the
transfer on death deed is valid one of
the provisions that we've added into
this bill somebody has the ability to
challenge the validity of the transfer
on death D just like somebody could
challenge the validity of a will after
the person has died so there are some
mechanisms by which we're putting into
what we're working on to address and
counter potential fraud for transfer on
death Deeds
one of the other one of the other things
that the bill does not address that
we're addressing and what we've been
drafting is whether or not and to what
extent an agent under a power of
attorney
or a court appointed Guardian can create
a transfer on death deed for the person
who owns the property or revoke a
transfer on death deed that's not
addressed in the current bill we're
looking at how to make that work with
New Hampshire law uh to make sure there
is that option and under what
circumstances that can be done
so I agree that this would be a great
addition uh to our toolkit as eternally
salic said as an option for the clients
where it's appropriate
um so I am in agreement philosophically
with having a transfer on death deed
Statute in New Hampshire but it needs to
be revised as as attorneys say like
indicated and as I've indicated here as
well I don't want to take up the
committee's time uh but I'm welcome to
any questions that you may have
questions for attorney Bianco
you know what I just have one question
do you agree with attorney is 30 days a
realistic do you agree that the 30 days
is about a realistic time for for your
group to get back to uh this committee
with with your you know your draft so to
speak I do as she indicated we have a
couple of meetings already calendared to
do it we were we were close before the
holidays
um on getting it done so we are very
close to to that so I think 30 days is
realistic okay great thank you all right
thank you very much I just see no other
questions thank you thank you
um I'm going to call on uh Kathy Stacy
good morning
Mr chairman members of the committee my
name is Kathy Stacy I'm the Rockingham
County Register of Deeds I'm the
legislative chief of the New Hampshire
Association of counties
um I'm speaking I'm not going to
reiterate we we have I've given you some
written testimony with regards to
issues that we see with the bill we're
not in opposition to the bill I mean I
think it's I think it would be uh
a wonderful opportunity for people we
just have questions about some of the
terminology or the lack of terminology
and and
um
obviously we're looking to see if uh you
know and I'm thankful that these members
from the bar got up and spoke because
there are I think a lot of issues with
this I had spoken with representative
Edwards over the summer about it in
hopes that some of the some of these
things would be addressed but they
obviously were not
the bottom line is the Registries of
deeds will record whatever we're told to
record so long as it obviously meets the
statutory requirements but we have no
issue with that whatsoever
um the um I will tell you that the state
of Maine enacted this two years ago and
when I've spoken with a couple of the
registrars up there they said the
biggest challenge that they have and
they're they they're having to entertain
is that a lot of times you know just
like in New Hampshire a lot of people
want to do their own paperwork
doesn't mean it's done right doesn't
mean it's done wrong and
um what they see is a lot of people
coming in doing transfer on death deeds
and within a week two weeks three weeks
they come in they're revoking
and then they because maybe they get
into an argument with whoever they're
transferring it to but they see this is
a lot of repetitive stuff that they see
here in Maine and
um you know the the question
becomes how how is it reported or not
reported to the towns because one of the
things in New Hampshire is any deed that
gets recorded gets obviously transferred
to each community
and so I mean there needs to be some
type of an education piece I think for
the assessors here in the state to make
sure that they realize that these Deeds
go on record but they do not become
effective until the person actually dies
or revokes you know and you know you've
got certain mechanisms but they're not
really listed in this in the legislation
and there need to be protections for
people the other thing is
um
I had questions about the terminology
when we talk about lapses and what
lapses and how how certain things affect
joint tenants versus a single owner I
just think that there needs to be more
specification and I'd love to see what
is being proposed by this group
um that probably will address all of
these issues because they would
understand but the big one of the
biggest issues and they're absolutely
correct is you have title companies who
will not uh title insurance companies
will not ensure over these transfer and
deaf deeds and that's a big problem
because you'll have people who may
inherit on obviously get the get these
properties and then what what are they
going to do with it if they can't
mortgage it what are they going to do
with it if there's a if there's a
mortgage on the property it needs to be
paid off and they can't utilize that
property you know to uh
you know get another mortgage
so a lot a lot of questions with regards
to the bill but you know again the
register the registrars are ready to
record anything that you you're telling
us so long as they you know it complies
with the statutes
thank you questions representative Smith
uh yes thank you would you be willing um
to work with the attorneys who are
trying to answer the questions that have
been raised about this legislation
absolutely yes yes and I'm a New
Hampshire attorney as well so yes I've
been more than happy pleased to hear
that
um in that case Mr chair it does seem
clear that there are a lot of people out
here who are sympathetic to the premise
of the legislation
recognizing a need to refine the
language and it is seems ideal that
those people with specific knowledge
would work on it before it comes back to
us for us to consider
um
improvements sure no I I agree
completely I agree thank you very much
are there other questions for this
Witness
thank you thank you very much Ms Dixie
anyone else who is interested uh who
desires to testify on um HB 68.
seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on that bill and we'll turn to
the hearing on um HB 290
um
and the prime sponsor representative
chamburn is not available uh he's he is
ill today but uh fortunately we have
representative Alexander who will
introduce the bill for us perfect thank
you Mr chair members of the committee
for the record my name is representative
Joe Alexander out of Goffstown
um I'm just here to introduce the bill
on my friend's behalf from Seabrook um
he's not feeling well today
um so I'm just going to read his
testimony and refrain from questions and
my support office to the bill
um because I'm not sure yet so um HB 290
he just wrote several police agencies
are considered constables or ex-officio
under the New Hampshire statute they
include State Police conservation
officer legislative security police
officer and two of these are statutory
statutorily barred from serving civil
process that's the state police and
conservation officer
um
HB 187 will also be heard later today
that has to do with this as well so I
think we're getting multiple bills about
this subject matter
um but we're being asked to change the
police chapter of the statute to allow
civil serving process uh by a police
officer so HB 290 does the same thing by
changing the statute relative to
Constable found in the sheriff and
constables chapter currently a constable
may only serve writs to them
um directed wherein the amount of
dispute is 75 or less so by removing
that monetary restriction we allow
Constable or a police officer to serve
all Ritz that are currently reserved
solely for service by Sheriff or deputy
sheriff
so with that I'm just reading the
testimony so I won't be taking questions
all right thank you thank you
representative Alexander
um
we uh is there anyone else here who uh
desires to testify on HB 290.
seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on HB 290
and open the hearing on HB 162.
and
um
represent Representatives Mooney or
representative
okay
um
is there something I guess I should say
who is here to introduce the bill
oh great all right we'll we'll we'll
take a maybe we'll take uh a two-minute
stretch break if that uh makes sense
sort of
uh we're back in uh session and um we're
gonna now uh open the hearing on HB
162 and I'll recognize representative
Mooney uh to introduce a bill
thank you very much Mr chairman and good
morning to members of the committee for
the record my name is representative
Maureen Mooney from the town of
Merrimack Hillsborough County District
12.
I'm here to introduce House Bill 162 of
which I'm the prime sponsor
it's to support a section related in the
law to supporting decision making
now this bill came to me as a
constituent request to further clarify
section RSA
464 hyphen d
which I've distributed to each of you to
gain a visual of where this bill would
go
in fact I have highlighted in a yellow
highlight marker on the statute that you
all have the precise section where this
bill language would be located
this chapter of law that you have was
part of an Omnibus Bill Senate Bill 134
which was adopted in 2021.
the bill language House Bill 162 would
be placed in the omitted
section three
lowercase b
requiring quote a description of the
types of decisions for which the
supporter is authorized to assist
as you'll see right now in the statute
there is nothing located there so the
idea is to further enhance and clarify
the statute adopted in 2021 by placing
in Section 3 lowercase b
that the agreement must contain a
description of the types of decisions
for which the supporter is authorized to
assist
I have a constituent here who requested
the bill who can talk further about it
and with that I will conclude my
testimony thank you Mr chairman
questions for representative Moon
can I ask you uh representative seeing
no other questions can I can I just ask
so the
and should we infer from the existing
law that
there was just sort of an oversight in
the in when it was originally enacted
somehow it didn't the language that
should have been in there wasn't put in
there or
true that that is correct okay and and
so do you know I mean and this was what
this was this language that you've now
proposed in this bill is this the same
language that was supposed to have gone
in there originally that I do not know
okay
all right but true it skips from a to c
and a to c okay so um all right
right I mean to me this makes makes
imminent sense especially I've it's rare
that we see a statute that is drafted to
say you know omitted agreed with a
section that's for sure
um all right um
uh any questions for the for this
witness thank you very much
representative
I'm gonna call on uh Bob Bethel
how about that now that works good
morning uh chairman Lynn and the rest of
the committee uh thank you for hearing
me this morning my name is Bob bevel I
live at 12 Blair Road in Merrimack New
Hampshire
uh I have the dubious honor of assisting
the New Hampshire Department of
Education in uh rewriting the parents
guide for the due process uh position
for when parents uh have problems with
uh the school districts and they need to
have Clarity on that as we're developing
this new user's guide for the parents to
understand that one of the new sections
that we had to include has to do with
RSA 464d which is the supported decision
making process New Hampshire happens to
be one of the few states that is
beginning to implement this as a parent
of special needs kids I think this is a
fantastic bill in that it allows those
children who become adults who do not
need full guardianship but need
assistance in making decisions to have a
code decision capability for them uh as
this is new we're still trying to roll
it out people are trying to understand
it uh one of the things that it's going
on is to understand what a supported
decision maker can do and cannot do
and unless it's properly enumerated it
kind of gets lost in the path so what's
happening with it being omitted in 3B
some of the language is already there in
461 D7 1 B and C so I'll point that out
in in one B and C it says a description
of the type of decisions for which
supporter is authorized to assist and C
says a description of those for which
they may not assist
part of the problem though is that
chapter in Section 3 is controlling and
so if you think of this like you're
trying to do a will or a trust or
something like that you have to follow
certain elements and the element for
what is there is missing so I I don't
know if uh representative Mooney gave
you a copy of the entire section of the
law but if you go down to RSA 464 D16 it
has a sample form that can be used
that talks about my supporter may help
me with obtaining food clothing and
shelter taking care of my physical
health Mental Health financial matters
public benefits education and employment
where my involvement in this comes from
the education in that some of these
children will be becoming 17 18 are part
of their IEPs and when they do this they
get to sign off on their IEPs up until
the age of 22 as a co-decision maker so
either parents are operating as their
guardians or now under the support of
decision making uh that is where it
comes under the the child who's now an
adult is still in the school district
and gets to help make decisions part of
that comes in also under what's called
vocation in that we try to put these
children out into the Working World into
different things uh but there's a
bifurcation because of an authorization
for Education support versus doing
employment so that's kind of where I'm
trying to get that here is that the
language is just missing from the
omitted when you turn the page in the
Omnibus Bill and that was all I was
looking for on there the concern is that
you're we're going to have parents that
are going to be looking to this they're
going to look to the form of D16 and
they're going to be lost and we want to
be able to help them do this just as you
would an advanced directive or a health
care proxy if you're standing in the
hospital have a child that's going in
for wisdom teeth surgery on Friday
that's where I'm wearing the mask so I
don't get sick
that you know you make a decision at
that time it should be able to be made
at that moment without it being a power
of attorney or something at that level
um I'll yield to the floor thank you
questions for this Witness
yes representative Manos
good morning
um I'm confused about why 1B
is not sufficient
so under a strict reading of it one
talks about a supported decision-making
agreement shall include
but it is not mandatory whereas when you
read three it says a supported decision
making agreement is only valid if all
and when you say only valid if all
the item from one B is not included in
three
of course
so your view
your language
um in one that says the agreement shall
include it's not mandatory but it's
permissive the judge I can defer to
shall can be must you know in in in
courts but you know again these are
going to be parents that are
self-directed doing this to assist their
children all I'm looking for is that in
the controlling paragraph number three
is that it enumerates that when you say
that you're doing a supported decision
making it's not an all-inclusive that's
not the point the point is is that this
adult child is saying I can make my own
decision on which classes I pick but I
need help with my banking or I need help
deciding on my health care kind of
things and it is the adult child
who we are empowering here to do that
and that's all I'm trying to do is to
make sure that in the controlling
paragraph of three the language of one
uh one B is there if the committee feels
that it's sufficient as is that's fine
but this was the concern we had as I was
helping draft the parents guide and we
were including the new sections about
supported decision making because that
came up we're there for talking about
education but in some of these kids
situations from the age of 16 to 22
we're also looking for vocational
support and work support and that came
up as is a supported decision maker in
education also authorized to speak on
work
that's where that came from thank you
any other questions for this witness so
I do have a question thank you and it
really it follows up on on what
representative Manis says because I
think
I think she raises a very valid point is
it
in other words I I would think that a
court would say shall mean shall not May
and so one is kind of mandatory and I
and I guess one one of the things that
concerns me is
if that's true if if section one is
mandatory and it says that the agreement
has to contain a list
of the types of decisions for which
support is authorized and a I'm sorry
description of the types of decisions
for which support is authorized and a
for which support is not authorized
then I'm wondering if in in this piece
of legislation
we should in order to make section one
consistent with section three
be here
ought to say the agreement contains a
description of the types of decisions
for which the supporter is authorized to
assist as well as a description of the
types of assistance for which the
supporter is not authorized to assist
because if I'd be concerned that if you
only put you know if you have a conflict
between one and three which I assume you
don't want to have absolutely I agree
sir
um I wish I had provided copies of when
you get down to 464 D16 it offers a form
which is a very good form and you can
basically say yes or no on the form but
what's missing on there is like for on
the example it has like supporter one
can do this versus supporter two can do
that
it feels like the form is controlling us
there may be decisions that the adult
child would like assistance to that are
not included here so it feels like they
are trapped with what's on that form all
I'm trying to say is we want to empower
this young adult
who is making decisions that you and I
we just do but we want to give them the
strength to know that we're going to
assist them without it being a power of
attorney or controlling them so again if
they if I forgot that one of the in one
of our meetings somebody included
something else that was not in the list
of food clothing shelter physical health
Mental Health financial public benefits
education and employment there was one
more and it's so well is that not there
it would be something you know where
that you could put another one in
uh below that that would say
I grant so and so the right for x and it
would have a yes no where that supporter
one could in support of two could I know
I'm kind of doing this on the fly but
that was the concern is that what
authorizations do they have this is
again being driven by the Department of
Education parents guide as to what
decisions can a supported decision maker
make in the moment when they're at an
IEP is it only education or Does it
include work product or vocation
that's where that came from thank you
other questions yes uh representative
Tripp thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question so are you suggesting
that we also take a look at the the form
and maybe modify that yes sir again I
literally got this called
what time was it like 11 o'clock before
the deadline of filing it at noon and we
we literally filed it at 11 45 because I
wasn't even aware and so I did not have
time to ask to look at D16 but yes
thank you
any other questions for this Witness
thank you for your time
thank you thank you
um
Chris madement
oh I'm sorry this is a different Bill oh
no I'm sorry different Bill sorry are
there is there anyone else
um who's uh is here to testify on uh HB
162.
yes
okay
so can you fill it out and then then
we'd love to hear from you please
foreign
oh I'm sorry
oh I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm I'm sorry I
apologize if you had a question of the
for the last witness well no not
specifically the lat witness it was a
comment about the bill I was uh oh when
we got the
um
when we got this bill we very handily
we're showing the chapter law which was
the bill that created this well which is
passed in 20. 2021 and it was part of an
Omnibus Bill and then
um there's a house Amendment and it just
skipped straight from a to c for no
apparent reason and it should have been
caught during the enrolled build process
or during the committee of conference or
whatever but it wasn't so that's uh and
so the original Bill the ominous bill in
the Senate said pretty much exactly what
uh represent Moody and the others have
uh have suggested so that's not really a
question for the previous witness
because he was talking about other
issues I think but that's
just thought I'd it's okay to State it
now instead of waiting for the executive
session but
all right we do have another witness on
this bill uh please
good morning I'm Karen Rosenberg I'm the
policy director at the disability rights
Center
um and I wasn't planning on testifying
and really I just want to provide some
information for the committee on this
bill this is um the law is something
that my predecessor worked on
um quite a lot in the 2021 session and
the idea was not for someone to delegate
decision-making Authority but for there
to be an alternative to guardianship
which is an opportunity for someone with
a disability to choose people who they
trust to assist them in making their own
decisions
so it's really not it's not substituted
decision making it's to enable someone
with a disability to
come and have a formal agreement with
someone they trust who's knowledgeable
to assist them in making decisions so
with a student if they want to keep
their parents included in their in
making decisions about their education
they might enter into a supported
decision-making agreement which would
basically say I want my parent to assist
me in making my own decisions for how
what classes I'm going to take you know
what my IEP is going to look like those
kinds of decisions but the decision
making Authority rests with the
individual not with their supporter the
supporter provides assistance and what
this bill does as written it just
basically you know it carries it carries
over the requirement that these
supported decision making agreement just
State sort of what the what kind of what
kind of issues I'm going to be relying
on my supporter for what kind of
decisions I'm going to be relying on my
supporter to assist me with
so I don't know that this amendment is
really necessary I think that section
one actually does
have the shell and say what needs to be
there I think you start getting into the
if if we start adding additional
Provisions like also having to enumerate
all the things that a supporter might
not be able to assist with we it might
end up being very onerous because
there's a lot of decisions that we all
make every day of our lives right and
that we might rely on people to assist
us with and I don't know that we want to
make completing this form onerous
there's a check but there are there's an
opportunity to say what you're not going
to have a supporter make decisions or
help you with decisions about right in
the form that's in the statute it's also
in the Shell provision
so I'm not sure it's necessary to amend
it at all and I also think we need to be
careful That We're Not Gonna
Force someone who has a disability who's
already engaging supporters to put in
more time that's necessary
um to enumerate all the things that
this person you've asked to support you
with may not assist you with because so
as an example like if I wanted my if I
was a a an 18 year old I wish and I was
asking my parents to continue assisting
me with my education I might not want to
list all the things I don't want them to
assist me with like decisions around who
I hang out with or decisions around you
know where I live or just you know there
could be a huge list there so it could
get very onerous for someone in
completing one of these forms
so
I'm happy to take any questions
questions for this Witness
so you know what I I'm sorry yes
representative page thank you thanks
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question the Bill's been in effect
for a little bit of time now do you know
of any instances where the current
statutory Arrangement has caused
problems for children or parents I I am
not aware of any but that doesn't mean
that they don't exist I've just not
heard of any
other questions
so can I may I just ask uh the um it
seems like the the
The Proposal
um would would simply be I mean would
all it would do is really make section
three
it would eliminate the omitted which
does seem a little bit untoward and just
put in
basically the same language that's in
subsection one I mean I don't I don't
see this as making any
substantive change to the law but uh so
I'm I mean if I it I mean do you do you
think that that would make a substantive
change to the law if we just sort of put
put the same language that's in section
one in section three
well I I see your point
I
like I said my only kids there I I see
what you're saying and that it would be
perfectly consistent to have the same
Provisions in both sections of the law
that's true
um I think it would be really important
to make it clear that
um
it's just you know add the if any Clause
so that it's exactly the same because we
don't want to create a situation where
someone would really need to think about
all the things you know ahead of time
that we might not want someone to assist
with and there is an opportunity for in
the form to check off some of those
things that they might know up front
sure uh representative Smith
thank you Mr chair
um and nature aboards a vacuum could it
not be that we could very simply
um uh call for a re-ordering of uh
section three so that c becomes b e n d
becomes c and e becomes D and there is
no longer anything that says omitted and
we can just go on about our business
that seems like a lovely eloquent
solution
the form includes the provisions that
are required in Roman one
and you would not have the vacuum that
we apparently abhor
and it would be quite elegant
other questions for this Witness
thank you thank you anyone else who
desires to testify this and I wonder if
um I I don't see anyone I wonder Miss
Moody could I just ask you do you do you
have a view on on what representative
Smith suggested I mean could we just do
just you know renumber that leave just
take the omitted out and just remember
would that change anything in your view
thank you Mr chairman and I sort of
predicted what the committee options
would be with regards to this bill with
my constituent and that was one so you
hit it very good uh so long as it is
Crystal Clear oh that's the description
of the types of where the
decision-making uh agreement are clear
in the law I'm good with it
all right great any other questions for
this witness thank you
all right
um I'm no one else indicating they wish
to testify I'm going to close the
hearing on HB 162.
and open the hearing on HB 164.
and
um
Let's see we have uh representative
Heinz representative
great thank you
great good thank you
these are the ones we've done already
oh okay thank you to go with her okay
all right
fine
representative Hines
uh thank you um your honor and chair and
it's uh good to be back in front of
Judiciary uh so this bill
um there's a slight inaccuracy in the uh
title uh but it doesn't affect the text
of the uh proposal which is correct
um so this bill is relative to
prohibiting and title says towns but it
would also apply to cities and any other
unincorporated or otherwise Municipal
ordinances from criminalizing the right
to peacefully and orderly assemble now
some people might say why do we need
this it is in the state constitution I
agree I am tracking the language of the
State Constitution uh specifically uh
part one article 32 that provides people
the constitutional right in New
Hampshire to assemble in a peaceful and
orderly uh manner so the reason this is
needed is my interpretation of that law
um and I guess judge's interpretation of
when that applies or slightly at odds uh
so by way of background this bill is
primarily in response to the town of New
Field that uh did not like people
petitioning and protesting outside of
the governor's house in the case
numerous people were arrested
um at least two of those people I
believe are here at least one testifying
I'm not sure about both of them but in
that case where people were arrested
they were engaged in a peaceful and
orally protest it was a silent vigil
people were walking outside
um in public on the sidewalks no traffic
was inhibited um they weren't loud
making noises or otherwise just
disrupting things
um and the I filed a motion to dismiss
arguing various constitutional
protections including like I said
article 32 but also in that case when it
applied to a government official
arguably the highest government official
in the state I think it's uh further
protection under uh the right petition
petition ultimately the court denied our
motion to dismiss
um the everyone who is charged with that
ornus was found not guilty
um in our particular case we didn't
really even present defense at trial
hopefully hoping that it would go up to
appeal to New Hampshire Supreme Court
and validating the statute
um so trying to I guess cut this off
um by legislative means so this statute
um I do Define an orderly manner and the
way uh
I'm open to any type of redefining
orderly manner but I picked various
parts of the disorderly conduct statute
that already defines things that I would
consider orderly
um or disorderly so if this were passed
um people still can't obstruct traffic
um they can't obstruct entrances they
can't breach the piece they can't be
inconvenient annoying make loud noises
um disrupting conduct or assemblies
those types of things Isis so when
applied to things like riots
um that certainly would still be
prohibited I didn't actually Define
peaceful um in this and there's a couple
of reasons for that so I think it's
difficult to imagine every type of
instance that could in fact be peaceful
or not so certainly things that would be
prohibited would be what courts consider
true threats so true threats are outside
constitutional protection
um I guess the easiest example of a true
threat is if I say I'm going to kill
someone so clearly someone cannot go
outside anywhere and just have a sign
saying I'm going to kill or kill or
attack or someone's name I think any
Court would certainly find that outside
of any type of constitutional protection
it would be criminal threatening in fact
um this wouldn't actually legalize that
but like I said the reason I Define
peaceful specifically is it's just I
think hard to imagine every type of
thing dealing with that also the courts
um regularly or at least as far as the
Supreme Court regularly addresses what
constitutes a true threat so in some
circumstances it's kind of a gray area
whether it's a constitutional and
protected right so on this term even the
Supreme Court of the us is going to deal
with the truth right
um
so I just didn't want to get into it I
just want to be clear my intent behind
this is to expand and clarify our
constitutional right it's not in any way
to limit it
um so
um certainly I think disorderly conduct
when it's involving speech
um can be problematic for the court um
so New Hampshire Supreme Court in the
past
um in a certain version of the statute I
believe in validated part of it and
certainly made it clear that like any
law cannot actually violate
um constitutional rights
and uh I can submit to this um committee
uh the motion to dismissed I filed in
that case as well as the judge's order
um so that we can get a look at that um
and just uh just further addressing uh
for those who might not know so New
Hampshire is um not a home real estate
um so in states that are not a home real
estate towns and cities can only do what
the legislature allows so I did argue
that the town was prohibited from doing
this in the first place
um the court disagree with me with that
I essentially found Town had Authority
um to enact this so he attended this is
to prohibitedly
make it clear and preempt any town or
city from doing anything that would
violate the statute it also would
provide an affirmative defense if
someone were to be tried with the
a state
um
law that violates it um but the primary
intent is to prevent towns from doing
this
um I think this make it very clear to
the time that they could not actually do
that and in the new field case
specifically the town had so originally
the reason it was adopted is in the past
and I didn't represent anyone or I was
involved in any of those things but a
lot of people I guess I would say were
disorderly protesting in front of the
governor's house so if people are
showing up and
I mean the easiest example I think is
certain loud noises that would be
outside constitutional protection
um I think that was already the town had
ample Avenues to already address that so
whether it's the disorderly comic
statute as it was written or various
other things so like I said this this
early conic statue of this build
um well or else I were to pass it still
prohibits the
non the disruptive kind so
um 2C would still be in effect
um and three would still be in a fact
three dealing with loud noises so is
again limited to peaceful and orderly
assembling and protesting
um and that is explicitly what our state
constitution provides yeah I'd be happy
to take any questions
questions for this Witness
yeah uh I'm sorry representative Morgan
do you have a question
yes you kind of alluded to it but uh
many of the same individuals involved in
the new Fields protest I guess we're
also uh
arrested in uh I'm not sure whether it
would have been Goffstown or Manchester
whatever decided the Town Line the New
Hampshire Institute of politics is when
they had the executive Council uh
Chambers so it's your bill apply to uh
meetings such as the things
things such as executive Council
meetings or is this or where's the uh
where's the uh the line between what
this bill covers and what it doesn't yes
I guess I'd have to have to see what the
complaint
um alleges so if the complaints alleging
that people are acting in a disorderly
fashion so if you were inner if a bunch
of people came in and started
interrupting this proceeding I don't
think that would count as an orderly
manner in under our present statute
specifically three already deals with
breach piece inconvenience annoyance
including loud noises and specifically
disrupting
um so in those particular facts I would
say no it would not prohibit that but if
people were outside of that place with
some signs picketing I would suggest yes
those people should not be charged with
a crime
thanks
yes representative
what was the basis for the motion to
dismiss for the allowance of the motion
to dismiss
the U.S Supreme Court has a law that on
its face
um
that this law in space would be
constitutional
um I think it's distinguishable I did
try to distinguish it so the case that
um
the U.S Supreme Court relying on
basically allowed under limited
circumstances people to be criminalized
for potentially protesting in a
residential neighborhood I think this
statute as applied was different because
it was directed at the governor so the
basis of the dismissal was that specific
U.S Supreme Court case and I would add
that
um the U.S Supreme Court basically sets
the minimum standards New Hampshire we
have our own Constitution specifically
article 32 addresses this and cert more
protective yes
other questions
so I I just want to make sure I'm uh so
did the did the what court was this that
denied the motion to dismiss it was a
superior court a circuit court it was
District Court uh Brent and was there an
opinion written by the court uh yes
there was and I will submit that to you
saying that saying that what this that
it was not unconstitutional
okay yes at the motion to dismiss stage
and a lot of my arguments
um applied to the essentially
I think the main thing the core was
Finding was that it was constitutional
science based but um the court in my
opinion deferred on the as applied and
wanted to wait to the point of trial to
address that issue so ultimately it
wasn't well it was addressing trial with
a not guilty verdict
um but there wasn't any specific binding
after trial or after testimony as to
whether it was constitutional as applied
to the case
so I just I guess I have one of the
questions under if under under this if
we were to enact this as a law suppose
that
um whether it's in new fields or
wherever uh you know any anywhere
suppose that a people are unhappy with
some
person who lives at a particular address
and they decide that they're going to
walk a picket line peacefully and
quietly at two o'clock in the morning
can they do that
I think if it's peacefully and quietly
yes
um if it's disrupting people
um either with it doesn't have to be
noise I guess if it were
um even sounds I would suggest that
that's still inconvenience um and the
court could take into consideration the
time of night people don't want light
shined into their house or if you're
somehow Awakening people
um I would suggest that that would still
be some type of breach of peace or
inconvenience or annoyance so I think
um it would depend on any specific facts
but I think if someone's just walking
quietly outside of someone's house while
they're sleeping I don't think that's
really
I think that person's the least likely
to even know about it and be impacted by
itself I think that would be a poor way
to go about that speech but
um I guess under certain circumstances
it would protect that speech all right
other question representative uh
so in this case that you're mentioning
was the reason were they on the street
or were they actually on his property
because
that's his private residence so not a
government property correct correct so
yes
wait a minute I'll help you if somebody
else wants to testify you'll have
perfect opportunity to do that sir but
not right now yep so the ordinance has
written a plot and I argued also the
ordinance was block has included things
that they also can include but for the
facts of the matter um no it was on
public property a sidewalk
um very s factually specific to the
governor's house is there is a private
right-of-way that goes along his prop
basically
among sort of dividing his property
between things
um so there was no
that there was no trespassing I guess so
this wouldn't prevent trespassing that's
a way to answer your question so it
would only apply to public you can't go
on someone's front yard and start
protesting okay thank you that was the
question is this this seems like it only
applies to public land and I wanted to
make sure that that was the case thank
you other questions for this witness yes
representative Turner
uh yeah and and this made me my lack of
understanding of of the law um
I'm understanding that the the
Constitution essentially encompasses
what the law that you're proposing is
also trying to Encompass and I would
assume that the a constitutional
provision would supersede
um so is this just related to the way
that if the court applied the law or and
is there any other instance where we
sort of have a law that sort of codifies
something that's in the Constitution
I guess I am
yes used to it being the other way
around but in this case the town passed
an ordinance knowing about the
Constitution many people at least I
think was like seven or eight people on
that specific night were arrested for
violating an orange so police didn't
think if I lay the Constitution
ultimately an attorney filed a motion to
dismiss argument violation a judge
disagreed with me um so maybe I'm the
outlier but numerous people are just
finding that the specific at least the
statute itself did not violate the
constitution so I can't I don't think I
can further amend the Constitution to
make it clear so but we can
um make it clear specifically when it's
being applied to a town the state is
well within its authority to preempt
towns town you cannot do that
I hope I answer your question
yes representative
thank you Mr chair uh thank you for
taking my question uh you may have said
what
the people that were protesting were
charged with but uh I may not have been
listening or I didn't write it down
could you repeat that please yes I will
submit the actual complaint and text of
newfields town ordinance but basically
it was prohibiting
I forget to use the word prototype I
believe it's protest my business
template but essentially protesting
outside of a residential area that's
essentially their broad statute didn't
include any limitations
um obviously every law Town ordinance or
otherwise is limited by the Constitution
uh but it was a very broad statue
um basically said on protest in any
manner outside of a resonance
yes so you have written testimony that
you're going to be giving us uh yes I
will submit that and the reason I didn't
do it ahead of time is I try to listen
to everyone else's comments and so I can
add further too
testimony that obvious to me but I will
submit the town ordinance a question uh
my motion is dismissed I filed as well
as the Court's order in that case thank
you
yes representative Perez
thank you for taking my question
does that ordinance appear to be in
direct violation of the constitution in
my opinion yes okay is anything being
done about that ordinance
it can't be at this point because it's
moot because everyone was found not
guilty so this is my response to making
something being done about it
may I yes so in other words the
ordinance still stands in that
particular town so if that ordinance was
in my town
and I went and peacefully assembled
outside of
um my next door neighbor's house which
is a residence I could be arrested if I
stepped off the sidewalk
onto the street
uh so if first your town would have to
pass an order it's assuming they did yes
assuming they used the language that the
U.S Supreme Court allowed
um
I think yes I I would agree there's a
difference between a sidewalk and a
street um obviously you also can't step
on a person's property
um so yeah any other town or city even
um could adopt a similar ordinance
um I would expect the attorney would
challenge it on constitutional grounds
and um so district court cases aren't
binding on other judges um I think
judges certainly would give it deference
and look at the decision taken into
consideration
um I would hope there would be a split
and a judge would find that particular
statue unconstitutional But ultimately
without the New Hampshire Supreme Court
addressing this specific issue the next
best remedy in my opinion is having
legislature essentially overriding the
towns thank you
other questions representative Patel
so if that
um ordinance is still taking place and
the fact that it's a constitutional
right to be able to do it didn't stop
them from putting in that town ordinance
how would this RSA stop them from having
that ordinance what is different here
yep uh two ways I think it just broadly
clarifies an affirmative defense but
second so towns can only do what the
state allows them to and one thing's
what's called preemption
um so we have various statutes that do
that off top of my hand Firearms being
one of them we specifically tell us the
towns you cannot address any law dealing
with this so if the legislature comes in
and specifically tells the town or city
you cannot do this
um of course I don't think there's any
question I don't even think a town would
try
thank you other questions for this
Witness
yes representative De Lorenzo thank you
Mr chair just one quick one uh
representative Heinz um who defines
peacefully and or orderly assemblance
yeah so I mean ultimately I had to make
a judgment call of that if the uh and
like I said I didn't want to limit it so
um if courts were to like I said you
still have constitutional right to do
that so I'm happy with any um changes
that the committee might feel is a
better way to do it so I just didn't
Define peacefully because I think it's
hard to Encompass everything that might
include that
um and orderly I just this is in the
disorderly comic statue so I tried to
pick things in the statute that I
thought were disorderly and we might not
otherwise want to allow so
um it was just
me guessing it what I feel includes
those things but the committee wants to
make any uh changes to those language I
would certainly support that
other questions for this Witness
thank you very much representative Heinz
thank you I'm next gonna call on
um
uh Frank negus State I hope I'm
pronouncing this correctly negative
Staples legal Staples yes sir yes
Staples apologize for uh
my comments there I would like to put
the board on notice or the people that I
do have had trauma and I get loud
sometimes
and distracted so I may need a little
bit more time there's a lot of things
here that you guys were asking uh
attorney Hines that he's not aware of I
am the organizer of the original
protests in front of the governor's
house no one ever stepped foot on his
property there was a public cul-de-sac
in the cul-de-sac where he lives there's
a small park right there in that
cul-de-sac and that's where all of the
protests were held and that's where the
candlelight vigil was held where Skyler
Bennett was arrested for trespassing
into disorderly conduct the governor
used that arrest that he was found not
guilty of to cancel his inauguration and
publicly state that there were armed
protesters in his backyard
which was a lie a bold-faced lie
additionally his brother Michael sununu
is the one who passed this town
ordinance the town ordinance itself
derives its power from a motorboat
Muffler statue
okay it's right there in the town
ordinance and the town ordinance itself
does not define what is picketing it's
picketing in a residential neighborhood
is the town ordinance okay I've been to
the police station the newfields town
hall to ask them what is picketing the
officer directed me to come back I went
back and I actually bumped into Michael
sununu I have a video of the entire
encounter and he was unable to explain
what is picketing where I could and
couldn't pick it in new fields and he
said we were allowed to pick it but we
should talk to the chief of police I
tried to talk to the police chief of
police I got part of the conversation he
called me I have part of that on video
he's unable to Define he keeps referring
to this uh denial of the motion to
dismiss from attorney Hines to justify
this town ordinance even though Schuyler
Bennett was ultimately found not guilty
they're referring to the the denial of
this on the Constitutional grounds of
that case so and another thing if it
isn't disorderly conduct which is pretty
much a catch-all for anything if it's
not disorderly then it has to be orderly
by Nature okay so if you can't be
arrested for disorderly
then they they shouldn't this I mean
this ordinance is absolutely ridiculous
and when I represented myself at trial I
have this on video as well Trooper state
trooper dots testified that AG at the
time McDonald
gave them instructions on how to enforce
the ordinance
okay what were those instructions we
don't know I've been trying to find
Clarity on this the last person to get a
ticket stood in the cul-de-sac by
himself while there was a train of
vehicles with Dawn Baldock honking
around the cul-de-sac making noise Flags
waving driving back and forth back and
forth none of them got in trouble none
of them got ticketed my friend Brian got
ticketed for picketing in front of the
governor's house and then that case was
eventually dismissed and he was never
even received notice of it and that's
when we went to New fields to try to get
clarity so I also have a supreme court
appeal that McDonald had to recuse
himself of because I was arrested for
disorderly conduct after the fact I went
back after the vigil it's fine I killed
I told you I'm disabled so I'm asking
for a reasonable accommodation thank you
um
so we went back and I was arrested
after I was ticketed there was at least
10 or 15 of us singing Christmas carols
in the middle of the day and
they said we're all going to get tickets
and then there's State Police and the
Town Police talking to each other I got
it all on video and I S and we're
waiting and waiting we go back we say
Hey where's these tickets they give me a
ticket only me a ticket I say okay and
then I try to get this state trooper
next to him who's playing clothes with a
mask on to identify himself because he
was the one that this guy was talking to
I said who are you sir identify yourself
and then this new Fields town hall guy
arrest me for disorderly conduct doesn't
tell me any lawful order to stop what
I'm doing sure you know I I I we want to
hear what you have to say but you seem
it it needs to be related to this to
this bill it is related to this bill
hang on hang on you have to listen to me
when I'm talking sure okay all right it
seems like you're going into you know
sort of the the particulars of your case
that kind of go beyond what's no this is
why you were asking about the previous
protests never were there any arrests
for disorderly at any of the previous
protests which were supposedly so loud
and boisterous
never once okay instead they decided to
create this town ordinance off of a
motorboat Muffler law built for the
waterways to Target picketing in a
residential neighborhood okay so this
law is nullified it is unconstitutional
and it cannot be enforced that's why the
judge keeps finding everyone not guilty
and that's why they had to arrest me for
disorderly conduct for nothing for
peacefully protesting and then asking
why this this guy who this guy is who's
who's giving the Town Police
instructions on how to enforce this law
so this is a criminal conspiracy and
there should be in 100 investigation on
this I will email the video of the the
encounter that I had with Michael sununu
where he just unable he's the one who
signed off on this town ordinance if
anyone could explain it he can but he
couldn't
okay all right so if you have any
questions oh and I would like to hark
back to Governor Wentworth this is
historical facts of New Hampshire look
up Governor Wentworth the first governor
New Hampshire do you know what happened
to him
protesters came outside his house with a
cannon
and he took off out the back door and he
went to Canada and never came back
okay so protesting in front of our
political uh Representatives our public
servants houses to hold them accountable
is what it's all about if we're out in
front of your house because we know
where you live and that's not a threat
that's a matter of public record okay we
know where you live if we're outside
your house pissed off there's a reason
for it and maybe you should listen to
the people who you're supposed to
represent
right questions for this Witness
anyone have any questions yes
representative Horgan
you've referred several times to Michael
sununu so what what was what office and
what position of authority did he hold
in the town of new fields or effort he's
the Town Administrator
thank you all right thank you he should
have recused himself as being the
brother of Michael sununu and the
administrator the sununa administration
at the time reached out to the town we
have that proven New Hampshire Journal
proved that and there was a reporter
who's here a reporter who was covering
the vigil he was arrested and charged as
well and that is unacceptable absolutely
unacceptable other questions for this
Witness
yes representative Perez
so may I simplify this and tell me if
I'm wrong it's my understanding that
this bill
is being put forth because you and
others feel that your constitutional
rights were violated by an ordinance
that was put into place
that perhaps prohibited your
constitutional rights from being
allowed is that simple I as far as I
understand it I'm not Dan Hines he's the
one who put the bill forward this bill
um is put forward to
I mean it's it's re it's rewriting the
Constitution this is the problem we
already have the Constitution that's not
being followed and we are whittling it
away with all these statutes we need
less and less and less of these statutes
to have more freedom laws create crime
simple math zero laws equals zero crime
I'm not advocating for zero laws but
that's how it works so you can't
criminalize everything that you don't
like especially if there's a disorderly
conduct statute that's there that can be
used they could have arrested anybody
for disorderly conduct at any time other
questions for this Witness
all right thank you very much sir thank
you
uh
I hope I'm pronouncing this correctly
notch
graze
craze for the municipal Association I uh
can't remember if I've introduced myself
before this year it's been a little busy
um we are a voluntary membership
organization comprised of the 234 cities
and towns of New Hampshire we provide
legal advice uh to cities and towns we
provide training we did about 80
training and education events last year
we also come here and Advocate on behalf
of cities and towns we are opposed to
this bill
um it appears to be a limit on the
ability of municipalities to regulate
the time place and are put into place uh
time place and manner restrictions on
um
I guess public Gatherings
um these these type of restrictions have
been litigated extensively over many
many decades our New Hampshire Supreme
Court has addressed this multiple times
we have very clear case law about that
um and we believe that those judicial
decisions are correct we don't believe
that it is appropriate to upend the
apple cart and
um change what the existing law is
um it as I understand from the
discussion today uh this bill was filed
um as a consequence of
some enforcement actions taking place in
New Fields I'm not familiar with those
so I wouldn't want to speak to those
specifically
um I'm unclear at this point in time
whether the bill sponsor indicated that
he had
asked the court for an as applied
challenge to that ordinance and as
applied challenge is one where
uh essentially the defense and please
correct me if I'm wrong on describing
this uh uh representative Lynn
um but an as applied challenge is one
where
um the defense asked the court to find
that the law
is written is unconstitutional as
applied to the specific facts in that
case
generally speaking that's a little bit
uh of a lesser standard than an overall
challenge to an ordinance which is a
facial challenge which means that
essentially you're saying that this law
would never be constitutional in any
circumstance I wasn't exactly clear on
the testimony whether that was asked for
or not but I would assume that whatever
court documents he files with the
committee would clarify that I'm happy
to take any questions that you may have
questions for this Witness
yes representative breeson
thank you Mr chair and thank you sir for
your taking our questions uh line three
of the bill paragraph two excuse me uh
Roman numeral seven
it says notwithstanding any other
provision of law
it shall not be a crime or violation to
peacefully Assemble
so that Clause notwithstanding any other
provision of law
says that municipalities can still enact
laws your concern is you represent these
municipalities is that they would this
would infringe upon their ability to
enact laws that govern times and places
of protests
notwithstanding any other provision of
law says that these Municipal
municipalities can still enact such laws
so how
is this bill then
and additionally
the all the rulings if I understand
have determined that the law the the
ordinance that was put into place they
were all found not guilty so there's
clearly a problem with that law
so how would this then infringe upon a
municipality's ability to
regulate times and places of
assembly so as I mentioned I'm not
familiar with the cases oh irrespective
of that how would this if because it
says notwithstanding any other provision
of laws so that's what might also create
some additional confusion because there
is uh for instance RSA 3139 which allows
municipalities to put in place Municipal
ordinances on very specific things
[Music]
um
and
you know if they're and that would be
enacted at town meeting since the town
can do it generally proposed by the
select board and it's possible there
would be some sort of overlap there
where there's some sort of authority
granted by that law for municipalities
to put in ordinances that may
run
differently from how this law reads and
I am slightly confused with a lack of
definitions for the term peaceful for
instance
um as well as line six and seven that
say
um orderly manner means not engaging in
conduct prohibited under paragraph
2C or or 3 what exactly that encompasses
it's a follow-up Mr chair yes so where
in law is peaceful defined and if
there's a reference for this section
orderly manner refers to other portions
of the law I'm assuming that refers back
to disorderly conduct I don't know the
law specifically in this case but it's
at least referring to something that's
been codified how is then peaceful
defined so that any judge would then
know
this is how this is the standard for
peaceful I'm not aware of any statutory
definition of the term peaceful but
you're asking them to define it
there
I'm not the one proposing the law sir
but you just said you don't know what
peaceful is
well I'm that's why I'm pointing that
out because it's not defined in the bill
in front of you so I I don't exactly
know how that would be
understood by the courts it appears
don't they understand it let's not let's
not turn this into a debate that I think
I'm sorry questions are okay no I'm I'm
directing it to both both to both
parties here
all right other questions
so I guess I do have one question I'm
let's assume that
you're correct that the
the con the New Hampshire Constitution
would allow
municipalities
to regulate the time you know at the
time place and manner of of protests in
a way
um that
would not be allowed under this statute
I guess my question though so so this
statute then would provide more
protection than the Constitution
provides and I and I guess my question
is let's assume that all that's true
that that this a municipality could
prohibit could now prohibit some types
of protests or demonstrations whatever
that they would not be able to provide
if this statute was enacted
so I guess my question though is so what
I mean why why isn't this statute still
a good idea if it's limited as it's
worded to say it to being peaceful
protest well we do advocate for
municipalities to maintain their
existing Authority and we believe that
given the volume of case Law related to
what municipalities May and may not do
in this area that currently exists that
that was an appropriate decision by our
Supreme Court
um over the course of many decades
refining that as well as the U.S Supreme
Court and
that's our position as we think that's
the appropriate appropriate answer is
the courts have decided and their
decision was correct okay no that's fine
uh question yes representative Perez
thank you
I apologize we have a lot of people who
are very knowledgeable on the law I was
a nurse for 42 years so
um
are you saying that towns
can override the New Hampshire
Constitution so if okay so if the New
Hampshire Constitution allows for
freedom of speech
if a town says yeah but you can only do
it this this and this
the town's allowed to do that
so maybe it's easier if I give you an
example sure
um so
if you the town level were to say hey
something's a good idea
um I don't know you're gonna
ban let's say you're going to ban
nuclear weapons from your town right
some Town actually did this
you could you could pass a town
ordinance that does that now whether
that prevents the US government from
setting up a missile silo in your town
with a nuclear weapon in it is totally
relevant because you can't override
um law because towns are subdivisions of
the state and they can't override state
laws they can't override the federal
laws that would be applied through the
supremacy clause and they certainly
can't override either the New Hampshire
or the U.S constitutions
so in understanding what the
U.S and New Hampshire constitutions mean
they the attorneys assisting the towns
have to rely on
Court decisions Supreme Court decisions
mainly to understand that the words used
in those because they have very specific
meanings which
have developed have been clarified
um over centuries at this point
um so
it may be possible for a town to do
something which is unconstitutional and
I'm not saying nuclear weapons is is a
is a great example for this but they
could do something like that and that
would violate
uh some sort of state or federal law
someone with standing meaning they have
the ability to challenge that law could
come in sue and say hey this this can't
you can't enforce this this isn't a this
isn't a lawful ordinance and then the
court would look at that and they would
make a determination about whether it
was law or not and based on
both the existing state and federal
statutes as well as the appropriate
constitutions and if it if the court
found that it was not
um lawful and
some in this case constitutional uh
would be the question then that
ordinance would not would not be allowed
to be enforced it may still technically
be on the books but it's not enforceable
um and there there would be a clear
judicial decision on that I hope that's
helpful yes thank you uh representative
Wallace thank you Mr chairman thanks for
taking my question isn't any uh Laura
statute that's repugnant to the
Constitution Ellen void pursuant to
Marbury versus Madison
you are correct that thank you
uh representative Morgan
I'm sure I'm not unique in this but I've
had a couple occasions where people have
been threatening or leash harassing me
because they take exception with
something I said to Truth for their
special attention because I was a State
Rep but do
what power do municipalities have to uh
just protect anybody who's a target of
uh you know
a target of harassment or threatening um
whether or not they're a public
officials so they have any
because I know when I by these incidents
I did contact the police department they
just said they well while they well we
agreed to is that you know they keep an
extra eye on my house and send the
patrol cars more and if anybody was
presumably if anybody's loiting around
they would try to stop them from
loitering so is that something into
municipalities actually have uh you know
authority authority to do under some
laws and are we talking about this bill
I mean yes yes oh well yes I am yeah I
mean right I mean that
I mean that is part of it is that like
uh Governor it's a new new had
displeased a number of people in the
community and they were uh expressing
their displeasure in that particular
spot which apparently is allegedly
public property and probably was but to
see
does even disability of any specific
authority to
sort of like prevent people from uh
congregating or loitering or harassing
somebody who for whatever reason has
attracted the ire of of a group of group
of individuals I'm not sure if this
makes any sense
so
I'm trying to think about how to frame
this yeah so
um
the government can't control
what you say except in very very
specific manner so for instance you
can't go in a crowded theater and shout
fire when there's no fire because that's
that that creates a hazard
um but
they can regulate the time place and
manner for a public gathering so for
example
the government could prevent people from
you know closing down Main Street or the
highway to have a protest because that's
going to be dangerous they're you know
because people are not going to know
driver's not going to know if somebody's
going to hit by a car that's not a good
thing to do
um so generally speaking that's pretty
widely accepted and understood
when you get into specific facts as
appear to be the motivation behind this
uh this particular legislation
um that's going to depend on the exact
facts and Circumstance of the case as
they relate to the law it exists now and
the best
entity to decide what that how that
applies is the judicial branch they have
expertise in that
um
and they can apply to law and and make
those judgments that's what they're
that's what they're there for
thank you
good morning thank you Mr chair members
of the committee for the opportunity to
testify here today I know we're over
time so I'll try to be as brief as
possible for the record my name is Chris
madement I am here in my personal
capacity today as a resident of
Peterborough and a citizen of New
Hampshire uh in December of 2020 I was
employed as a reporter for New Hampshire
Journal uh in online news source here in
New Hampshire
we had broken the story of the ordinance
in new fields that had passed the select
board there uh after three readings
um and following us breaking that story
The the night in question that several
other speakers mentioned
um that Candlelight vigil was organized
and we had spoken with the the state
police and the newfields police ahead of
time and they had promised uh aggressive
enforcement of this new ordinance which
turned out to be absolutely true
um
I was cited
that evening as as well as the the
protesters were
um with the violation of that town
ordinance
um and I have the the text of that
ordinance I know somebody asked about
that the ordinance read it is unlawful
for any person to engage in picketing
before or about the residence or
dwelling of any individual in the town
of new Fields uh simple one one-line
statement uh the Attorney General's
office helped newfields draft this
ordinance they determined that it would
be constitutional uh the courts clearly
agreed with that
um as there was an as applied challenge
as the the previous speaker was
wondering
um the courts basically ignored the as
applied challenge in this case at least
in my case
uh so they did not render a decision on
whether it was uh constitutional as
applied or not
um but but clearly the motion to dismiss
was was uh
denied in all of the cases and all cases
did proceed to trial except mine after
18 months my case was Noel Prost uh in
May of 2021 uh 2022 rather
um
so
whereas the courts have found that this
is a constitutional ordinance this
statute is would be necessary in order
to prevent these prevent towns or cities
from passing similar ordinances that
criminalize Granite Staters right to to
protest now it keep in mind in uh
2020 we were in the midst of covid the
State House was largely closed to the
public
Representatives that were serving at the
time were serving from from home mostly
the lob was largely closed to the public
so the government normally where where
people would go to redress their
grievances or to protest certain certain
happenings by the government those
buildings were closed
and I'm not condoning protesting in
front of somebody's home but when I
spoke to the protesters at the time as
as a reporter they had indicated that
they had no other place to protest
except for the home where the where the
the governor was working from he wasn't
working from the state house at the time
and that their position was that
they were trying to protest his actions
he wasn't in the state house so they
couldn't protest at the state house so
they brought the protest to his quiet
residential neighborhood uh in another
question that I heard
a couple times is what defines peaceful
I would posit that the the right
question is what defines uh disorderly
I think if we were to try to Define
peaceful it would be a very long list of
what constitutes peaceful activity but
chapter 644 2 which is where this
statute would be placed if it passes
defines disorderly conduct all of those
statues would still be in place the
police would still be able to enforce
those statutes they would be able to
arrest or remove people that were acting
disorderly specifically this bill
mentions paragraph 2C which uh
refers to obstructing vehicular or
pedestrian traffic on any public Street
or sidewalk or the entrance to any
public building and it also references
paragraph three which talks about
breaches of the piece loud and
unreasonable noises annoyances threats
or disrupting the lawful assembly or
meeting of persons with lawful Authority
so if somebody were to come in here and
make loud noises and disrupt the
business of this committee that is
defined in chapter 6442 as disorderly
conduct and that would also apply to
Executive Council meetings for example
or any other government meeting select
board what have you so this really only
uh prevents towns from criminalizing the
peaceful and lawful assembly of people
uh as defined in in the United States
Constitution First Amendment and as well
as the New Hampshire Constitution uh and
whereas the courts have agreed that the
organ is passed by new Fields is
constitutional uh this statute would be
necessary if the legislature saw fit to
prevent more ordinances like that or to
nullify the new Fields ordinance
um I like I said I know we're over so
I'll wrap it up there but I'd be happy
to take any questions for this Witness
yes representative Turner
yeah um hopefully this question is
appropriate for you it probably could
have been directed at anyone I guess
what I'm struggling with is
um does this really hinge on the
question of whether or not the court
case challenging this
um was rightly or wrongly decided by the
courts and essentially if I'm getting it
right it could have worked its way up
through the system but it was sort of
nullified by the fact that everyone was
was acquitted in other words that versus
needing a new law versus the the
application of the the constitute excuse
me the Constitutional provision uh thank
you thank you for the question
um
so because uh all the defendants were
found not guilty uh my case was Noel
Prost but that did stop the appeals
process you can't appeal a not guilty
verdict I mean you could but that would
be kind of weird right
um so it did not it's not able to go up
to the state supreme court to to
definitively decide the
constitutionality
um but the courts the district court in
this case did
uh deny the motion to dismiss which had
the as applied uh challenge in it
um and they ignored that provision so
they didn't necessarily say that this
was constitutional but their the
interpretation of their order uh could
be construed that they had decided that
this was constitutional even as applied
um so this law would just clarify uh for
for any future cases any possible future
cases that towns do not have the right
to criminalize uh peaceful and lawful
assembly yeah it's one quick follow-up
sure so what would be your thought about
you you talked about if if something
like this were to come up again you know
would would this uh situation be
essentially processed by a case that did
make its way up the system and was
ultimately decided versus passing a new
law uh thank you for the question I I I
am not a lawyer so I can't speak
definitively to what you're saying
um I'm sure perhaps chairman Lin could
answer that for you um as a former
Supreme Court Justice and I I I'd defer
to him on that matter you know can can I
ask can I ask this question what um did
the um
in either in the in in the Court's
opinion in that case or in the or if you
know in this in the prosecutions you
know brief or memorandum to the court
was there any reference made to
in the decision to the fact that there
was uh you know that this that that
covid played a role in the Court's
decision the fact that there was uh I
mean was there anything for example like
saying you know people people who are
protesting peacefully in front of the
governor's house at a time of covert
they're going to be too close to each
other there might be some health issues
was there anything in the Court's
decision
predicating its decision in any way on
the covid situation uh I would have to
reread it to answer that for you
definitively I don't recall off the top
of my head I don't think so
um but I will reread that and I'd be
happy to submit
um the documents that I have that my
lawyer prepared uh from for my case to
the committee as well
other other questions yes representative
De Lorenzo
thank you Mr so um
on the day that you're arrested in
newfields were you there as a reporter
or as a member of the public yeah thank
you for the question I was there in my
official capacity as a reporter for New
Hampshire journal and I identified
myself to the police as such
other questions
thank you very much sir thank you
um now I'm going to call on Jason gearh
representative Jason Gerhart
good morning thank you welcome thank you
committee I
was actually one of the participants in
well that was there that night that the
tickets were issued so eight people were
issued tickets one was arrested
and the importance of this legislation
is just to reiterate the
we have to stick to the Constitution we
have to make it very clear that no
matter what office you possess in this
government state country
people can still Express themselves and
their concerns to you
because let's go back in time to when
this all was going down the governor
cancels the inauguration
so I believe it was that night actually
the candlelight vigil was planned
the vigil was for the victims of the
lockdown so people that were suffering
from drug overdoses suicides this really
messed a lot of people up people already
on the edge the whole covet thing kind
of pushed them off now we could argue
that it was necessary and all that and I
think events have proven that to be not
true but point being I all know we were
away over time so I just want to make
this quick and if anybody has questions
about the actual night's events but the
just the heavy-handed nature of the
whole situation was just insane I mean
you had to be there there's some videos
and Frank's a little bit out there but
he means well
um we it was just
it was surreal I mean we're just there
we're walking down that
the walkway that does abut his property
but it was all it's on public property
it's a right-of-way to this country
store down the street and next thing you
know all these state troopers show up
with the riot gear on it felt like
Hunger Games you don't have the shields
the I mean it was so unnecessary and I
understand it's to make a point to send
a message and all that but where are we
going to go from here if you can't
protest and it was not it was a
candlelight vigil there was no signs
there was nothing because we didn't want
the picketing issue
it was really for the victims of the
lockdown so if any questions I don't
want to Ramble On and On I know you got
to be on time but quick questions for
this Witness
can I do can I just ask right well I
know I have one question do you know
have has there been any effort within
the town of new fields to repeal the
ordinance no I think doing so would then
put them at liability of lawsuits well
there's already on lawsuits but if they
say that okay this is bad this is a bad
idea now it's okay now you're admitting
such it's all right are there any other
questions thank you very much sir thank
you all right uh
whoops I'm sorry anybody else uh wishing
to testify on HB 164.
all right seeing none I'm going to close
the hearing on 164.
and I know we're I know we're running
over I I would propose uh to go on to
169 and then we'll take uh a lunch break
so uh I'm gonna open the hearing on HP
um 169 relative to termination of
guardianship
uh
and um
we have uh
uh uh representative Smith I guess
you're the you're here as a sponsor yes
sir thank you
thank you Mr chairman and fellow
Representatives my name is Jonathan
Smith I represent Carroll County
District Five
I'm here to introduce HB 169 on behalf
of a constituent Linda Morgan who will
be testifying in Greater detail than
myself after I'm uh completed here this
comes about where
a one-year-old child
um
was uh
was given over to the grandparents at
the age of approximately one year old
due to habitual drug use on behalf of
both parents uh the child was subject to
mental trauma physical trauma uh this
child has autism
um the grandparent Linda Morgan received
custody of this child for a period of
almost six years
uh the parents then
supposedly were clean and wanted to
return custody of that child back to
themselves there was a long drawn-out
Court battle and unfortunately Linda
Morgan lost custody after raising this
child for a period I should say
guardianship I'm sorry after a period of
six years that's all this child knew
um even in the court hearing which I
think Linda's going to testify to
um
the level was preponderance of the
evidence which I'm not a lawyer but in
simple terms that's a 51 chance that it
was better to go back to the parents in
a situation like this I believe there
needs to be a higher standard this bill
changes at the clear and convincing
evidence that may not be the solution I
believe there probably needs to be
amendments so this doesn't happen again
but
the mental health and well-being of the
child needs to be taken into account the
situation that that child is living in
some may say this bill is an affront to
parental rights I believe it has to be a
balance between yes parental rights I'm
100 behind that but also the mental
health and well-being of that child
going forward especially at such a young
age where all that child knew growing up
for six years was the grandparent as
mama
um and now she was basically ripped from
her arms and given back to the parish so
this is a long long process it's com
it's complicated hopefully the great
minds in this committee can come up with
a solution to help alleviate this
problem for people like Linda Morgan and
many other people that unfortunately
wouldn't come testify tonight today
because they fear retaliation from
family members if they supported a bill
like this so I will take any questions
but I believe Linda Morgan will provide
a lot more detail she had provided a
written letter that she submitted to
governor sununu who does support the
idea of changing this or reminising this
problem that that this current law as it
sits
um
you know we
there needs to be something done here
put it simply
questions for this work yes
representative Grace
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative in the in subparagraph C
uh sub paragraph B should not apply if
guardianship of the person was granted
to a grandparent as a result of the
parents substance abuse or dependence
and yet in order to provide for
essential physical safety needs of the
minor of sub paragraph B would you not
also need to modify this to include any
form of abuse
not just substance abuse or depends
there's a reason why this child is not
in the custody of the parents but is in
the custody of some Guardian
in this case either not a grandparent or
other relative or a grandparent
so would we not need to amend this to
cover any other forms of abuse or is
that covered somewhere else in statute
I again I'm not a lawyer and I I
couldn't find anything particularly
being covered somewhere else but I think
again that's a great idea to make this
uh Bill stronger to take into account
the well-being of the child in a much
broader fashion rather than narrowly
focused
other questions yes representative
Turner yeah so uh building on what
representative greeson said it also
seems like limiting it to
um guardianship of a grandparent versus
any other
Guardian relative or not I'm not sure
why that the provision of a grandparent
stands out
it's a great question I can't answer
that why this was an existing this was
this was passed I believe back in 2017
and this is a modification of that like
from that time why it's subject to just
grandparents in here
again I'm not a lawyer unfortunately
this is above my pay grade
so
I'd be honest with you
yes question
as um as a labor and delivery nurse I
have seen
um over the years many
um
addicted children and often the
grandparents are the ones who end up
sometimes taking guardianship of that
child because the parents either have
left the child unattended after the
delivery
and gone back to Muse again or or they
just cannot physically
and mentally be able to care for that
child so um it often has been I've seen
where that the grandparents are the ones
who take guardianship over the child
other questions yes representative
balance
good afternoon
to
um
preponderance of the evidence
but there's a different standard in
paragraph 5A which would still be
um well you want to change it to clear
and convincing but paragraph 5A would
still be preponderance of the evidence
um
so I'm wondering about having two
different standards within the same
statute
sure so under B uh preponderance of the
evidence that's for the guardian has to
demonstrate by a preponderance of the
evidence that substitution or
supplementation parental care and
supervision is necessary to provide
essential physical safety needs of the
minor
so that's the case where
my understanding of it is it's that's a
51 chance preponderance of the evidence
if I put it in layman terms that the
guardian has to prove that it's
worthwhile that substitution is is
uh worth going back to the guardian
where I think in our case so when we
when I sent this bill to OLS they
changed both parts of it I was primarily
focused on C due to the drug use part
which changed it from preponderance of
the evidence which was 51 chance to
clear and convincing evidence which was
a higher bar again Layman turns is at a
70 chance I know Reasonable Doubt is
Criminal that's overwhelming clear 99 I
guess
so I think again through the amendment
process maybe B isn't necessary but I
definitely believe C is where the
corrections need to happen at least at
least in the case of Linda Morgan
other questions
all right thank you very much sir thank
you
uh next I'm going to call on Jonathan
Smith oh that was me oh I'm sorry
sorry about that Linda Morgan
good afternoon
thank you for allowing me to be here
today
this is my granddaughter Maya
she is with me in some form Wherever I
Go
let me first start by reiterating what
um representative Smith had stated um
that there are many many people that I
know of myself in my community in my
realm of friends
um and people who have reached out to me
that I've reached out to
um that are in this situation
and
they are afraid to speak out to stand up
um
because
they will risk most likely the
relationship that they have with that
child
um that they have today and that that
really shouldn't
shouldn't be a thing
I will share with you um as quickly as I
can I know time is an issue beginning
with the letter that I wrote to Governor
sununu back on October 10 2020.
I'm writing you today to ask that you
consider making changes to the
guardianship guidelines in our state
though each case is unique in its
standing the guidelines are overall
as I cannot speak for each case in the
state and each case has its own story I
can speak for mine
I've had my granddaughter in my home
under my care for then five years now
seven
she is
six years old now eight
and she is autistic
I have had permanent guardianship for
then three and a half years
a total of five and a half to almost six
years I am the only caregiver she has
known and I have provided for her
academic spiritual physical social
Financial emotional and mental health
needs with no help from either family or
parent
both parents are addicts in recovery
after several attempts by both they may
or may not be successful
as you know there is always the
possibility of relapse and Recovery is a
lifelong battle
both parents still have their parental
rights as it stands either parent could
ask the court to reverse the
guardianship
if this were to happen my granddaughter
would be taken out of the only home
that she has known
away from the only caregiver that she's
had
away from her community that has
established that she has established
roots in and that has enveloped her with
the environment of both support and love
away from her daily routines that keep
her growing successfully away from her
church family and church that she
strives in
away from her school and support network
and service providers away from our
friends away from her family
and away from everything that she has
learned to trust and love over the past
seven years
and be placed into a very different
community
with people that she's not familiar with
and who are strangers to her in a
different home with a different
caregiver different routines Etc
I don't believe that this is the best
choice that could be made for her
well-being
and after now seven years of nurturing
providing for love and support seeing to
services and providers encouraging her
success each day in seeing that she has
all that she needs to continue to grow
in a six into a successful young girl
despite her autism that that be taken
away from her it would be so unfair to
her in such a disadvantage after she has
come so far overcoming the effects of
Early Childhood trauma neglect and abuse
that she suffered in her first year and
a half of life
I am asking you to consider some kind of
guidelines that if a child is in a safe
healthy environment under guardianship
especially in permanent guardianship
cases for a period of time whether
that's 12 18 24 months whatever that may
look like that if the guardian is
willing to keep the guardianship
established permanently that that child
will not risk leaving a stable loving
nurturing environment that they can
thrive in and not be bounced into other
environments or situations that could
potentially cause them physical or
mental harm
the state is aware that the pandemic
that we are in at this time has caused
much Social and emotional turmoil for
our children not being able to
consistently be at school in a safe
environment throughout the day away from
their family routines and services
without their daily education and some
in harmful situations as there has been
support added to our school systems on
the return of the students into their
schools as we open this fall
imagine a child who cannot begin to
comprehend the situation and having to
change their environment altogether
it's a tremendously scary thing for
those individuals and I believe that we
are adding to the adverse childhood
Effects by doing so as well as the
strain on our mental health that it
causes and doing a disservice to those
young individuals
I feel that overall though our goal and
hope is to eliminate the strain put on
our children in New Hampshire in any
case that by continuing with the process
as it is we'll only continue to build
Ace
mental health issues and drug abuse in
the future
which is an ever-growing Circle that
needs to be broken
our children are being told in some
cases that no matter what it is that
they would like in life no matter what
they believe is most comfortable in some
cases even safe for them that that
actually does not matter overall because
they are at risk of being removed from a
safe loving nurturing environment and
being placed into something that may not
be what is best suited for their
individual needs and well-being
and in doing so we are actually creating
a horrific Circle which will continue to
put a strain on our mental health system
and create future turmoil and continue
the conflict of addiction from today's
children
they are not given the choice process in
their daily lives so how can they
determine good choices
or if they voice what is most
comfortable or fulfilling for them that
their voice does not matter
and the poor choices today
can lead to unlawfulness in our youth
as well as addiction
also in looking at the Americans
Disability Act a lot has happened over
the years in our state Alone by 2010 it
was clear that we had a serious drug
problem in New Hampshire by 2015 it
moved from a crisis situation and was
declared an epidemic
now we have a pandemic that we're faced
with yet past revisions in the Ada do
not seem accurate for what we and our
children have been faced with by this I
feel clearly that we are letting our
disabled citizens of New Hampshire down
the Ada is a complete umbrella but even
an umbrella holds multiple secure tips
to secure its own to support its own
canopy
I believe it's time for a change in
these areas and I believe it's now we
deserve better for our state and its
people and I know that you care for each
and every one of us I'm asking you today
to please consider changes for the
well-being of our children of New
Hampshire and to help provide for the
better future that each and every one of
them deserves
I have spoken to Governor sununu's
office I spoke to a few different people
down there several times one stands out
to mind his name was Preston
and um he said that this is something
that the governor would support
um something that um he looks for to um
to help our our state be stronger and to
help our children so I'm in hopes of
that
since I wrote that letter back in 2020
um
on August 29 2022
my granddaughter was forced to leave the
security and stability of her home that
she was raised in
she's been forced to leave a community
that um that supported her she's left
her church her school her friends the
close proximity of family she's two
hours away it's not easy
and this has greatly affected her
psychologically it has greatly affected
her
Maya suffers from PTSD as well as autism
due to the neglect and abuse an early
childhood Trauma from the environment
that she was forced to live in day in
and day out
she like so many others was born into
this you said yourself
um these children you know it's it's it
happens every day they're born into this
situation and
they they don't know better
um they don't know what it's like um
they deserve that and if someone can
provide that
that's a wonderful thing
we're adding to the trauma
and as we uproot them from a safe and
stable thriving environment
this as I said is my granddaughter Maya
this is her school picture from 2021 in
September
at the bottom you'll see there's a
banner and it says
let your smile change the world but
don't let the world change your smile
she has this on other of her photos as
well
but Maya is not smiling this year
she's broken and she's confused
you see it's hard to smile
when some when the world around you has
made a decision that will drastically
change your life
at this point
I don't know when I'm going to see this
little girl again
the last time I saw her was Christmas
evening
as in the darkness I watched her cross
the street up in Littleton
in her pajamas and her boots
she clutched a new toy under her arm
because she made her way up the
crosswalk she realized that I was
standing there she didn't even know she
was going to see me and when she
recognized me she stopped
and she called my name
and I said yes sweetie it's me
she ran as fast as she could to jump in
my arms and she just told me she loved
me so much how much she missed me
and how she hasn't seen me in Forever
I was so thankful for that night that I
was able to see her
but as I said I don't know
but I'm gonna be able to see her again
I told her when it was time to pack her
up the next day and send her back home
that I wasn't sure when I would see her
again but I hoped it would be soon
and I had to help her understand
that fact
and she doesn't clearly but I did
reassure her that I would see her one
day
and until then
she will be in my heart
and I will be in hers as well
she gave me a kiss and told me she loved
me and she hoped it was soon
she got into the truck and drove away
Maya and the children of this state
deserve to receive the security that
they can continue to thrive in an
environment full of love support and
compassion to be nurtured and to
continue to be successful without
interruption and I hope today is the day
that we can start making a difference in
the lives of the children
of this state all right thank you
questions for this wish yes
representative Greece thank you Mr chair
and thank you for
I don't even this is a gut punch I don't
even can't even begin to unders to
wow
we're dealing with terms like
clear and convincing evidence or
preponderance of evidence
what was the evidence that was provided
to a judge that enabled your
granddaughter to be then taken from you
in the stable environment and placed
with one or both parents
that you what what was that evidence
that allowed that to facilitate that
decision
it was a long it was a long drawn out a
few years of of going back and forth but
um pretty much
he needed a place of residence
which is an address
um and some source of income
and um
he is told the court that he hasn't
worked for a few years he's been
unemployed
so
you know I I don't understand it they
don't understand it
and that's basically what he needed
other questions yes representative Perez
I had someone approach me at church two
weeks ago in this type of situation
um must have been looking through
different articles this particular
person
um
took a year a grandfather to get their
grandson out of dcyf okay and
um he said the only way he was able to
get around this fear of having the child
taken away from him was he took another
seven months and adopted this child did
you ever consider trying to adopt her I
don't know the process I certainly did
it's not an easy process I don't um you
know I would have had to somehow
um
terminate both parents rights
I don't have the right to do that
they were in rehab so it's not about
abandonment they were In and Out Of
Reach several rehabs over several years
it's not abandonment even though they're
not providing for they're not caring for
they're not contacting
yes
that explains the difference
um his son was was in jail so okay um I
applaud you I'm a grandparent
I applaud you thank you other questions
for this Witness
I I guess I just have I I just have a
couple so am I understanding I just want
to make sure I'm sure that I am
your
the way that the guardianship that
you're telling us about was terminated
was
there was a proceeding by one or both of
the parents
to have custody of of your granddaughter
return to them and you had a
Court proceeding in which they were
successful yes we had a lengthy two-day
proceeding but three years of back and
forth right and and and I I take it you
think that the court made the wrong
decision in that case I do and and did
was there an appeal taken to the Supreme
Court about that I can't appeal it
you can't I've been told I cannot appeal
it there is nothing to appeal because of
the language in our system okay all
right other anybody else have any other
questions
all right thank you very much mayor
thank you
um Brian Clark
oh we have two people go sure yes in the
interest of time yeah so tell us just
tell us who you are please hi I'm Brian
Clark in the interest of time I'd like
to have Beth margason with dcyf speak
for me okay sure
thank you very much uh chair Lynn and
members of the committee we appreciate
the time to be heard this afternoon and
we'll be brief
um we don't take a position on this on
this uh piece of legislation as it does
not really uh pertain to dcyf however
there is one section that would affect
dcyf If This Were to go through the be
the change to B to a preponderance of
the evidence dcyf would need to have a
carve out
for that section to keep it at clear and
convincing evidence because we do
guardianships as permanency plans that
are done with the consent of the parent
under the adoption and safe family act
and that is actually referenced in your
in this in this
um statute as a number
463 colon 5 3D
whether guardianship is being sought by
the department as part of the permanent
plan for a child in the Department's
custody because pursuant to the adoption
and say families act and so if this were
changed to a preponderance of the
evidence that would not make our
permanency plans when we do have
guardianship which we Ms Morgan is no
longer here unfortunately but sometimes
we do have guardianships that are our
permanency plan and in order for them to
really remain permanent we would need
that higher evidentiary standard of
clear and convincing evidence
um so that would be the Department's
concerns about this and asking for a
carve out on it
um I did note just looking at this
occasionally dcyf does have to use the
guardianship statute
um the the
the standards for establishing
a guardianship If This Were to change
the standards for terminating it there
would be some incongruence there so that
may be something for the uh depart the
committee to look at but um those are
our comments on this bill the first
comments are just particular to dcif and
the need for a carve out and just a
general comment just looking at it as
somebody who does deal with the statute
from time to time the different
standards for establishing and
terminating a guardianship would change
if this bill were to go through all
right thank you uh questions for this
Witness
so I I see none I guess I do have great
I want to make sure when you say
are you saying that
when you talk about a dcyf carve out are
you saying that you that legally there
would be one that would be required are
you just saying that it would
that dcyf would not like to have the
standard lowered because it might make
it it might make
permanently planning more difficult yes
because as We Know
standard makes it more difficult to to
um to upset them to upset them okay so
that's whether or not that's required by
the adoption and say families act which
is a federal law I do not know okay all
right
any other questions for this Witness
thank you very much thank you very much
we appreciate the time
now
great all right thanks very much
thank you
very much
foreign
okay
good job okay
thank you
foreign
okay
I'll be here okay
thank you
foreign
pick up
um House Bill uh 187 FN
and I will recognize the primary sponsor
representative
regini
chairman Lynn members of the House
Judiciary Committee thank you for the
opportunity to introduce HBU 187 this is
the short one sentence bill and I will
try to keep my testimony equally short
uh currently uh only the sheriff has the
power and authority to serve criminal or
civil process and enforce civil orders
from any Court the fee structure for the
service is based on mileage the farther
away the sheriff office is from where
processes serve the higher the fees
in areas of New Hampshire where the
county office Sheriff's Office is
centrally located this works out okay
in more rural areas such as the town of
Grafton
the the
um this results in very high fees
Grafton County Sheriff lists mileage to
Grafton to be 135 miles with total
mileage fee of
88.43 and about two and a half hours on
the road round trip
for comparison serving the same process
in Haverhill where the sheriff office is
located is only 9.83 the difference
between 88 dollars and nine dollars when
the service being provided is the same
to the taxpayer is painful for residents
of Grafton
uh there are many ways to solve this
problem we can change the fee structure
away from mileage but I believe the
mileage is actually the most reasonable
way to do this since the cost of the
service is directly passed down to the
customer this leads to Greater
transparency and more efficiency
we could also move the sheriff to a more
central location in the county this is
obviously not a practical solution for
various reasons including Staffing and
the fact that the Sheriff's Office
performs many other duties which benefit
from being close to the county
courthouse the prison and other County
offices
the solution is in this bill is to
Simply delegate the task of serving
process to a department closer to where
the work needs to be done thus
eliminating the long drive and the high
fees local police also have the
advantage of knowing their town and
their people and how to find somebody to
serve process who may be trying to avoid
being served
I have received many objections in
talking to my County sheriff and and
local police Chiefs so the three main
objectives objections are that local
police don't have the resources of St or
Staffing to serve process
my response to this objection is that
the bill is purely enabling legislation
it does not require the local police to
serve process it merely enables them to
do so if a police chief does not think
serving process is good policy for their
Department then they will not be
required to do so
local the other argument is the local
police can't afford to do this my intent
with the bill is for local police to be
able to use the same or similar fee
structure as used by the sheriff in
discussing this with my local police
chief he says he currently receives
payment when someone updates with the
sex offender registry therefore
accepting fees for service is something
police departments already do
the third argument is that local police
should concentrate on crime I think this
is certainly a valid argument and the
prerogative of the police chief again
this bill does not require police
departments to change their process it
merely enables them if they choose to do
so
uh Grafton police chief is neutral on
this bill but understands the reason for
it and says he will take the extra
training as necessary to be able to
provide the service to Grafton residents
you will note that the the language in
the bill includes a lot more than simply
authorizing service of process the
staffer who wrote this bill explained
that this particular statute has not
been updated in a very long time and the
additional language is to make sure the
duties police departments are already
performing to not inadvertently get
excluded
finally I have two Amendment requests if
you look at the fiscal note on the bill
it uh the municipal Association found
that the bill has written would not
allow the local police department to
collect fees I ask that an amendment be
made to allow Police Department to
collect the necessary fees and also to
mirror that fee structure to um there of
the sheriff office
um and it was brought another uh
amendment that would be helpful is it
was brought to my attention that while
the language in this bill has taken
almost verbatim from RSA 1046 the
statute authorizing Sheriff to serve
process and enforce orders there was one
part missing as it relates to the
enforcement of civil orders in RSA 1046
there is a condition on civil order
enforcement to say quote notwithstanding
any law to the contrary end quote and I
ask that the same language carry on much
of this bill I'm happy to assist a
member of this Committee in drafting the
amendment and finally this bill was
requested by constituent in Grafton uh
thank you and with that I'll take any
questions
from members of the committee
yes representative Perez
thank you
why
are the sheriff's departments opposed to
this do you know
I'm sure they will tell you but it's
it's I guess it's one of their main
revenue streams and it's something they
already do
um it's some in
uh in talking to my to my County Sheriff
he you know he's opposed to this bill
but he understands the reason you know
it's kind of math right it's nine
dollars uh for to for him to serve
papers in Haverhill and 88 dollars
that's that's a large markup
um so he understands that part of it but
it's um you know that's something the
sheriffs do and the local police don't
and so I think a lot of it is just kind
of going with what's what um
yes
I also um spoke with the sheriff in my
area as well and he was opposed to it I
see where it is a bigger issue for more
remote towns in um
in in New Hampshire is there I guess it
has to be either one for all or all for
one correct it couldn't be that maybe
we're
um more like in Grafton County whereas
I'm in Londonderry so
um
you know we're more condensed
I can say that so I represent uh four
towns two of the police Chiefs said
they're opposed to this bill one of them
didn't get back to me and then the
Grafton police she said he's willing you
know he's neutral on the bill but he's
willing to do it if it passes for
Grafton
um so I think it's not so much a concern
that suddenly a whole bunch of police
departments in New Hampshire are going
to start doing this and that will take
money from the sheriff I think there
will only be a small number that are
willing to do this and it's it's
probably going to be places where the
town is very far from the just like
Grafton they're very far and it makes
sense for them to do it
that's right representative Smith did
you have a question
oh I'm sorry no then representative uh
yes representative thank you Mr chair uh
thank you for taking my question
uh you said this is optional uh I I
don't see where it is
but uh that doesn't mean that it's not
optional so uh but it I do have a
question that uh I would assume that
this is something that if it is adopted
it would be County White
well I'm not sure what you mean it would
be the local Chief it would be up to
them whether they offer the services it
would be up to the local chief
so that the the County Commissioners
wouldn't have any say in it
be in it no
the county would not like well like
uh
well
that answers my question thank you
representative Morgan
um have there been any issues with uh
the Grafton County sheriff or any other
Sheriff refusing to um
refusing to file a criminal or civil
processes that you're that uh
your constituents want to have filed for
whatever reason
so the the reason for this bill in the
first place is I have a constituent that
has had issues with the county sheriff
and that's the reason for the bill
um you know it is it is two hours of
driving so
the sheriff probably has to plan this
ahead of time that he's going to have
somebody come out and so it's not
something they can just do on a moment's
notice and one of the issues that this
constituent has had is that he knows
where somebody is that needs to be
served and if he calls up the sheriff
and says hey I know where the guy is he
might not be there for for long can you
serve him you know the sheriff is
physically limited by an hour and 20
minute drive to get there and that that
obviously makes things a lot harder
can these um
does this function have to be just the
sheriff himself or herself or can they
send a uh a deputy to do that instead
would say yes they can send the deputy
sure and um
and maybe a follow-up a second follow-up
and
um do you have any reservations about uh
eroding the historical role of the
counties and the sheriffs which are
different from that of the
municipalities and the police forces of
course that may be uh there may be a
relic of an error when the sheriff's had
much wider Powers than they do today but
like is is there do you have any
reservations about
allowing the municipality to take on a
function that for you know really
centuries has been the uh within the
purview of the county
and the uh and the court system who
I I think that this bill tries to solve
a specific problem in the simplest way
possible
um there there are other ways that were
suggested for example instead of having
the local police do it to have
um you can have bounty hunters I guess
or or a Justice of the Peace sort of
process so you know that's another way
where you don't involve the local police
in in doing the Civil process but that
that seems like that would be a much
larger piece of legislation than simply
enabling the local police to do it if
they choose so
all right representative D Lorenzo
thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my question you
know on its face this bill seems like a
symbol built
um authorizing our Law Enforcement
Officers to serve um criminal or civil
process and to enforce civil orders
issued by any court but when I look on
page two
session 105 colon 3 line four
all police officers are by virtue or
their appointment constables and
conservatives of the peace they shall
have the authority to serve criminal and
or civil processes investigate crimes in
voice civil orders issued by any court
and to pursue and apprehend criminals
that have
that have been that that they have in
their respective jurisdictions
um
as far as um the pursuant
but so and so bomb in apprehensible
criminals is that the law now that
any
local PD can
pursue
criminals
wherever they are I believe it is and
that was the way it was explained to me
by the staffer who wrote this bill
so have you had any feedback from local
departments on how they feel about you
know
people from other districts going into
their District to pursue criminals
I don't believe this lets them do that
it specifically says in their
jurisdiction at the end
see now I guess I do have a couple I
guess what I'm wondering is have
have you talked to any police
departments that have said they want to
do this in other words I realize this is
only a proposed authorization but
unless I'm missing my guess I don't
think you're going to have a lot of
police departments that are going to say
oh yeah we want to start doing this
unless
you know they're going to go to their
towns and say we want we need three more
officers uh here's here's how much the
budget's going to increase
so I spoke to three police Chiefs out of
the four times that represent two of
them one of them is just against it one
of them is very against it and one of
them is neutral so none of them are for
it the one who's neutral is for is
grafton's police chief and he
understands the problem it's the most
acute and Grafton so he you know he's if
the bill passes he's willing to to go
through the process to help craft and do
this
other question yes representative Tripp
thank you Mr chair
I I still don't understand
the adoption process
so this is something that would be done
on a Town by Town basis
it's just it just enables the police
chief to offer this as a service this it
would be they either offer it or they
don't and
if they have the resources or they can
hire the resources if they think there
will be enough demand
well
if they're going to be delivering uh
notices or whatever how would they
obtain these notices that uh because I
I've been served a couple times myself
as a function of being on the town
console not not because I did something
wrong
yeah
and uh
and uh you know these came from
uh
like the state or something so you know
how How would how would that be
accommodated because you know for them
to serve the papers they have to get the
papers in some manner you know and the
people that are do
providing the papers to be served they
have to know
that the police are doing this now and
not the county sheriffs so how is this
going to work out
is it well this doesn't uh it's still up
to the sheriff that's the last line of
sort of it's their responsibility to do
it this just allows the local police to
do and it and it could be that in
particular case of Grafton uh if the
sheriff can't come out he could uh ask
the police the local police to do it for
example
right so if the sheriff has the the
paperwork and and they you know it's
going to be in our a 135 Mile Drive they
could uh send it to the local police
chief to to perform that to drive out
and serve the papers
yeah well thank you very much other
other questions I have just I guess I
have just one other question you
mentioned that this was a you proposed
to set the request of a constituent can
I just ask other than this one
constituent I mean
do we is there any evidence that there's
sort of a Groundswell of complaints
among the citizens that you know my God
you know this is this is a huge issue
that that uh the sheriffs are the ones
that serve process and
um we got to change this
so uh I can give the example by way of
why one of the Chiefs was very much
against this bill is he believes that if
the bill passes even if even if it's
optional he believes that some business
owners in the town will will demand that
he provide the service
so there is definitely there would
definitely be a demand for this
thank you other questions
I'm sorry next we have uh William Wright
the uh Sheriff from belnet
foreign
from here I'm like all right sure
chairman members of the committee thank
you for having us today my name is
William Wright I've spent 24 years as a
full-time law enforcement officer here
in the state of New Hampshire I'm
currently the sheriff of Belknap County
and I'm in my second term uh today I'm
here to testify in opposition to house
bill 187.
I said thank you uh Mr chair and members
of the committee my name is David Croft
I am currently the Merrimack County
Sheriff I'm on my second term and I'm in
my 40th year in law enforcement and I
too am here to testify in opposition to
this
okay for consideration and determination
uh on the need for such legislation as
proposed in this house bill 187 month
one must examine the past practices in
the current legislation currently on
hand
the sheriff and sheriff's deputies are
clearly our our roles and
responsibilities are clearly defined in
RSA 104
and specifically RSA 104 colon 5.
further our powers are also defined in
RSA 1046 there's remedies for neglect of
Duty which is found in 104 colon 10
which if we don't serve civil process uh
accordingly or if we refuse to do it
there are penalties that that we have to
face specifically as the sheriff
various writs and precipes uh they get
delivered to the Sheriff's Office
in many different manners
some of them are emailed some of them
are handed directly by the clerk of
court some are done to The Postal
Service and others are when the
respondent actually comes to the
Sheriff's Office and delivers the
paperwork in hand
should this particular bill become law
the question is going to come into play
as to where these papers are taken in
who reports what paperwork was taken in
who they're reporting it to who collects
the fees how many more government
entities are involved in this process
how do the sheriffs if we're ultimately
responsible for this under the law
currently under 104
how are we going to determine what local
departments have decided today that they
want to serve the process and tomorrow
they do not
we go before the delegation each
respected Sheriff goes uh before the
delegations
to ask for uh monies for personnel right
and salary lines and we staff based on
what we project is going to happen in
the future we don't have the ability to
necessarily say well one Town's going to
ask us to or they're going to ask to
serve the paperwork today but not
tomorrow we don't we can't predict that
and staff that way
other things that we got to look at is
whether or not local departments there's
over 240 police departments spread
across the state of New Hampshire
out of those
some of them work some of the time some
work all of the time you know they have
24 hours seven day a week coverage
others do not this then comes into a
complexity as to what political
pressures are happening uh for those
people who are asking for the Civil
process or the writs and precepts to be
delivered
if they don't have the Staffing on at
that given time who's then responsible
for it is it the sheriff
is it the the local PD
is it controlled by the Selectmen or or
that particular city council those are
all questions that are uh complex as it
relates to just this enabling uh statute
as it was proposed
other things that we got to look at is
uh the sheriff's offices have been
around since the 1800s we were the first
former law enforcement uh here in our
state and we've been doing these tasks
since that time
we have people who are trained in civil
process civil laws as well as the
service of all the documents that come
from the courts or competent
jurisdiction
we're the go-to people but when local
departments don't know what to do with
this stuff
we're also the ones that report
everything that we have to our
commissioners and to our Representatives
also making up the delegations
it's not a huge Revenue stream we do not
uh we are not a a for-profit business if
you will
we we operate Sheriff's offices and we
try to offset
um our budgets based on some of the
revenue that comes in through civil
process
this civil process is customer based
it's it's people who own uh properties
and are asking for services to be done
that's according to law
as a relation to that again it's
offsetting the costs for the for the
remainder of the taxpayers that are
paying for the services of the sheriff's
office which again when you look at RSA
104 it describes four primary functions
that Sheriff's offices are required for
in uh serving and executing uh written
precepts are one of those
okay one of the things I I first off I I
certainly concur with what my um what my
uh bordering Sheriff said to uh to to
all of you one of my concerns is that
when this bill first was uh brought I um
had a lot of conversation with the
police Chiefs within my County I haven't
spoken with all of them but I've spoken
with the majority of them and I think
you're probably all aware uh right now
as far as law enforcement is concerned
we're in a terrible Place one that I've
never seen in the 40 years that I've
been involved in law enforcement and
when I say that I'm talking about
recruitment the latest numbers with our
state police are somewhere about 80
Troopers down my County Jail is down
approximately 35 correctional offices
the numbers in our County state prisons
are close to a hundred and this this is
going uh right out into my local police
departments as well
um I received a call from one of my
Deputy Chiefs in my largest community in
Merrimack County last night asking if I
could render assistance in handling
calls because they are so down on
Personnel that they're they're very
concerned about being able to put out a
whole Force so my point being is
um when when they saw this bill coming
they were very concerned that if this
was an option that was going to be
available for a citizen to come and ask
that this process be done by them
they're very concerned that they are not
going to have the Personnel to be able
to do this uh and I know that the
representative presenting presenting the
bill indicated that this isn't going to
be a requirement but
I I will tell you that my police Chiefs
are very very concerned that they're not
having enough people to handle their
daily calls now if they were to be
inundated with something like this they
don't know how they could handle it
I too have reached out to the police
chief of the largest or largest uh City
in my County which happens to be Laconia
and chief Canfield indicated to me that
he has zero interest in having uh
himself or his Personnel out serving
civil process or doing the business of
the sheriff uh within his uh City and he
probably has the best staffed the most
staffed Department in our County as well
as they're probably one of the better
trained so having that it builds concern
for me for uh even the smaller
jurisdictions that we predominantly
support So in closing I ask that you
find House Bill 187 in expedient to
legislature and that will conclude my
testimony anything further you want to
say sure no thank you all right
questions for from the committee
representative Morgan do you have a
question yes thank you under
I mean this uh your history goes a long
way back and I guess back when you
started doing this you did many of the
functions of the court clerks but that
was a long time ago but my question is
under the current system what's our
quality control is there on the civil
and criminal processes do you have to
file just any piece of paper that
anybody thinks is a valid civil or
criminal process or who likes or brief
processes it for you before you take it
out and try to serve it
so it's vetted by the courts so we get
predominantly the court paperwork that
comes in and we'll take a look at that
in my particular case I have a Civil
Division supervisor that will look at
that paperwork and ensure that there's
no uh immediate issues that we can see
that might violate somebody's
constitutional rights as we are the only
constitutional officers uh uh here and
um
we also if there is a problem we contact
the courts immediately before it goes
out for service to make sure that
whatever is the problem is rectified
before we get there
I also representative have that same
type of procedure in place
and um oh
and we uh so you if so if we pass this
bill then the police officers wouldn't
have the same relationship with the
courts or I would
I don't know if I could answer that
and my last one which your counties are
both much smaller than Grafton or co-osh
but is that
you you personally have to serve these
Ritz or can you send a deputy who might
be located closer to the destination of
the because we heard a lot from the
prime sponsor about the whatever the 65
mile round trip or whatever is from
North Haverhill down to down to Grafton
but I assume the Grafton County Sheriff
must have a hole you've got several
deputies who are probably anytime
working in different parts of the county
is that chewing your slightly smaller
counties that is correct I have a civil
unit consisting of five deputies
and in Belknap County I have several
deputies that are out there so they have
the ability everything has to start at
the sheriff's office so we can log that
paperwork and we can vet that paperwork
to ensure that there are no problems so
uh traditionally that's where the
mileage starts is where that home base
is so where the paperwork comes in and
yes they do concentrate on certain areas
in our particular case uh and this is a
process just for my agency Alone
um deputies will pick certain towns that
they're going to go in sort of
processing in any given day Barnstead is
probably one of the furthest away
between Barnstead and Central Harbor so
they'll they'll take the paperwork for
them towns as well as any corresponding
town that might be to and from in the
well sort of a group of paperwork at
that given time great thanks thanks
other questions from members of the
committee
thank you very much
um Anson Smith there's Anson Smith here
to testify
so you support the bill
but
thank you
there's no form up front if I want to go
someplace like to a website or even make
a telephone call to find out did this
warrant get served and I'm talking right
now mostly about benchmarks so this is
something where someone didn't show up
in court or
for some reason the judge
wants them to show up the next time
so uh there's no way you can go can you
go on a website and say okay here's my
one what's the process where is it has
it been served no no call up the
sheriff's office and they don't seem to
know a lot about what's going on up
there either they didn't know how many
warrants they had out for service they
didn't know how many had accumulated
they didn't know how many they get per
month or for anyway so I filed the uh I
think you guys call him a pretty
Information Act
and found out that in the county in the
Grafton County Sheriff's Department he
told the sheriff told me in writing he
gets 13 of these things in a six month
period in time boy there's an overload
for you
okay I also want to make mention of you
people have been around a little while
some 10 or more years ago they started
doing video things for the court in
other words these sheriffs used to be
trotting these perps around in Crown
Vics
taking them to their Court hearings and
bringing them back well a lot of that
has been done away with it I don't know
how much
but I didn't hear any Sheriff's coming
around and said well gee we got some
extra people now we don't have to drive
all these people around
but now we come up with something we
might not ask them to do I know they
don't have their personnel okay
there's two sides of this coin uh
the
business about Grafton being at the
other end of the county
where is the price for Hayward was worth
fifteen dollars or something and for me
it's uh it's over a hundred the the
actual fee was structured as I think you
just mentioned that but then there's uh
some other fees that go on top of that
um
and we don't know whether we got it done
I want to take you back now too or
something I don't know if any of you
people remember this this took place I
believe in
2017 I think there was a fellow named
Jesse Campbell
who was shot to death in the car in the
town of Grafton you know I wonder if you
could tell sir I I what
I guess I want to know you how is this
relevant to the issue here of service of
of process by someone other than the
sheriff
I think what I'm trying to tell you
these sheriffs really don't have a lot
to do and they're going to step up now I
don't know about this Europe but that
sheriff so so but I guess I'm I'm not
clear I mean
if you want the sheriffs to do more it's
not clear to me how allowing the local
police to take away some of the
sheriff's work is going to have the
sheriff doing more
I want to get my job done all I want is
my warrant served I don't really care
who does it's going to be lawful
so they need this will be other people
options I don't care if we point bounty
hunters
I'm willing to pay for it these people
the sheriff does not even find people
they never show up in court and then
when they do show up in court if they
finally get snapped and which I
sometimes make a rumble yeah we had one
guy come in and they they
forced them to put a bail for his next
hearing right well don't you know the
next hearing come around he didn't show
up before this bill
this is just the court system in this
state is atrocious I'm talking a civil
cycle not talking criminal but I want to
reference a criminal case in Grafton
that resulted in the death of a person
who did not get served
this guy's name was Jesse Jesse um
championing
he died and grafted I think it was 2017
or thereabouts he was pursued because he
was eluding the police and Nano Chase
and alleged drug thing that person
was put on the was a criminal warrant
was issued him for a year before that
event they finally caught up to him in a
snow field and and uh
Canaan was King yeah it was Canada New
Hampshire
and he fled and threatened or whatever
they shot him to death he's gone
so
why did he why did it take a year for
them to serve this guy it was a million
times along the way when they could have
served him when he maybe wasn't high or
he was wasn't excited or curbed or
whatever it was this is a mess
and that's the criminal side I'm dealing
with the the Civil side no one thinks
the process is important
it is important for this for the normal
conduct of business now I'm a landlord
if I can't collect my money
what do I have to do I either take the
loss or you have to bury that on into
the cost of housing going forward
because certain people are just not
going to pay and there's some of those
out there
so this is something that is required
for the normal contact of a business in
a society
and in the state
so there's many other reasons but
and again all right I may have more
problems with Grafton County Sheriff
than I do with those two guys with the
guns behind me
all right questions for this Witness
any questions all right thank you very
much sir appreciate your testimony okay
thank you all right is there anyone else
here to testify
on um HB 187.
here for you or any just anybody that
might be able to is there any kind of
tracking on these documents
that sounded to me like the biggest
complaint he had was that there was no
tracking of these documents
representative we have a software
program referred to as IMC Bell map does
as well as soon as we get the
documentation in the office it goes into
the computer system and it's tracked all
the way up to
um the date served and a lot of them
have restrictions on they need to be
served in a certain amount of time
that's our Safeguard as well to to
ensure that that's done
you know just just for your information
just based upon my experience in the
court I mean if they're if something has
if process has been issued by the court
yes there is a track I mean you know if
uh if service hasn't been made there is
going to be inquiries made about you
know periodically I can't tell you
exactly how often but there will
definitely be inquiries made about what
why hasn't this happened what's going on
that kind of thing
other questions
um all right I guess we're no no
additional Witnesses so I'm going to
close the hearing then on uh HB 187.
sorry thank you I'm going to open the
hearing on
cacr-5 uh relating to fundamental rights
providing that the constitution protects
the right to marry
and
um
ah all right representative Hines
uh thank you for the record Dan Hines um
ton of Bedford representing Hillsboro
too uh says the Constitutional Amendment
um pretty straightforward one line it
says the right to marry shall be a
fundamental right and I think that's
something a lot of us take for granted
um it's something that um various Court
decisions have applied
um the issue is in my opinion uh there's
no specific constitutional right to
marry so while it comes by implicit
things due process Etc
um we're at the will of Any Given Court
finding that there is no right to marry
um so this is partly in response to the
you know Supreme Court decision last
year Dobbs B Jackson
um where in the minority opinion
um questioned whether some of the
underlying cases that dealt with this
might want to be Revisited uh I don't
expect the current Court favorably
revisit some of those prior cases but we
don't know what a future Court might do
some of those cases include loving V
Virginia which gives constitutional
right to marry based on race and I know
the next bill on this committee is going
to address would countify that in state
law I would support that the other being
of um I'm going to mispronounce it Phil
V Hodges in 2015 which I'm codified
same-sex marriage and New Hampshire even
though those are constitutional rights
we we even have it in law for the
same-sex marriage um again that bill
after this um
the bill sponsor is seeking to add race
to which I think is a good thing so the
reason this is needed like I said is we
just I think people should
they have a constitutional right to
marry they expect constitutional right
to marry and at the end of the day this
does put in front of the voters um so I
think certainly should be up to the
voters to decide whether they believe
they have a constitutional right to
marry uh in regards to the language of
the bill it is uh trying to make it as
simple as possible so it says says the
right to marry shall be a fundamental
right at the end of the day as we all
know Constitutional Amendments and
rights are not
um unlimited
um speech being example
um right self-defense being examples
there's many limitations on those rights
and courts will appropriately apply
analysis to that so this doesn't cover
every right
um the reason I worded the bill as I did
is the I just mind it as simple as
possible for voters
um so it was my thought process that
it's implicit in the language of the
bill that it would be dealing with
consensual marriages
um so that's why I didn't put in age in
the bill I would expect the bill itself
to apply to people in the majority the
reason I put a specific age is
um I guess I felt it was inappropriate
to do that but if it were worded as
majority I think then the legislature
could change that further down the line
if need be
um
uh if the committee did want to amend it
to make it clear that it doesn't apply
to children or otherwise Limited in some
fashion I would still support the bill
and I'd be happy to take any questions
questions for this witness yes
representative Alexander thank you Mr
chair thank you representative for
taking my question
um so we're talking about marriage
between two people
but what I'm concerned about is you have
a marriage between eight people right
and and you could see the runaway
problems when you grant a constitutional
right and I understand that sometimes
it's limited in some fashion but would
you be amenable to amending that to a
marriage between two people is a
fundamental right
I mean I guess I think the voters should
decide whether they want that
um I guess my position would be the
religious
I guess it's not my preference but if
that were to be limited it still would
provide things that I think are
important to be there so
um that's the best way for me answer
that um did you see could you see like
somebody petitioning the court to allow
for another marriage should this be put
in the Constitution and then it could
just create a lot more problems than
just like specifying it to begin with
I guess I could foresee someone doing
that um and I think the court would
appropriately
apply some type of strictness scrutiny
um at the end of the day
um I would leave it up to the courts
what they're going to do with that
um so I I guess that
I foresee that could happen
other questions
representative Smith
yes
um thank you I I've been looking at
um
the Constitution part first
and I was interested that you chose
Article 5 rather than for example
um Article 2
which talks about certain natural
essential and inherent rights
um
uh
seeking and obtaining happiness
um yeah I guess there's no real reason
for me picking 5A right to marry I have
to just made it cleaner uh but yeah if
it were to amend article two to add the
word marriage after right it's like I
guess I would support that as well
so it's just a I guess a drafting
decision on my behalf that I just
thought it was mean that way but um yeah
I can to your point of why I should be
into and if
I could just follow up
um uh following the theory of
forewarned
um
are you proposing this amendment because
of the additional language in Dobbs
where one of the justices
perhaps a little more enthusiastically
than one would hope from a Justice
anticipated other areas in which the
court might seek to live it
um
personal rights yeah I think that's the
driving point of why it's important to
do that now um at the end of the day I'm
always in favor of the State
Constitution codifying further rights
that are also in the Federal
Constitution so there's no reason we
can't do that
um because the state constitution could
also go beyond and provide additional
rates so
um yes that is part of the premise like
I said I don't think the current Court
would do anything but I think it's a
good thing to essentially codify
something I believe people
want and think they have
thank you
any other questions
thank you very much sir thank you all
right
the next bill uh is is we're a little
just a couple of minutes early so I
guess I'll
oh I'm still I'm sorry good point anyone
else to testify on cacr5
therefore I'm going to close the hearing
on cacrify thank you
um
this black
foreign
welcome representative Ming I know we've
spoken on the phone that's right
to meet you yes yes uh so my my thoughts
are a little a little more prepared and
um maybe a little flowery for for this
um this situation but I'll start with um
chairman Lynn Vice chair Wallace and
members of the Judiciary Committee my
name is Ben Ming I'm a state
representative from Hollis and I am the
prime sponsor of HB 240 a bill with
bipartisan sponsorship I thank you for
the time I have I have before you to
introduce what I will refer to as the
marital Freedom Act in short this bill
seeks to assert the validity of
interracial marriage entered into within
the state of New Hampshire
it is likely that many of you are aware
of the recently passed respect for
Marriage Act the federal law that
protects same-sex and interracial
marriages
that law protects the validity of a
same-sex or interracial marriage of a
couple that as an example is validly
married in Maine but now lives in New
Hampshire
the marital Freedom Act seeks to make
race a non-factor in determining whether
any particular New Hampshire marriage is
valid
on the second generation
chinese-american and my wife is a third
generation irish-american
although this bill matters to me
personally I'm here to make the best
comprehensive case for this bill and how
it helps the state of New Hampshire its
citizens and its future
we have an aging State and a Workforce
that at best is sufficient but tricking
there's no single answer to that problem
because younger workers must consider
income costs housing and lifestyle in
determining where they will raise their
families
increased income can't come with
increased costs
a family-friendly lifestyle won't matter
if there's nowhere to live
so we should support growing families
and in passing the marital Freedom Act
we can take a step towards showing that
New Hampshire has the modern values that
will attract and retain the people who
will make up our future Workforce
we were new englanders and don't take
the change easily so I should make the
point that supporting modern values
doesn't mean leaving behind spirit and
tradition
the core of Granite State values can be
seen and how tenaciously we fight for
small people focus governance
volunteers making important Community
decisions on Town boards
The Advocate the advocacy for the
efficient use of limited funds
and a staunch belief that government
doesn't get a say in what we do that
doesn't affect others
in other words our rights of privacy
marriage and interracial marriage in
particular is one of those rights of
privacy
there are currently no New Hampshire
laws that address interracial marriage
but absence is no indication of security
the diminishing public respect for
governmental institutions and traditions
is a clear and growing problem
therefore we must be clear about the
values that we share
House Bill 240 the marital Freedom Act
asserts an important component of our
Collective rights of privacy and I ask
that you support its passage into law
thank you and um I I would like to go on
the record that I would probably support
um representative heinz's
um Constitutional Amendment and um
I'll leave it to you great thank you uh
questions for this Witness
yes representative uh Manos good
afternoon uh Ben I wanted to know
um the um the bill says the actual take
effect 60 days after its passage and I'm
uh wondering whether you would be
willing to amend it so that it takes
effect immediately after its passage I'd
be very open to that thank you other
questions uh yes representative
Alexander thank you Matt um Mr chair not
Madam chair um and thank you for taking
my question
um are there like specific examples of
New Hampshire infringing on the right to
marry for anybody
sent like in recent memory since Supreme
Court of burgerfeld's decision
um so I asked OLS to to dig into
same-sex marriages
um it goes back almost 30 years and
there's a lot of back and forth
um many of those bills did not pass
um the ones that would seek to take away
same-sex marriages
um and as for interracial marriage like
I said before uh I haven't seen anything
so outside of outside of that no
thank you
other questions for this witness so
representative can I just can I just ask
them if
the
as I understand it the uh from the from
the bill as drafted the the language
that this that your bill would add to
existing law
is basically adding the words or race is
that correct that is right all right so
I and I guess my question is if they're
um
why is this bill necessary I guess
really is the question if there I mean
it I
I haven't heard
um in fact even Justice is taught
Justice Thomas's uh uh concurring
opinion in the uh in in the case that oh
what I forgot the name of the case even
now the ones yeah Dobbs it it didn't
suggest that uh loving could be
overruled because that's based on the
14th Amendment that's based on the uh
racial discrimination
um so the fourth you know the core of
the 14th Amendment so where is the
where is the risk of you know somebody
saying there cannot you know interracial
marriage is is in jeopardy
um thank you for the question
um this is definitely more of a planning
type type law there's no there's no
burning fire
um and all due respect to Justice Thomas
not so sure I believe him
other I'm I'm sorry other yes
representative Smith
um
representative Ming I I certainly
sympathize with your last comment
although it's probably not appropriate
to say it publicly but there's a very
real and personal reason why we know
that representative Thomas will not be
involved in any measure to declare
unconstitutional a marriage between two
people of different races
is that not so
I'm not so sure I understand your
question
um
thank you and you have every right to
say that
um the reason I say that is because
um Justice Thomas has been involved in a
long and apparently very close and
successful marriage with a woman of A
different race
and so he would be in a very difficult
position to lead
the fight to eliminate interracial
marriage
do you think that by adding race
and not other
categories
religion for example that you might be
undermining the efforts to make sure
that everyone's right
to marry the person of his or her choice
is guaranteed
um thank you for the question
um
we have protected classes for a reason
those are explicit in my opinion and um
this is one this is one area that I
believe needs to be said
let's ask one other question
representing and that that is this and I
want to say this in the most respectful
way possible but if the
If there really isn't a one one of the
things that concerns me frankly about
this measures this if there really isn't
a realistic problem
that needs to be solved one of the
things that would concern me and I'll
frankly say it's sort of it's sort of a
political thing is if the legislature
were to pass this law
would there then be you know would would
people be saying you see we had to pass
this law because there really was a
threat
um and that's why and you know that sort
of shows that uh you know one political
party or the other was really uh there
you know we really can't trust them that
would be one of the things that would
concern me frankly uh where there really
isn't at least as I sort of see it I
don't see a problem of you know any
Potential Threat uh that that uh
interracial marriage is likely in any
kind of Jeopardy
uh thank you for the question could you
maybe clarify what you mean by threat um
the um
the part where you said we were forced
to pass this bill because
right now in other words what I would be
concerned about if we were to pass this
bill is that
it it could it could generate an
argument or a claim by which I I tend to
think would would not be would not sort
of help
uh bipartisanship by one side against
the other that you see we really needed
to do this
we needed to pass this bill because
there really is a threat
to interracial marriage
when you know it doesn't seem to me that
there really is a threat to interracial
marriage that that would be my part of
my concern I mean being very candid with
you about it thank you um
um
like I said at the top that says
bipartisan sponsorship and
uh from my side of the aisle I don't see
this being a political party
I don't see this being a partisan issue
okay there are like like was mentioned
earlier
there are plenty of people on both sides
of the aisle both locally here and at
the federal government that are in
interracial marriages
and
um
I don't see this as a political thing
but I I do feel it's important
um
in my remarks earlier
that this is a signal to show that New
Hampshire isn't completely backwards
this is important to show people that
are growing up in a more
Blended Blended Society
um
we're diversifying in the United States
and I don't want New Hampshire to fall
back
on that
okay but you know just your answer that
you just gave to you see my concern when
you say that New Hampshire we want to
show that New Hampshire is not a
completely backward
Society
I mean
that sort of makes my point I think the
suggestion was we needed this because
New Hampshire really is a a totally
backward society and this will correct
it and you know for I think for those of
us including myself who don't think New
Hampshire is a particularly backward
Society
um
your answer sort of makes my point
respectfully thank you for the question
and respectfully I we we obviously did
not grow up in similar situations right
we're we're of different races and we
have
um different different backgrounds
um I grew up in the Greater Boston area
so I was very close to New Hampshire and
um
for someone that is not white race is
ever present
other yes representative representative
Perez
thank you
you know there's two ways to look at
this one way to look at it if it's not
broken
don't fix it
the other way to look at it is being
proactive
um I'm very new at this but I have
become very aware of what people think
of what goes on in here outside of here
I'll give you an example A couple of
years ago when the freedom fetal Act was
passed people said why are they wasting
their time with that people people don't
have abortions in New Hampshire over 24
weeks okay
I'm afraid that people if if we
I understand being proactive and I'm
older
but at the same token I don't want and I
think perception is huge
I don't want people to think that
is this what they think is important
there's not a problem here
why are we making this a priority and
it's not to undermine your feelings at
all you know
um
my parents when they came from Italy
were in New York where the signs all
said if Italian do not apply
so I understand that but we don't have
that a problem we don't have a sign that
says if you're you can't have a biracial
marriage
okay does that make sense
that doesn't make sense thank you
yes representative testerman
I sort of take offense at this I have a
wife
who is Japanese
uh
I don't think about it
until I hear something like this law
being proposed
and my wife to my knowledge doesn't
think about it either
I sort of take offense at this kind of a
law that specifies race
other
yes representative Tripp
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question uh
I really don't have much to say about
the the raised part of this bill but uh
uh
there was uh there's some other wording
in the bill that caught my eye
and it said that uh
any person who otherwise meets the
eligibility requirements
of this chapter May marry any other
eligible
person
are you aware of any other eligibility
requirements that uh might we might want
to fix with this bill
um I'm not aware of any and thank you
for your question
um
what this bill does is is add it adds
race to the component of the RSA that
um made legal same-sex marriage and
that that's exactly what I want for
interracial marriage
follow up please yes of course all right
so uh would would you uh would you mind
if we uh do a little research on this
and if there's other issues that uh need
to be fixed we can uh make an amendment
and do that it's happy to Let's thank
you thank you
oh yes representative
foreign
thanks uh for taking the questions
um going to the point of whether or not
this is needed preemptively whether this
is addressed as a current problem or not
are you aware of other states that
include uh the term race in their
um in their marriage statutes or or
Constitution all right thank you thank
you for the question
um I'm not aware of that
um
a lot of what
instigated this bill was
there was the fall of Roe versus Wade
and I I believe that to be its own
separate issue um in terms of Rights of
privacy and
um
but it it did wake wake me up and wake
other people up in terms of
the values that we that we hold and um
um
again it is I I do appreciate this is
not
directly at you
um but I do appreciate that it is
difficult to understand
what it's like to grow up non-white and
the types of protections that we feel
that we need
now just one quick follow-up yes
um I I I totally respect that and I I I
I I can see the value with this but um I
guess what I was just trying to draw out
was whether or not we would be unique in
that regard and I guess also since you
mentioned the the point of privacy uh
the other Provisions that were in the
Dobbs uh
um language from the uh the Justice
um they is it correct that they all did
sort of focus on the right to privacy
provisions and the decisions based on
privacy even though they didn't
explicitly mentioned interracial
marriage but several others that that my
understanding was are based on the right
to privacy is that right
um I I don't recall
um if that if that is the case but it
was things like um Family Planning I
believe
um
and
I'm not sure what what was the what was
the um connection that you were trying
to make
with with your question
just whether any
um marriage provision tied to the right
to privacy is more or less under some
form of threat because of the way that
that was worded
um thank you again for the follow-up um
I believe
um
the implication is there
yeah other questions for this witness
thank you very much representative great
to meet you very nice to meet you
uh representative Hines
or damn Mr hi Jess thank you I think
I'll be quick I was trying to address a
couple questions uh I guess I agree at
the Lee at the moment there's no legal
need for this but I think it is symbolic
um legislature does do symbolic things
um so when we vote to send a message to
the federal government about whether we
disapprove of something or whether we
name a bridge after someone in some
honorific manner um those don't really
have legal consequences but I think
there's a benefit to gain from that I
just don't I guess I don't personally
see the harm in doing this
um and I think we do enact laws that
um might not be needed just to clarify
so while we have a constitutional right
to privacy we often adopt laws that's
incorporate from legislative standpoint
what that means
um so I'm happy to take any questions
I'm just trying to address some
questions for this Witness
yes representative Alexander thank you
Mr chair and thank you representative so
um with following on that um thought
process would you be amenable with
amending to add every single protected
class in here so that next session we
don't have somebody coming in asking to
add ethnicity or religion or something
else for instance
it's not my bill so I want to speak for
the sponsor I think uh classes that this
committee feels are important to protect
to one ad I personally don't have any
problem with adding that
other questions for uh yes uh
representative De Lorenzo
thank you for taking my question
representative Heinz so we're talking
about a cacr you know and we talked
about ceremonial or whatever
this is the bill oh yeah yeah
um
makes sense to just have a house
continue a resolution about
um you know the right to marry and
including all the little you know all
the different categories of people uh I
think in the immediate time frame they
would essentially serve the same purpose
um if we are trying to to I guess
prevent or somehow influence future
conduct and suggest amending the law it
does go further than that but I would
also support what you're suggesting
other questions for this Witness
thank you very much
are there any other people that wish to
testify on hb240
right seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on HP 240 and we've got about
five minutes before we get to
cacr6 and I'm also going to ask my vice
chair uh representative Wallace to take
over the chair since I'm that that's my
bill
we'll reset for about five minutes
foreign
okay good afternoon we'll open up this
hearing on cacr6 and uh representative
Lynn the floor is yours thank you Mr
chair um uh good afternoon my name is uh
Bob Lin I'm a representative from
Windham
um and I'm uh
I've I've like to testify in support of
this bill which proposes a
constitutional amendment
to raise the retirement age for all
judges in the state from 70 to 75.
um the the age 70 limit has been in the
constitution of New Hampshire from the
beginning from 1784 when the
Constitution was first adopted
um at that time the average longevity
was in the early 60s I believe maybe
even a little less than that but the
early but at the early 60s at the latest
so a constitutional provision that says
judges can't serve uh Beyond 70 didn't
have much practical effect but now it it
really does
um
there are a number of states around the
country that do have age limits and 70
is often the age that uh you know that
that uh
uh that applies I mean I know you know I
come from Connecticut originally
Connecticut has a an age 70 uh limit
um
uh I believe Ohio which uh Connecticut
does not elect judges similar to New
Hampshire
um
uh I believe Ohio as another example
which does elect judges they also have
uh an age 70 limit although I as I
understand as an example the way Ohio
law works is if you are you can stand
for election and I think Ohio Judges are
elected for six-year terms I believe if
you can stand for election if you're
under 70 and serve out your term even if
you go over 70 but you can't re you
can't run again if you're if you're over
70. and different states have different
uh different laws uh Rhode Island as an
example does not have any uh age limit
Vermont has an age limit of 90.
and as you probably all know the the uh
the Federal Government Federal Judges
are not subject to any age limit I I
have to say that
um I I think that there should be an age
limit so I'm I wouldn't be one I would
not be here advocating to not have any
age limit at all I think there should be
an age limit
um and I also kind of believe in you
know trying to do what what seems to be
realistic
um it might be I I think I you know if I
had my druthers I I might say that maybe
the age limit should be 80 or as opposed
to 75 but
um you know I'm I I want to try to do
what I what I hope this committee and
the full legislature and the people uh
will think is is a is reasonable and I'm
sort of an incrementalist if it you know
if if we were if we'd were to pass a uh
Constitutional Amendment that raise the
age to 75 and if we had it in effect for
you know 10 or 15 years and it seemed to
be working well then maybe it would be
time to consider raising the age limit
to 80. on the other hand if it turned
out we had a you know a bunch of people
that were uh dribbling on the bench uh
you know at uh at 74.75 uh then we maybe
maybe we want to rethink it and go the
other way I I feel very confident that
that scenario would not happen but
um I do you know I think it it makes
sense to kind of go uh step by step
um yeah I would say we I bear in mind
that
judges are generally
judging is generally something that is
done by
relatively speaking mature mature people
in other words I I would say that the
average age of a job when a judge is
first appointed is probably runs from
the mid 40s to early 50s uh generally
that you know you don't you don't people
don't generally become judges at 25 or
30 years old
um it just it just really doesn't happen
and so
um they often judges want to serve uh
Beyond 70. I know I mean I Frank Frankly
if you know if I if if I didn't have to
retire that's where I'd still be I'd
still be over at the over at the Supreme
Court and I know some you know deer a
very dear colleague of mine judge Convoy
felt this feels the same felt the same
way I mean she she absolutely and there
was absolutely
uh no reason for her to retire she's and
she's as sharp now as she ever was and
she was always very very sharp I hope
that I haven't you know I know I've lost
a step or two physically that that's for
sure I mentioned that my uh I think I do
in our introductory section session I
mentioned that my hobby was target
shooting I used to be really good a
really good Target shooter
um I can still do all right but uh you
know age has definitely uh I can't hold
the ten ring like I used to be able to
hold a 10 Ring that's for sure but but
mentally I think I've still got
um got my faculties and and would still
be able to do a good job
um as a judge
um Beyond you know at beyond the age of
70. I I should know just to so that the
because I know that I've heard some
comments from this committee but just in
common I should note so it's very clear
this proposed Constitutional Amendment
even if it were enacted would have
absolutely no retroactive effect so that
I'm I'm already retired and you know
that would not apply to me judge Conboy
actually I'm I mean it would not apply
to her either in fact she's she turned
75 this summer so it wouldn't apply to
her either but it would apply to judges
that are still on the bench and are
still and are still active and I I have
to say
we have I think an extraordinarily good
Judiciary in the state particularly now
and that includes people that have been
appointed to the bench by both
Republican and Democratic Governors um I
think we really can be very proud of the
judges we have in New Hampshire that are
currently on the bench and you know I I
think it would I think that we the state
would greatly benefit from from
permitting those judges that want to
stay Beyond age 70 for up to another up
to age 75 to do that uh and the last
point I guess I would I would note uh on
this is that you know we don't limit
um the other persons that are limited in
the Constitution by age are sheriffs and
I I think that that you know
that is a more physical law enforcement
kind of job where you can understand uh
that there may be a need for
um an age limit uh but I I would
respectfully submit to you that there is
no more of a need for age limit
of 70 on judges than there is for
legislators or the governor or or
anything and I think we have some pretty
darn good legislators uh who are over
70. and uh do do a very good job so that
that's kind of my pitch I hope you will
agree with me I'm really honored that
Senator Susie is here
um uh to support this this proposed
amendment I think it really is
bipartisan
um and I hope you're I hope you'll
support it and I'm happy to answer any
questions that anyone may have
represent representative Smith
thank you very much
um
thank you for checking my question
um and thank you for permitting me to
serve well past 70 or 75.
um I uh I'm curious as to whether there
is any procedure in place in the
judicial branch where if it came to pass
that a judge or Justice regardless of
age was manifesting
um
signs that they perhaps were losing
their acute mental acuity
is there any provision for addressing
that either formally or informally yeah
that's a no that's a very good question
um and and the answer is formally there
formally there is I mean it's through
the it would be through the code of
judicial conduct
um that you know that the a complaint
could be filed if a judge were you know
were unfit to serve that could that
could happen
um you know can't I mean candidly those
kinds of things I I've I've I
know from experience
um with with federal judges particularly
when I was a law clerk as I say federal
judges are not subject to any age limit
um but there are times
um when federal judges you know are they
really are losing a step and it can and
they can't be forced to retire
um but it and and it can be very
very difficult
um you know that that's a very hard
conversation for one judge or an or a
supervisory judge whatever to have with
a judge it's sort of like you know it's
like uh it's like taking telling your
your uh mother or your grandmother you
can't drive anymore it's really it's
it's really like that only maybe even
out of my I mean the implications are
probably even more because more
important because of the power of a
judge but the short answer to your
question is yes there are provisions and
I think
you know I think internally
um judges
are I think they they do understand the
importance of the positions that they
hold and I think they are
you know they do have their sort of
antenna antennae up so to speak
um is you know if if if another judge is
kind of
doing something that seems to be
untoward or you know whether
intentionally or because of because of
some you know mental acuity problem so I
I it's a hard issue but I think it there
are Provisions that that uh that address
that I think if I could follow-up
I want I want to change the the arena
rather dramatically on this matter and
say
ask you whether you can
conceive of a situation in which either
raising the age to 75 or
eliminating any age limit
could be misused politically
for example if it appears in this state
where we do not elect judges we appoint
them that
um
the uh the incumbent Governor uh might
not be running again and might wonder
and there might be some question as to
the political loyalty of his successor
or her successor could you imagine a
situation in which uh
judges approaching
70 or 75 might be encouraged to resign
so that very young
judges could be named in their place and
therefore serve even if the political
party in control of the governorship and
executive Council were to change sure no
that's a that's a very good question I
you know I think candidly that I think
that could happen I haven't seen any
evidence in the time that I you know the
27 year almost 27 years that I was a
judge I haven't seen any evidence of
that kind of thing happening but it
could but I guess I would say to the
extent that you know the scenario you're
talking about could happen I I think
that what the age limit is wouldn't
really make that much difference I mean
that could happen now it could happen
that you know a governor could say you
know to somebody who's coming up on
retire you know trying to exercise some
pressure so that that Governor could
appoint a younger person to replace him
so I I think I haven't as I say I
haven't seen any evidence in the time
I've been a judge of that kind of thing
happening
but I suppose it could and I I do think
that on that issue what the age limit is
doesn't really make all that much
difference
thank you very much
representative Alexander thank you Mr
chair and thank you representative Lynn
for taking my questions I have two if
that's okay my first one is
um kind of like a passing the torch
question because as a young person I'm
28 years old
um is there a shortage of good potential
judges or a a very small back bench of
Judges that could replace I'm just
worried about you know keeping keep
keeping judges on five extra years would
hold back once that would be great
judges
right moving forward so do you have any
kind of evidence to show it no I mean I
think I
getting a Judicial appointment is a very
you know very highly sought after
position if you're a lawyer I think a
lot there's a lot of lawyers there's a
lot more lawyers that want to be judges
and there are Judges available so
candidly I think you know I I don't
think we have we that that I could
honestly sit here and say to you let's
extend the age to 75 because otherwise
we're gonna we're gonna have a shortage
of Judges that I think that would that's
not the case
um but I do think
um that um we lose some very good people
um as as you know as judges and and I
that because I have to leave early and I
guess the other thing I would say is
that
to some extent
um you lose the opportunity of having
people appointed to the bench that are
you know are really sort of at the prime
of their career but are a little bit
older in other words for example if if
someone under the way the way the
retirement system works for judges and
and it's a I want to be honest it's a
very good retirement system I don't have
any complaints about that at all but the
way it works is if you are if you are
appointed at let's say 62 if you're
appointed at 63 and that still can be a
very you know people can be very very
much sort of uh mid-career or or maybe
maybe sort of towards the end of their
career but still a very good career to
go you get if you were appointed at 63
you can only you can serve seven years
and you get no if it's if
it's exactly seven years you do get a 50
retirement but if it's any if it's one
year less than than
um then seven years you get no
retirement so I'll give you an example
Judge David Garfunkel served on the
Superior Court wonderful judge he'd been
uh uh director of the public defenders
program for many years then was in
private practice just a wonderful trial
court judge he was on he only he got
appointed at 63 and a half let's say
something like that he got no retirement
uh he served for you know six and a half
years I did a wonderful job got no
retirement
um so I that you know that by by
extending the age limit you would you
would reduce the chances of things like
that happen
thank you and one other question if I
could
um I'm glad that there's a state senator
in this room because maybe we can work
together because I'm not allowed to run
for Senate yet because I'm under the age
of 30. so my question to you is maybe we
can work together on this would you be
amendable if we change the age to run
for Senate it also would not apply for
me because I'd be able to run for Senate
next time or something but we can change
this all together would you be okay with
that are you asking the question today
oh I don't have any I don't have any
problem with that awesome thank you no
problem
representative Terror
yeah thanks and and and I'll say um I
and hopefully everyone in the committee
will set aside the fact that if this
were in place we would be deprived of
your leadership in this committee
um no you wouldn't I'm not going based
on not going anywhere based on based on
that you would still be on the bench um
my question symbol I think the first
half of it already got answered which is
I got the sense there's not a Workforce
or or shortage uh driven uh purpose
behind behind this as there are for so
many sort of other positions these days
no I candidly no they're they're really
aren't there's there's it's a very
sought after position and then sort of
the related question are you do you know
how many people have have been uh um hit
this limit in in a year and past X
number of years boy well
um
Justice sure
judge uh Duggan who's now passed I mean
but he he he hit this you know he
retired just before he turned 70. I
think he was a wonderful judge I think
he probably would not have retired if
the if the you know 70 age limit uh
justice Convoy as I mentioned uh myself
um I know uh justice Hicks
um who's on the bench now he will turn
70. I believe next October and you know
I'm uh I mean obviously he's going to go
but still on under the under on the
existing law but I think he would be
would be very likely to want to stay
um if the uh if if the age limit wasn't
70 and there's a number of superior I
mean
Kenny I don't know if some of you know
Ken McHugh was a long long time Superior
Court judge just a wonderful judge
um he you know he he's like 78 now or 79
he'd still be there if he could and he's
still going strong I see him every you
know occasionally uh so I think there's
a number of a number of Judges judge
smuckler another example
um I think there's a number of Judges
who would stay who would have stayed if
they could have
foreign
representative Tripp
thank you Mr
chair
representative Lynn
the uh I guess I'm going to show my
ignorance here but uh
the constitutional
[Music]
retirement age does that apply only to
Supreme Court Justices or is it all
Justice all judges all judges in the
state no all right so this will be uh
you'll be backing up the uh the young
people even more
if I uh passed in this uh Constitutional
Amendment well you know there I mean you
shouldn't I don't think you should
assume that all judges will stay till
70. I mean there are a number of Judges
who who uh who you know who were good
judges but but you know once they got
eligible once they became eligible for
retirement which um depending on how
many years of service you have can be as
young as 60 under the current retirement
system some judges you know were very
very good judges leave uh judge Abramson
a good friend of mine you know she was
she was a long time Superior Court Judge
excellent judge she left at age 60. she
she sits in Us in senior status from
time to time but she's she left
um at age 60 there's others that have
done that
um you know so I think it depends on who
the judge
this isn't a question that is a comment
that I saw a uh in the newspaper a
couple days ago there was a there's a
quote by somebody saying that uh in New
Hampshire when you retire you either go
to uh Florida or the uh House of
Representatives
would you believe
would you believe thank you
representative Delorenzo
I was doing research on this bill I came
across some states that would allow
judges to retire
um no to continue working after you know
whatever the age limit is but they had
to Forfeit getting paid had you heard
about that or do you have any feelings
or thoughts on that I I wasn't aware of
that or to be honest with you I thought
I know that some states have
a system where you know even if you're
even if you're over the age limit you
can serve in some and I should say that
that you know in in New Hampshire a a
judge who is over 70 can
serve as sort of a uh what's what are
the what's the term they use uh mediator
yeah a Judicial referee in other words
can't can't
there any or anything that they do it's
limited to what they can do and their
orders have to be countersigned by an
active judge I think I misspoke for a
second there
what they
I thought that's really strange oh I'm
I'm not aware every time okay I'm not
aware of I'm not aware of that I'm uh
thank you
yes
representative go right ahead
thank you for the question I
did I know that Smith said if in regards
to if you had a judge that um reached
the age of 70 or if we put it up to 60
um what would happen if they were
failing in their mental capacity but
then refused
refuse to leave what would be done at
that point I think the judicial thank
you that's a very good question I think
the judicial conduct committee would
have the authority
to recommend I mean the Supreme Court
the Supreme Court would have to make
the ultimate to say the other the other
if it was a Supreme Court Judge the
other members of the Supreme Court but
they would have the authority to say
that the judge they can't
they can't you know they can't impeach a
judge but what they could say is the
judge no longer has the authority to to
exercise judicial power
thank you
any other questions for representative
Lynn
saying none great thank you thank you
very much and we now call Senator Susie
thank you very much Mr chairman members
of the committee for the record I'm
Donna soucy I represent Senate District
18 which is comprised of the town of
Litchfield and Wards five through nine
in the city of Manchester and I am a
proud co-sponsor of this legislation and
I I truly appreciate having the
opportunity to sit through and hear some
of the questions that the committee
members ask because I really think they
are quite Salient something that we
should all consider before moving
forward but it you know just to bring us
back I think it needs to be made clear
70 is the youngest age
through all all of the states in the
union
um that judges are forced to retire so
making this this incremental change to
age 75 would still have us on the
younger
um the younger end of required
retirement
uh this was age 70 was placed in the
Constitution
um in 1971 the Constitutional Convention
voted on it and then seven excuse me in
1791 and then 1792 was enacted some of
the studies I've looked at put life
expectancy at that time about 35 years
of age
um so uh 70 was
I think what we would consider a hundred
at this point
um it was uh a very very Advanced age
it's what the founders of our our state
and what the the Constitutional drafters
uh thought was important that it'd be
someone of an advanced age that could
sit on the bench
I think what's really important is to
consider also um the medical advances
that have occurred since then since the
late 1700s uh we are all living longer
we live in a state that's one of the
oldest states in the country and one of
the things although I certainly have
never sat on the bench I'm I'm a lawyer
I have been in court in practice before
judges but one of the things that I
think makes a good judge or Justice
is their ability to to reason uh to work
through the arguments to be open to
hearing all of the different arguments
but a lot of the best judges I think are
more experienced judges and the more
time spent hearing cases and varieties
of cases
um I think makes you know someone uh a
very very good judge I mean
representative Lynn mentioned a number
of Judges who really I think were at the
prime of their careers but were forced
to retire I think of Justice Convoy
Justice delanis people that uh were
certainly capable able able
um very very good practicing judges who
were forced to end their careers but I
also think we have to remember on the
other side there's nothing precluding
someone from retiring early should
someone choose to retire at age 60 or 62
and they're sitting on the bed that will
always be up to the individual to decide
as long as you know they're acting
within the confines of the law
but
I do think that we're doing a disservice
to ourselves forcing some of the people
that currently
um sit on the bench and have in recent
years past forcing them out at age 70 in
this day and age in 2023
um there are very very capable able
people that are age 70 and Beyond doing
great work uh either practicing as
lawyers practicing any number of
professions and I think this is a simple
change that I would hope this committee
would look favorably upon and I remind
you that really ultimately the question
is one for the voters so this would be a
question placed on the 2024 ballot and
you know it would be up to the voters to
vote it up or down as you know the other
thing that's kind of unique about New
Hampshire we have a very high threshold
in which to amend our constitution so it
you know it's more than a simple
majority it would take a number of
Voters viewing this in a positive light
but I think it's it's a good change it's
an incremental change and I think it
would benefit the state of New Hampshire
with that I'd conclude my testimony and
happy to answer any questions
any questions from Senator Susie
they were all covered by oh
representative Lorenzo yeah
um life expectancy has um
change
um quite a bit and I was thinking not
only do we have a greater life expense
expectancy but we also have
um digital
um
in electronic processes that make the
workload easier for folks do you think
that would have any has any effect on
retirement age for judges
I think it's
um certainly uh the workload
um certainly representative Lynn could
speak to more directly but yeah I I
agree unlike sheriffs which are also
Limited in the age in which they can
serve
the work is not as physical and it can
be assisted by electronic devices and
the fact that you know many people live
longer healthier lives than when this
age was originally established I think
are all important factors that I hope
this committee will consider the house
and then hopefully when we get to the
Senate we can consider that as well so I
thank you for that question thank you
any other questions for Senator Susie
seeing none thank you for your time
thank you
the committee now calls representative
Heinz
once again
thank you chairman Wallace Dan Hines
Town of Bedford representing
Hillsborough too I'll be brief um
because pretty much a lot of what people
have said has been covered but uh I'll
just point out this is essentially age
of scrub emanation in employment
um New Hampshire does not like that we
have an anti-discrimination statute
specifically prohibiting it
um if there weren't this constitutional
amendment I would suggest this would not
be allowed to be
um and I think there is a lot of overlap
between a legislator and a judge um so
one thinks about a law and potential
consequences on how it might be applied
at the end of the day a judge applies
facts to the law and interprets that law
both require logical thinking critical
thinking and a lot of analysis and I
think if there are a proposed cacr to
set the legislature age of 70. it would
not go over a very favorable poll in
front of the legislature so I'd ask that
the same type of accommodation be given
I personally don't think there should be
any limit but I do agree Justice land
that 75 is certainly better than 70 and
light of the times changing essentially
and if the constitutional
um as it as it is if there's a problem
with bad judges we already have remedies
and I think the solution is to address
that specific Judge and not ban all
judges because I think at the end of the
day what this does is eliminates and
forces into retirement a lot of good
judges and since we're over time I won't
be taking any questions thank you
thank you representative Heinz
and with that we'll adjourn the hearing
on cacr6
thank you uh so now we will turn to the
hearing on the last bill of the day
that's uh HB
um 63.
and
oh okay great
um
sorry
okay
uh all right
so
um
HB
uh oh Ray I yeah I should fill out a
pink card
um oh right representative um did you do
you have the code yeah yeah
um do you want me to do that now or
afterwards okay oh you're gonna fill one
out is that it yeah I'll fill it out
yeah all right sure go ahead
so uh hi I'm
Eric Gallagher I represent Merrimack
County District 20 which is
Concord Ward 6 and I'm here to introduce
House Bill 63 relative to religious use
of land and structures
um
so
um so I'm just going to start with a
little
legislative history here
um
this is actually kind of the result of
two separate uh bills from last term
um
so I had my
own bill
um
House Bill one
uh
one two one nine
um
last term which
was intended to make it easier for
religious organizations such as churches
who turn their parking lots into housing
if they're safe facing declining
declining membership and want to do
something with that space so
uh house bill
um
came before
my own committee Municipal and County
Government
um
and at the hearing for it one of the
points that was brought up was that
um
it conflicted with House Bill 1021
uh from that year
uh
which
also
um which was a more
General Bill about religious land use
um
so um
I reached out to the sponsors of that
bill
um
to try to
figure out if the house bill 1021 would
in fact cover the case that I was
thinking about of uh churches building
housing and the answer seemed
inconclusive
um
so
um yeah I've
I decided to file this year's bill
um House Bill 63 to
uh
provide some clarity that yes the
language
from last year's
House Bill 1021 can in fact be used to
make it easier refrigerator just to
build housing
um so and then
um
in the process
of studying the bill
um
I also learned about
some concerns that the uh Municipal
Association had
with
the existing language that was added
previously in House Bill 1021 uh so
I uh
I Incorporated their concerns into this
bill as well so it
it's basically just doing a little bit
of
reward rewording of
the statute to make it a bit clearer of
um
what exactly
towns can and can't do with
religious land use
um
so uh
yeah nature Grays from the municipal
Association
uh should be
here to testify to that part of it um
so
I've also heard that um
so one of my co-sponsors uh
representative Mooney will be
introducing
an amendment
um
to bring it back a little bit closer to
the original language of last year's
House Bill 1021 and
I'm okay with that I'm okay with with
the bill either with or without the
amendment the main thing I want to see
added is just the clarification about
housing being covered under it
um
so
uh and with that I'll take any questions
from members of committee representative
testerman
have you do you know of any specific
case
where your
Amendment to the bill or your amendment
to this legislation
will will make it better I mean is there
a problem there or some problem that has
been created with the existing
legislation
I don't mean that the the original
writing that done with the final one
you've got here is there any problem
we've got
well mostly just the uncertainty of it
um
like
just from talking with town and
Municipal officials they are confused by
it and need some clarity
um and in terms of specific
uh developments um
well
so for example
um
well I'll give some examples of some
places that did some Churches or
religious organizations that did
successfully
do housing related stuff so
um
they're
um if we were on the other side of the
building I could point it out the St
John's Church was conf um
on
uh I think it's pla or I think it's
Pleasant Street
um across from the federal courthouse
building has been converted into housing
and they were able to do that because
the church was closed down
completely and just rezoned but for
other churches where it's like okay we
want to keep using this as a church but
we also want to provide housing here
there's a little bit more ambiguity in
that case uh like for example my church
uh
runs this program called Family Promise
of our church which is
provides temporary housing for the
homeless but
um
yeah it has to be temporary and uh we
can't really make it anything more
permanent for them
um
so yeah I think
just having some more clarity in this
area about what is and what isn't
allowed would be helpful for both
municipalities and religious
organizations
foreign
other questions
this Witness
seeing none thank you very much sir all
right thank you
um representative Mooney
thank you Mr chairman
good afternoon members of the committee
once again
by means of introduction I'm
representative Maureen Mooney from the
town of Merrimack Hillsborough County
District number 12.
my name is on the bill as a co-sponsor
and I support it with the amendment that
I've given to the chairman uh copies of
which can be distributed it's amendment
number
2023 hyphen double zero 46 h
now House Bill 63 aims to allow the
building of housing for the unhoused by
a religious organization
I think we're all in agreement that that
last sentence of House Bill 63 that
begins on line 9 is important and an
exercise of religious freedom the line
reads as follows
the building of housing to house the
unhoused by our religious organization
shall qualify as religious exercise
under this section
however
there is a dispute about the language
preceding that last sentence about
housing
my Amendment again that's 2023 hyphen
double zero 46 H distributed to the
chair for distribution
preserves the carefully crafted existing
language currently in the statute
that came from House Bill 1021 that was
signed into law just last year July of
2022.
my Amendment not only preserves that
language that was adopted last year but
it then adds that last sentence from
House Bill 63 about housing
at the end
so on my amendment that last sentence
appears on line 11. again after the
existing language that was adopted last
year
I encourage you to adopt my Amendment
therefore adopting the bill with that I
will conclude my testimony thank you Mr
chairman
questions for representative mooing
uh yes uh representative mount
good afternoon representative Mooney I
wanted to ask I wanted to ask about
um your Amendment and you see you have
listed very specific
um
uh requirements that a municipality or a
town or a city could enforce and I'm
wondering whether you would be open to
um
making it broader by stating that
building codes are applicable municipal
or town building codes are applicable
rather than having this specific list of
um requirements
thank you for the question
representative
I would be okay with that however
we have somebody testifying probably
immediately after me who is very
instrumental in the original language of
House Bill 1021 adopted last year
and my guess is that that is
specifically in there for a reason
considering that that language just
recently went through the process of the
house and the Senate and the governor's
signature and the like so
that's my preliminary answer but I would
ask for the full answer to come from him
thank you
other questions
or representative Mooney so
representative Mooney can I um
can I make sure that I'm
under
either the original version of the bill
or your proposed amendment
am I understanding and maybe this is the
way
the law is now under the bill that was
passed last year but is it my
understanding that
a
a church or a really a church synagogue
whatever
um
is not
in other words if for for example
suppose that a um
in
a particular area of of some of City X
um uh it's it's zoned residential and
only uh either single-family houses or
maybe single-family houses and multi
multi-family houses are allowed but
nothing beyond that is allowed that
um no other
entity that isn't a house or either a
single-family house or a multi-family
house would be allowed but a church
would be allowed is that is that correct
I'm going to defer that also to the
gentleman testifying after me
because I believe that the whole impetus
for this last year was the differences
in various communities so this attempts
to make it more uniform
so I think that the answer to your
question might be varied Community to
community
all right other other questions
thank you very much representative
Mooney thank you
um
Michael uh Tierney
afternoon
[Laughter]
we love you we love your Edge microphone
yes please
my apologies good afternoon my name is
Michael Tierney I am a practicing
attorney I've represented a couple dozen
religious organizations in their land
use approvals but I'm testifying here on
my own behalf and not on behalf of any
particular client I work very hard with
representative wolper last year in order
to get HB 1021 past that is the existing
language of RSA 670 476 and that takes
care of what was a problem in many towns
ran the state of having discretionary
and arbitrary ordinances okay that would
require religious organizations because
they are religious to obtain additional
greater approval based on such criteria
such as fits within the character of the
neighbor neighborhood okay criteria such
as fits within the character of the
neighborhood is a recipe for a
subjective determination
let me give you an example of one
particular ordinance which I found very
troubling in the HB 1021 last year took
care of and that's at the town of
Bedford has a parking ordinance that
says that you need a certain number of
parking spaces per square foot if you're
a movie theater if you're gathering for
some sort of commercial purpose
but if you're gathering for a Christian
purpose you're a church then you need
more parking spaces in a movie theater
but if God forbid you're gathering in a
mosque the town of Bedford had an
ordinance that you need even more
parking Okay so
all three of those ordinances are bad
when you look at the fact that the
religious nature is determining the
parking requirement that shouldn't be
happening in HB 1021 which was passed
last year adopted at 674.76 took care of
that problem and got rid of arbitrary
discretionary ordinances okay
it wasn't in a vacuum
670 476 is based on the Massachusetts
Dover Amendment which for 50 years
has said that you can't have local
zoning regulation of churches based on
discretionary criteria but you can have
objective and narrow criteria that are
applied to all uses whether it be a
church or a school or a house you know
if you have a setback ordinance that
says you cannot have a building within
50 feet of a wetland okay it doesn't
matter whether it's a school or it's a
church or it's a house if you have to be
50 feet back from Wetland you have to be
50 feet back from wetland
what this statute that was adopted last
year got rid of was saying that if
you're a movie theater you have to be 50
feet back from a uh Wetland if you're a
church you need to be 100 feet back from
Wetland and if you're a musk you need to
be 150 feet back from Wetland okay
that's what 674 76 does
hb63 which is before you is a bad bill
um I oppose it I oppose it because all
of the problems
um that the current statute was intended
to get rid of could happen
if you look at the language of hb63 okay
you need to show that the soul the sole
reason why the municipality is
regulating something is because of its
religious nature so a town
could say we're regulating the parking
the purpose isn't solely religious
nature therefore we can have as part of
the basis that a church has to have this
parking ordinance Hamas needs to have
that parking ordinance a movie theater
has to have whatever other parking
ordinance
the current law which has only been in
place for a matter of months is a good
law it should stay that language should
not be repealed as is proposed by hb63
as introduced
um
the second section of hb63 has what's
called substantial burden language
substantial burden language has been
adopted in States all across the country
maybe in 30 different states
and it requires a religious organization
to show that it has exhausted all
alternatives
prior to being able to use its own
property for religious purposes such as
housing and housed having religious
worship services having a religious
school okay so that language is not very
helpful to making sure that we have a
protection of religious liberty here in
New Hampshire it is also an invitation
to litigation
I can cite thousands literally thousands
of cases where towns and religious
organizations have litigated what it
means to be a substantial burden the U.S
Supreme Court hasn't decided that
um 10 different circuits around the
country have come up with different
definitions and tests and how to
determine a substantial burden and it is
just an invitation for Unnecessary
costly and time-consuming litigation
over whether this particular proposal is
a substantial burden
the existing language is clear it's easy
to apply
um and it could be improved by adding
um representative Mooney's Amendment
which makes clear that housing the
unhoused is religious exercise I heard
that uh representative Gallagher is also
in support of that Amendment taking the
existing language and just adding as a
final sentence a clarification okay that
religious exercise also includes housing
the unhoused
um if there are any questions I'd be
happy to answer any questions
um about hb63 or about current law and
how it all works
questions for uh Mr Tierney
yes representative Tripp thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question
so uh essentially what uh
what what this bill is doing is uh uh
stripping out anyhow Sony regulations in
the town right
if you're talking about hb63
um hb63 is repealing 674.76
thank you okay um other questions
so I I have a couple of questions uh uh
Mr Jimmy if I could so am I
understanding correctly then that
are you okay with representative
Mooney's proposed amendment yes yes the
way it's rewarded yes all right so my
question is this
um let's put aside any version of the of
63 whether it's the original or the
amendment under the existing law as it
was changed last year
if
zoning in a particular area says
single family houses
or mult or let's say you know duplexes
or single-family houses or duplexes or
triplexes okay that's it nothing else
can a church be located there under
existing law as it is today okay if the
exclusion of churches is because it is a
church and not a house that is not
permissible under existing law if the
exclusion is because the zoning
ordinance does not allow structures over
five thousand square feet
um then that exclusion would be
permissible but an exclusion based on
religious purpose is not permissible it
needs to be on objective criteria such
as size but for example for I guess what
I would be asking I mean for example
suppose that the that the
The Zone the purpose of the zoning
ordinance is in other words
single-family houses or or let's say a a
Triplex is you're gonna there's a
certain limitation on the number of
people
that are that are you know I mean in a
single family house you generally it
would be quite unusual to have 25 people
living in a single family house and so I
guess I mean if the
a church is I I guess what I'm saying is
a church is not a house and so it you
seem to be saying that that doesn't
matter so that doesn't matter let me
give you an example okay an example in
the town of Hanover right now there's
litigation that's pending okay regarding
a church that is trying to obtain
permission to build okay in what is
deemed a residential area because
they're not able to or allowed to build
anywhere else okay and one of the things
that the zoning board has restricted and
regulated is whether you can have a
Bible study for six to ten people now
whether a Bible study for six to ten
people happens in my living room or
happens in a church basement it's the
same six to ten people
okay and the town should not be given
the power to regulate the time the hours
or the day based on the religious nature
now if a town has an ordinance based on
number of people size of structure
setbacks all those objective criteria
they're all permissible under existing
law
but it's not permissible to exclude
something based on its religious purpose
right okay okay so let me just ask what
follow does this
I'm I'm wondering if the language the
language in representative Mooney's
proposed amendment the the language that
starts provided
I'm wondering if the
if the
language there that says these kind of
regulations are okay and can be applied
to a religious Institution
are they
more limited than what exists under
current law no that is exactly identical
to current law okay current law lists
the um height of structures yard sizes
lot area setbacks open space building
coverage requirements okay that is
existing law and as long as those
objective criteria are applied to uh
movie theaters or churches or synagogues
or Moss those objective criteria can
continue to be applied you just can't
have criteria especially for religious
purposes
I want to just ask one one other
question to make sure I'm gonna so
suppose that we're talking suppose that
uh a zoning area is single family houses
only okay right
and a a religious organization wants to
build on its property Apartments
uh with a greater density can they do
that
so under the Mooney Amendment my
understanding is that religious exercise
includes providing services to the
homeless it doesn't include providing
Apartments
um you know at two thousand dollars a
month that is not included under the
Mooney amendment in my understanding oh
well okay so let me change my question a
little bit so if the if a really in a
single family zoning area if a religious
institution wanted to provide Apartments
to house the homeless in that zoning
area would that be allowed
it would not be able to be excluded
because of the religious purpose if
there was a density or a height or a
setback or if there was some other
reason to forbid it that could be
forbidden by some other reason but not
the religious purpose
thank you other questions for this
Witness
oh I'm sorry yes the representative
Perez
thank you for taking my question
the building of housing to house the
unhoused by allergist organization shall
qualify as religious exercise under this
section
who determines that who determined that
housing the unhouses
housed and pardon my ignorance is a
religious exercise that would be this
body
this body is writing into law a
clarification that the housing of the
unhoused is religious exercise do we
already may I do we already have
something that states that so I don't
believe there's anything in existing law
that states that I know there are
existing cases around the country that
are about 90 percent that the services
to the homeless can qualify as religious
exercise but there are some outliers
that say that services to the homeless
unchurched properties cannot qualify as
a realtor exercise AI yes so
this is not only changing things about
the structures I understand that that's
pretty clear but it is also
adding the fact that
housing the unhoused is a religious
exercise that is the purpose of the
money amendment is my understanding yes
okay thank you representative page thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question
um this is on that last sentence with us
determining what's a religious exercise
do you find that problematic at all from
a constitutional perspective
that's a very good question
um I don't think that the state can
determine what is and is not religious
exercise I think that is a huge
constitutional problem but the state can
determine what is and is not really
sexualized for the purpose of
restricting the powers of attack
so if this was saying that this is
religious exercise in church you must do
this
that would be a big problem but this is
a restriction on the town's restriction
on churches which
I I don't know if I'm making this health
clear but because it's a restriction on
Municipal Power it's not a restriction
on a a religious organization's
determination of religious exercise
okay representative Horgan
yes but we would agree
that the current law and I guess this
bill too you would you would provide
different
um protections to
organizations that hold say they're
religious as opposed to organizations
that are explicitly non-religious or sex
or or a secular
like say you know like you're maybe
you're talking about like you know
having six to ten people and doing their
Bible study in the church basement but
you wouldn't apply say to six to ten
people like playing Dungeons and Dragons
in their Dungeons and dragon Club
basement if they had one
so I'm not aware of a single town in the
state of New Hampshire that regulates
the playing of dungeons of dragons or
regulates
um activities based on the secular
nature I am unfortunately aware of
dozens of towns that regulate based on
the religious nature and make a
determination that the government is
going to impose greater restrictions
even based on the form of religious
worship
other questions yes representative
yeah um I you may have tried to touch on
this but I'm looking at the difference
between the uh House Bill 63 versus the
existing language and and provision
Roman numeral one online four four and
five says what I think you've been
saying or I'm interpreting it that way
it says uh no ordinances Etc
um shall restrict the use of Land
restructures Based solely the word
solely on the religious nature of the
use and it sounded like that's what
you've been supporting is that it
shouldn't be based solely on the
religious nature of the use
um
the existing language actually talks
more about the use of the structure
and it says basically restrict the use
of land or structures primarily used for
religious purposes so it seems like
there's a fairly big difference between
what the existing language says versus
the new language and it sounds like the
new language at least that first
provision is closer to what it sounds
like you're supporting is that accurate
that isn't accurate the the newly
proposed language that has the phrase
solely okay is
um
problematic because of the potential in
the everyday experience that you have
activities happening at religious
properties okay that an outside Observer
could say well that isn't solely for
this purpose we have this other area
um um where we intended as well so let
me go back to my Bedford parking example
when they have an ordinance that is
restricting parking at mosques more than
it's restricting parking at churches
okay that wouldn't be prohibited because
it's not based solely on the religious
nature it's based primarily on the
religious nature but it's also based on
the town's interest in making sure
there's sufficient parking and the town
does have an interest in making sure
there's sufficient parking but they
can't be doing it based primarily
on distinctions between religious groups
so that's why primarily is more
protective than solely
just one quick follow-up so in the
example that you had given before is it
the case that if you could show that
the interest is not parking because
you've got one group that's allowed six
bases and one group that's allowed more
but the only difference is
the religious component isn't that Soul
isn't that the word where the word
solely does come in
so the word solely comes in from and I'm
going to pronounce it wrong but a U.S
Supreme Court case of the Church of
lukumi babalai okay and in the Church of
lakumi babalai the church needed to
prove okay that the real basis for the
town's ordinance was anti-santiary
animus that discrimination okay the
church needed to prove that needed to
prove that in a lawsuit that went up all
the way the U.S Supreme Court took a
number of years cost hundreds of
thousands of dollars both for the city
and for the for the church okay
um
if you have language such as current
existing law primarily okay then there's
no need to show that the one and only
purpose of the town is its religious
discrimination that they don't have any
other no if it's primarily for a
religious purpose
um then that takes that confusion
um and that litigation out of the
um out of the mix
um solely is enshrining
um First Amendment jurisprudence
um and so the statute does nothing more
than the Constitution under the first
member already does
all right representative Tripp I think
you had a question
uh thank you Mr chair uh thank you for
taking my question
uh you said that uh this language is uh
language it was used last year in uh
house bill 1024 10 21 10 21. oh that's
my poor handwriting uh
so uh so that uh
they're they're can I assume that
there's a church that has built housing
on its property
no
um the addition of the housing language
um is not part of HB 1021
um that is what was being proposed by
representative Gallagher and
representative Mooney here today
okay the clarification that housing on
Church properties is what is new
1021 is everything before that final
sentence in representative Moody's
um
uh proposed amendment all right well
thank you very much I understand now
another question yes uh representative
Mass
thank you thank you for taking my
question
um I asked a representative Mooney about
her view on broadening
her amendment to include building codes
municipal or city building codes and I'm
wondering what your view on that is so
my view is number one the state building
code is not impacted by existing law the
state building code is already
able to be applied to churches just like
it's be able to be applied to movie
theaters or houses or what have you okay
now when a municipality comes up with
their own additions to the building code
um it would be my view that if those
additions to the building code are
objective and definite that that
wouldn't be a problem it would only be a
problem
um if they were subjective and
discretionary okay so a building
provision that said that you need to
have
excise trusses for why size you know
weight great you know those are going to
be applicable regardless of building
code that says that appropriate
provision or adequate ventilation or
those sorts of discretionary terms are
exactly why HB 1021 was adopted last
year so you don't have discretionary
enforcement against religious
organizations so if it said objective
and definite
uh
municipal or or city building codes you
would
be okay with that
I I personally would be okay with that
okay the other thing I wanted to ask if
I make yes
um
the amendment says do not does not
substantially burden religious exercise
who would it be the town or the
municipality or the city that is in the
positioning in the position of
determining whether or not it
substantially burdens religious exercise
great question there is a lot of
litigation on exactly whose burden it is
um and the cases are split
um the relupa federal law okay places
the burden in the first instance on the
church and then places the burden under
strict scrutiny on the tap okay and that
conflicting burden is applied
differently in the first circuit that is
in the 10th circuit that ends in the
sixth circuit
would you be willing to specify who has
the burden that the religious
organization has the burden I would be
concerned about putting a municipality
or a city in the position of making a
judgment or evaluating whether there's a
substantial burden on religious exercise
so I would not be opposed to clarifying
that the church needs to make proof of
its substantial burden in the first
instance
um but it is the typical practice that
the church makes a representation that
is a substantial burden and the city
says no it's not a substantial burden
because you could do it this other way
and whether they could or could not do
it this other way is sort of where a lot
of the fights get into
which is why having objective indefinite
setbacks Heights those sorts of things
um
avoids all that unnecessary litigation
thank you other questions for this
Witness
thank you very much sir thank you oh I'm
sorry yes representative I'm sorry I'm
sorry I I really like the intent of that
last sentence and and I just wanted to
Circle back one more time and try one
more question again around what I what I
asked a moment ago
um
if that first line of the new bill
said no zoning ordinance local land use
regulation shall prohibit regulate
restrict
use of Lander structures based primarily
on the use on the religious nature of
the use would that solve the problem
because I I think what I'm struggling
with here is that the new rule talks
about the nature of the use being why
the restrictions happening the other one
talks about the fact that that's the
purpose of the structure it says
restrict the use of land or structures
primarily used for religious purposes
and so it seems like that opens a much
broader door to anything happening at a
land on land that's used primarily for
religious purposes where the new
language seems like it's
more concretely focused on whether the
Restriction is either primarily or or uh
I'm sorry I'm losing my language here
um uh predominantly or whatever the word
was so I'm wondering whether or not it's
possible to if you think that that would
be an acceptable change that would sort
of keep the focus on that the
Restriction is based either solely or
primarily on the religious nature of the
use so primarily would solve the problem
my view in section Roman one yes but
there would still be a problem in
section Roman two okay that an arbitrary
and discretionary ordinance could be
applied okay and it would be incumbent
to show that that arbitrary
discretionary ordinance results in a
substantial burden okay the existing
language okay says that you can't apply
arbitrary
um discretionary language such as fits
within the character of the neighborhood
because showing whether a requirement of
fits within the character of the
neighborhood results in a substantial
burden becomes such a difficulty of
proof that we're talking about years of
litigation and and personal opinions
instead of objective facts if you have
however an ordinance that says that you
have a height limitation of 35 feet okay
you have a height limitation of 35 feet
it's 35 feet whether you're a house a
church a movie theater what have you
so so start final follow-up if I might
yep
would it be would it create an
inconsistency to have section one
reference primarily and keep the
language the way it's in in uh hb63 and
and then switch over to the language
that the existing law has for the rest
of it
sorry if that's a lot to just sort of
throw out there so I think what you're
saying is could one add the section
Roman one with the word primarily two
existing law
um or to the or to the to the proposed
in an amended version I guess
and I wouldn't see a particular problem
with that as long as the prohibition on
any regulations that are not listed in
statute is still there
other questions for this Witness
thank you very much sir thank you
representative McGuire
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee for the record my name is Dan
McGuire and I represent the town of
Epsom I apologize for not being better
prepared to speak to you on this issue
but I I was unaware of this bill until I
walked in the door a couple of minutes
ago to talk on a subsequent hearing and
but I am a member of the Epsom planning
board and so I'm very familiar with uh
whatever it is RSA
674 colon 76 which is the topic of this
bill and so
um our our planning board is planning to
and maybe what I'm about to say you've
heard from others but my our planning
board is planning to uh ask our town to
change our zoning regulations in direct
consequence of that new RSA to to uh
remove
um location stuff related to churches
right to change our zoning so it
complies with this with this particular
section and but but we do think on our
planning board that this section needs
to be fixed a bit because mainly because
it includes this list of things that we
can regulate and that list is is
inadequate right it's a list it says so
such Heights such setbacks such yard
size and so on but it doesn't include
drainage it doesn't include signage it
doesn't include parking it doesn't
include driveways you know all the
things that we would normally
regulate so we don't care the fact that
it you know it's fine uh that churches
can be anywhere I think that's the main
point of this but I we just don't think
you really want a list of of this is
what you can regulate I mean that should
be somewhere else dealing with planning
boards can regulate these things kind of
thing and and in here it should be just
don't just don't give special treatment
to churches because they're churches and
and uh different than you would do other
things either in that area or in town or
however you want to ride it but but the
fact that you put a list of of things
that planning boards can regulate in
this particular little section seems to
be wrong to us but you know we'll deal
with it whatever you do but it's just
the list itself seems kind of weird
because there's plenty of stuff about
land and building and so on that we
regulate
that's not here
thank you Mr chair questions for
representative McGuire
thank you very much okay
I'm sorry hang on representative
that's my bill yes
oh it's on the back page Maybe
oh
okay
all right
uh
uh Sharon uh Foster
John Sean I'm sorry Sean Sean sorry
about that I didn't think I did either
okay okay
yes good afternoon Mr chair and
honorable members
of this committee my name is Sean Foster
not Sharon sorry about that I apologize
um I'm the senior pastor of Crossing
Light Church in Windham and I rise today
to oppose hb63 the current law was just
passed this year it's clear
understandable protects churches in New
Hampshire from undue hardship and
sometimes discrimination we've
personally experienced this kind of
history for the past decade in Windham
in 2003 we were denied property tax
exemption and had to spend tens of
thousands of dollars and at that point
we're a very small Church
um to sue the town and receive the
exemption that we deserved these types
of situations have continued until more
recently the church had to spend tens of
thousands of dollars to gain permission
to erect a tent for our work weekly
services and programming we were charged
fees and asked to go through processes
that no other business or organization
had to do
we had to submit administrative appeal
to the zoning board against those
officials who are supposed to be there
to help and guide us
the assault was so incredulous that
residents outside of our church as well
as a building official from Manchester
came alongside to advocate for us
Crossing Life Church of the church that
spends a lot of effort to support and
strengthen our community and the
surrounding communities with its
programs and resources we offer weekly
events for children youth elderly
regardless of whether they attend our
church or not we allow other community
groups to use our property like the Boys
and Girls Scouts and schools in the area
use our property and Facilities we offer
daycare and Academy free holiday events
like Pumpkin Fest and Christmas at the
Crossing we offer an agricultural
mentoring program for Children and Youth
in a community garden in partnership
with the town free of charge we want to
spend our time and energy serving as a
resource in Windham and the surrounding
communities and not fighting against
undue hardships and clear discrimination
I really appreciate your time today and
I ask that you oppose hb63 and allow the
current law that protects us to remain
in effect
questions for this Witness
representative
thank you for coming here today pastor a
question for you are you in opposition
to the proposed amendment which uh
representative Mooney had just recently
presented I'm not sure if you've gotten
to see a copy of that yet or not I did
yeah I I am I am opposing it because of
introducing more ability to the towns to
regulate your activity outside of the
regulation of State Des building
setbacks Heights building codes
Electrical Plumbing code
because it allows uh
like a discretionary determination
that's
they can just request things because
they want to request it
thank you even building design like we
don't want like wood siding we want
brick
which is more cost
other questions for this Witness
thank you very much thank you
um
oh I'm sorry Dan representative Hayes
my Heinz I'm sorry that's Heinz uh thank
you uh chair uh danheim's representing
Bedford
um I'll just uh say kind of appalled
that this happened in Bedford where they
treat religions differently I think
that's entirely offensive to the
Constitution I don't know how in any
world that survives uh Viewpoint
discrimination I think it's laughable
but
um that's why we need laws like this um
to clarify so um I should have led with
that I do oppose the original language
of this bill I think existing law is
great actually protects towns and uh or
protects some religious freedom and I
think this bill I'm not sure the intent
of it but I think it does the complete
opposite I think if this bill we're
enacted it just doesn't do anything I
think it just sort of recites or makes
worse existing law
um as a attorney Tierney pointed out I
think the my main problem is based
solely on the religious nature I don't
think towns are usually blatant enough
to say we're not gonna let you do this
because you're a church but sometimes
they do so I just expect it would be
smarter about going about the
regulations to limit churches in regards
to paragraph two one of my concerns is
it seems like the legislature is trying
to define a type of standard and in
looking at it I think they somehow went
between height and scrutiny or
intermediate scrutiny and strict
scrutiny so the difference obviously
strict scrutiny from my point would be
the best because generally statutes a
lot less likely to be upheld but thing
missing from strict scrutiny is narrowly
tailored so it's not actually super
experience so I just suggest that if you
want to keep protecting religious
freedom that existing law is good and
this does the opposite in regards to
representative Mooney's amendment I
didn't hear anything particularly bad
about that I certainly support that much
more than this existing
um bill I don't think I have anything
further
questions for this Witness
thank you very much sir actually none
and
Mr gries
naturally sorry about that thank you Mr
chair Nate Graves for the municipal
Association glad to be back here
um so I had a couple handouts for you I
had some written testimony that
um explained kind of the origins of this
bill as well as a second document with a
purple tab on it to direct you to the
correct page so over the summer nhma
spent time with the Bureau of economic
Affairs office of Planning and
Development they're the state agency
that provides
uh guidance to local planning zoning
boards they're formerly known as OSI or
the office strategic initiatives and
they publish some important documents
like planning planning hand planning
handbook and the zoning handbook which
are used by planning boards and zoning
boards throughout the state
um and we spent time with them to
try to figure out how to implement the
new law how what what advice do we give
cities and towns about how this
functions and how to implement it at the
local level
and it was problematic and so that's
Illustrated in the guidance document
with the purple tab
so looking at
um
existing law that applied to local land
use boards and local land use
regulations prior to the enactment of
the law last year there are a couple of
relevant
um
pieces of well law that that we thought
made sense to put into statute because
they weren't currently in statute and
that was as previously mentioned that
the Church of lucamai Babylon High
versus halaya from 1993 and I apologize
for butchering that name that's that's
the U.S Supreme Court precedent
um and that's that's hopefully captured
in Roman one here in the original
legislation and it simply says that you
can't have a land use regulation that or
zoning ordinance essentially says you
can't build churches
um you just can't do that that is
unconstitutional
um and then section two was supposed to
capture
um the application of relupa the
religious land use and institutional
persons Act of 2000 and clarify that
that does apply in New Hampshire so that
was the
um that were the main points of the bill
that the original bill that you see in
front of you
um and to that extent
um I would not be in favor
representative Mooney's um Amendment
simply because it preserves the original
language of the bill
um as as my handout illustrates we
identified some concerns with that
um
and it's a bit confusing how that is is
supposed to be implemented because even
though there's only a short list of
things that towns can look at
there are other things not captured
within the typical
um zoning areas that they may also look
at when
some sort of structure or application
for a structure comes forward for
religious use
um so while it's pretty clear from the
existing law they can't look at things
like lighting signs noise Etc
they can look at things like building
fire codes driveway regulations other
areas that aren't necessarily falling
under existing zoning ordinances but
they are still land use statutes
uh and we we were concerned that this
would trip up municipalities that they
would get in trouble because the uh
because they were unclear of how to
apply the law and so basically the
advice that we created in conjunction
with Bea this summer was call your call
your lawyer and have them help you
um and
really that's because it wasn't quite
clear how to apply something like a
primarily religious use test
um it's possible There's A time test so
how long is a space used for religious
function versus non-religious functions
so I know one of the previous speakers
talked about using the space for the Boy
Scouts the Girl Scouts Etc
those aren't typically religious groups
I mean they're non-profit groups that
exist and they do things throughout the
communities and those typically aren't
considered religious and we didn't want
municipalities to have to look at well
how much time are the Boy Scouts there
versus how much time is you know the
pastor they're giving service that
doesn't seem like a good solution we
also didn't want to have them have to
use a space test because that that would
be a problem as well because you have
some religious structures that then have
a large parking lot surrounding them in
fact most of the land or the lot might
actually be the parking lot it might be
Woods it might be stuff that isn't used
for
some sort of religious purpose so again
you're not accomplishing the goal of the
legislation which is to protect
religious
um activities on specific Parcels so
that's really the basis of
of my uh testimony and I see some
confused looks out there I'm happy to
take any questions that anyone has
questions for this Witness
thank you very much sir thank you for
your time
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on hb63
seeing none I'll close the hearing on
that and we will turn to our last bill
of the day that uh I have to say both
the ranking member and myself forgot
forgot was here it's uh HB 256.
um
and let me uh find that and pull it out
56 yeah I've got it here we go uh
so it's
all right um so I'm I'm gonna represent
I'm going to uh recognize representative
McGuire uh to testify as the sponsor of
the Bill thank you Mr chairman members
of the committee once again I'm Dan
McGuire uh representing Epsom so uh this
bill is based on an incident that
happened to me so I'm gonna have to tell
you an anecdote of what happened to me
and then I'm going to have to convince
you that uh maybe it can happen to other
people and and therefore we should pass
this bill
so I'm the chair of our local Republican
Town committee and
um prior to the primary so last August
we wanted to have an event where we uh
have primary voters and primary
candidates get together and meet
and my town has a park and in the park
is a large Pavilion with a roof and
about two dozen picnic tables underneath
and a small restroom nearby and we you
can go to the town office and rent this
Pavilion or you can rent the whole park
if you wanted to but I we only wanted
the Pavilion and there's a certain fee
for doing that you have to have one
day's worth of insurance and so on
there's certain restrictions but you
also have to tell them what are you
using it for okay so I wrote down
meeting of Republicans right and
um so it was denied
based on the fact that we don't allow
political activities in this location
okay which to me is crazy because you
know that's like anti-free speech and
that sort of stuff and
um and it's also sort of silly because
in this particular Park is where we hold
our old home Day activities and both the
Republicans and the Democrats have had
booths every year for who knows how long
so there are political activities going
on in this location right in this park
just not on that Pavilion on that
particular day Etc and also our town is
somewhat inconsistent because we also
have a library and the library has a
community room and that room
um is used regularly by democrats for
their you know monthly meetings or
whatever no charge no insurance no
nothing and I and I could use that room
too if I wanted to I just preferred in
this particular case to want to use the
Pavilion so
um so it seems to me I could probably
get an attorney and and write a letter
or Sue or something but since I'm a
legislator
um you know it's like you have a hammer
and you every problem looks like a nail
um I write legislation right to try to
solve this problem and I think what
would happen if you if we were able to
pass this is I could go to the committee
that deals with the park and say look
RSA 155 39e says you can't discriminate
based on political activity and
um therefore they would in the future if
I wanted to do the same thing they would
let me use let me rent it
um so I my guess is it's because why I
had the problem is because the park is
kind of under control of a particular
committee and and that committee doesn't
know any better right and and
um it'd be a lot easier rather than go
to them with some sort of argument well
you know this is a First Amendment case
and you can't you can't discriminate Etc
it'd be easier if I had a specific a
very specific thing okay in Parks you
can't discriminate and and
um that would solve this problem and I
think it's it's unlikely with 200 and
however many towns that I'm the only one
and my town is the only one that might
think to do this right or might have
this kind of a problem so so
um you know just because I don't know of
others
it's hard for me to believe this kind of
problem can't come up in the future it
can't happen to anybody else and so on
certainly it could happen to other
people in my town but but
um anyways so uh it's a very simple bill
it to me it's like let's pass motherhood
and apple pie
um but it would help me out and and I
think possibly others who run into the
same sort of problem thank you Mr
chairman sure uh questions for
representative representative Perez
thank you for this bill
we have a very similar problem so you
are not alone
what happened to us is that they just
decided to change the innate the use of
the we have a community
room called a community room
we wanted to have our LSR meetings there
um so they decided that well we're just
not going to let anybody use it nicely
so um there's a longer story to it but
you don't need to know the whole thing
so I it is happening in other places
um we thank the Lord for churches
because they have allowed us to use
their facility but a
um I feel that we are our taxes are
paying for these rooms so um I support
you 100 You are not alone thank you well
I didn't hear a question but but you're
welcome
other question uh representative
yeah just on the on the on the language
in the bill about discrimination I think
you had said there's another facility
used by the other party in your town
um that's not being charged but that you
also wouldn't be charged if you use that
facility
would the same apply if that other group
tried to use the facility that that you
were hoping to use and in other words is
there a discrimination right I
understand what you're saying so right
the Discrimination is on the type of use
right the fact that it's a political
use right not the fact that it's
Republicans Or democrats so so uh
anyways yes I think if the Democrats
wanted to have a picnic in this Pavilion
they would not be allowed just like we
were not allowed yes
uh but but I think that that should be
prohibited because because it's its use
of public facilities and they're
discriminating based on what we're going
to talk about in that while while we're
using those public facilities right
isn't that discrimination against speech
right that's just quick so so
essentially it was because they made the
statement it's not that they require
insurance or a fee it was that they made
the statement that they didn't want you
so absolutely if you had made the
payment and the and taken the insurance
you would have been allowed to use that
no no no okay yeah so I I mentioned that
just because
it seems weird to me anyways but you're
right that part is irrelevant
the the fee and the and the cost and all
that you know what I mean I I don't
really object I was willing to pay those
things but but it's the it's the fact
that certain speeches a certain talk is
not allowed in this location right
that's the key of this right
representative Smith
thank you Mr chair it's always a
pleasure to see you
um
this morning we heard House Bill 164
relative to prohibiting towns from
criminalizing the right to peacefully
and orderly Assemble
this had to do with a little kerfuffle
that happened in new fields
Yule I'm sure enough to what I'm
referring did it somehow involve the
governor location yeah okay thank you
foreign
is this not somewhat the same problem
well maybe maybe slightly although
here we're really talking about
people reserving Town
locations right I mean Parks
Community buildings
um things like that that are
for a particular activity right I mean
if I I suppose if somebody you know
wanted to block off a street and have
some kind of parade or something like
that there might be a parade permit
involved and and so that's kind of what
I had in mind with this
um yours sounds like the example you
just talked about sounded like it was
more about a spontaneous
sort of a thing and and maybe it's a
little different in that way
there's a point yeah it wasn't
spontaneous in that it was planned
people knew it was going to happen
um it was
um on uh
a street a public Street sidewalk
walkway and
um
by the same token
there are laws which prohibit people
from
Gathering near particular sites that may
or may not be publicly owned but
privately owed
um where they're not permitted to to
congregate
um and I'm just a little nervous for
someone
like me who believes in Free Speech
every place
with rare exceptions
um
if we're talking about a slippery slope
here somehow
well thank you for the question
representative I'm not sure if you're
asking me if the Two Bills should be
combined or
you know since I'm not that familiar
with the other Bill maybe I can't really
comment
I guess I'm just troubled by
use our powers as legislators
to
um
solve a more common problem it's like
you know the person without sight
asked to describe an elephant and
depending upon where the person is I'm
sorry I shouldn't have said elephant
donkey
but depending upon where they are
there's a donkey they're going to
describe something very different and
I just because we're a legislator
doesn't mean we should be passing bills
all the time I guess is my concern okay
okay thank you other question uh
representative Tripp
ing
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question uh
very interesting problem
uh what I
what I find extremely interesting is uh
it sounds like you have a Town Fair
occasionally old home day and you have
boosts
and uh you have
Democratic booths and you have
Republican votes
and you're both on Town property
and uh this shouldn't be permitted
you know uh it it clearly sounds like
you you ran into someone that isn't
uh
isn't aware of past practices
you know and and it
because you probably use this this uh
Pavilion before
and uh something caught their eye and
and they decided it wasn't permitted now
this is uh
well all right thank you for the
question representative but
in fact I have many years ago used the
Pavilion for a very similar purpose all
right but I think what happened was a
different
group of people became in charge of the
use of the park not that they're
unfamiliar with old home day of course
they are but
um but they decided to make up a set of
rules and they decided to you know write
their rules however they wanted to you
know they think well we're in charge of
the park we can write the rules however
we feel and so one of they decided to
write
no political activities in the park you
know because they thought it was a good
idea kind of thing you know what I mean
it's it's it's just what they decided to
do is what happened and it was obviously
different than the group that same group
who existed in the past and so on so
yes follow-up but that's that's
you said that much better than I did
okay because I was trying to say that
you know and uh
what it seems is that uh you have a
local problem not a Statewide problem
and I do agree that legislators tend to
see changing laws is the solution to
everything you know so that's uh
I'm gonna have to say that you should
probably talk to who's ever in charge of
the park and not submit a bill
representative Manos I think you had a
question
thank you Mr chairman
um and thank you for for being here I
wanted to ask about commercial speech
and commercial use and your bill to me
seems to be overly Broad in that it
doesn't appear to me that it would give
the town the ability to exclude
commercial use
um or commercial commercial use of the
public space that you're seeking to use
um thank you for the question
representative
um in my particular case
on the same day we were going to have
our event there was another event which
was commercial going on in the different
part of the park where they had rented
it for selling crafts all right so so
yes I think
um if if in general somebody wants to
use it for some other purpose and that
purpose is commercial
um
I think they should be allowed you know
what I mean so yeah other questions for
this witness yes representative uh yeah
so I building on what uh representative
Smith was asking about about a previous
case
um the one involving the governor's
space
um one of the things that came up in
that was essentially that it never the
the there was a court case but it never
really reached or or there was there was
uh charges brought but it never really
reached its conclusion because the
charges were all dropped so it never
made its way through the court system to
figure out whether or not the the
Constitutional guarantee would have
prohibited that to begin with I'm
wondering if this isn't maybe the same
situation because essentially the right
to assemble sort of does guarantee what
you're asking I think
um
and so you said you would have had to go
through the whole process of suing the
town or something along those lines I'm
wondering if this were to be in place
wouldn't you theoretically still have to
do that and does this actually add
anything or or could if you had brought
that to the town as either a lawsuit or
something along those lines and it made
its way up uh is it possible that the
existing constitutional guarantee on
assembly would have would have been
sufficient thank you for the question
representative so I do think that
had I gone to had had I or will I you
know if I were to go to court
I would Prevail all right and and
therefore you know the problem would be
solved in that way but it would be very
expensive and and you know you
understand why I don't want to do that
right I mean suing my own town it's
crazy right but
I do think that this will solve the
problem in the sense that
um I will go to either the selectman or
the group of people that run the park
and I will say you denied me so we put
in I asked the legislature to please add
this this little non-discriminatory
section they did so and so this clearly
covers the situation and you should
remove the the Restriction from your
application form that says you know you
can't no political activity allowed
right so so I don't think they're
unreasonable people or something like
that I just think they think they have
control like it was their own you know
sort of like it was they owned the park
and they and they didn't want this to
happen there therefore they can do
things right and and and they don't
really see it as
um it's public property and therefore
there's there's
non-discriminatory aspects to it you
know so other questions yes
representative page one one question and
I apologize for the late hour but so
let's say the legislature did pass this
and you were able to go to town hall to
Epsom and say look here's the statute
and their response was well we didn't
unlawfully discriminate we said the
Democrats couldn't come either to the
Pavilion what would be your remedy yeah
so again thank you for the question I
probably would
have to go to court and Etc right but I
like I said I I find I think that's very
unlikely
other question representative
so just to clarify this is not
that they're not saying that you can't
use public property that you can go on
to for any purpose it's
Municipal property that you're actually
renting for a specific purpose and
you're giving like a fee agreement to
rent it and so it wouldn't be public
property that anybody could just walk on
to to use anyways because you have to
rent it for that purpose is that correct
thank you for the question
yes in the sense that
um our town wants to have insurance and
and charge for using this particular
thing and presumably if we simply went
there and had a picnic and it was
sizable enough they would chase us away
I mean
but I don't
but it well yeah so I so yes I mean this
is this is public property
um they use it for public events all the
time old home day being one
um but when when individuals or groups
want to use it then there's a form and
there's a charge and you know all that
sort of stuff
exchange for this Witness
so
um I've seen that I I do have two
questions uh representative Maguire the
first question I have is and this is
this happens
um uh a lot you you put the word
unlawfully in paragraph one or Roman
numeral one
and I wonder
I guess what I'm really concerned about
is it says no municipality shall
unlawfully discriminate well
it's only I mean that's that's it's
unlocked unlawfully doesn't refer to
something else it refers to this law is
what makes it unlawful right I mean it's
not something else yes thank you very
much for the question Mr chairman so I
asked the drafter exactly that because I
I thought we should take out the word
unlawfully and and shall not
discriminate right and the drafter said
that
uh somehow that that
it's it's this is kind of a known word
and if he took that out he would have to
say shall not discriminate on a
religious basis or or a political basis
or this basis or that basis all the all
the the giant list of things you can't
discriminate against so so personally I
think you don't need that word all right
but the drafter thinks you do so that's
that's the way we ended you know and I
felt like they knew better than I did so
if you think you know and obviously you
know your committee is just as
familiar with with this kind of law as
the drafter I think so I would be with
you and say take it out but it's up to
you the other question I have and it
sort of I think goes along at least a
little bit to what what representative
Manos was saying is this if the way I'm
concerned about the broadness of the
wording so
um
if you
um so it says let's let's assume we did
take out the word municip unlawfully so
no municipality shall discriminate
against any individual or group in the
use of of a municipal facility on the
basis of the individual individuals or
groups speech or purpose
so
I guess what I'm I'm concerned about is
what if
what if a group says
we want to
we want to walk down Main Street in the
in your town you know in the middle of
the road on Monday morning at rush hour
um and to you know for political reason
or whatever for whatever reason to
advertise Snickers and that's what they
um would
would the
would the town be required to allow that
because it because the under definition
of Municipal Municipal facility under
two it says that um
um I see you're objecting to the word
purpose
I guess so thank you Mr chairman so so
what you're saying is I understand so
the beach is the to me the key word here
um purpose
yeah I mean
you want to sure I I would agree you
can't block traffic right or something
like that right I mean it's not what's
happening to us is it's a normal use of
a normal thing and we're being
discriminated against
based on what we want to say in that
location right and so to me the speech
is the key part of that
um and and if you want to eliminate
purpose I would think it's okay but
again the drafter right so you know what
I'm really wondering is wouldn't it be
better if the language said something
like I mean to be more more direct and
sort of say no municipality
shall prohibit
the use of facilities
for political rallies if the facilities
are allowed to be used for other for
other purposes that you know involve
similar size uh activity or I'm not sure
exactly but in other words so there
can't be any discrimination against
the purpose of a political rally versus
some non-political
activity yes thank you Mr chairman so
that would certainly I would think that
that would solve my problem
um I thought that writing it in a
slightly more General way could
potentially solve other potential
problems right so so that's why we did
it this way so it's really up to you
that's fine representative Schmidt
I know everybody wants to go home I
understand that and but
representative who
who appoints or elects the park board
whatever the title is
I I believe it's the selectman select me
has the thought occurred to you
that you might go to the selectman and
say
this board that you appointed has made a
decision which really doesn't hang
together
and how do you think we can address this
problem in the wonderful town of Epsom
without having
to create new law yeah thank thank you
for the question and essentially I've
done that I've talked to one to one
selectman and it didn't really get
um a satisfaction but
um because of
maybe because of relationships and other
stuff between the the individuals right
so
um but I could try harder I mean sure
yeah
representative kuta
so I have another question just about
the language so I know for example in my
town because you're saying regardless of
purpose in my town if your purpose is
non-alcoholic for example they don't
require Insurance however if you plan on
serving alcohol at the event then you
would have to have insurance and so
it is a little bit
and I don't want to say discriminatory
but it kind of is like in that depending
on the purpose of the event there's
different requirements for the event and
I feel like this would kind of say no
you can't do that thank you for the
question representative and I have a
feeling that this is what you're the
kind of things you're bringing up is why
the drafts are put in the word
unlawfully
because
all those kind of discriminations
there's nothing unlawful about them
right but discriminating on the basis of
religion and speech and
you know racism and all this kind of
stuff those are unlawful discriminations
and so I think that's what the drafter
had in mind when they wrote it this way
thing any other questions for uh yes uh
representative Stapleton
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question I thought I'd chime in here
so everybody knows I at least have a
voice
um
purpose is too broad creates problems if
you put the word political purpose in
front of it it might clarify it but also
make some other problems what about that
well thank you for the question
representative again I I agree with you
that that would make it solve my
particular one example but it it seems
to me I could probably think of other
other examples that
um
people are being could be discriminated
against and and they're non-political
right
um so I don't know maybe uh
I don't know if somebody wanted to have
a girls event maybe instead of a boys
and exclude boys or something
um
there might be other other kinds of
discrimination that's that's not
political right
other questions
thank you very much representative thank
you Mr chairman is there anyone else who
uh desires to uh testify on HB 256.
seeing none I will close the here
I want you to understand I am I well you
know what let me just ask I am not a
glutton I want you to understand that
and please don't please don't attack me
I just want to raise one issue it
appeared that representative Smith and
myself were of the same view that one
particular bill could be exact now but
given the hour my suggestion would be
that we not do that members have left
right right so that's you yeah no no no
okay right right
others would have liked to have left
so so I will entertain a motion to
adjourn
all right all in favor
aye any opposed or
get me down
again
yeah
hey Dave